DOCTOR QUIRK NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA.
BRO [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS RAY.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER WICKS WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS.
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO PLEASE STAND. FOR THE OPENING
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA ROBERT OCEAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
HOW CAN I BE HAPPY?
THIS IS THE QUESTION WE ALL
WONDER AT TIMES.
EVERY TRUE SPIRITUAL TRADITION
TRIES TO TEACH US TO DISCOVERED
THERE ARE REAL HAPPINESS.
EMERGES NATURALLY IN WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO TRANSCEND ARE SELF
CENTERED MINE.
THIS IS THE MIND THAT COMES TO
CONCLUSIONS OF GOOD OR BAD RIGHT
OR WRONG.
THIS IS THE SEGREGATING
CALCULATING MINE THE JUDGES WHO
IS IN AND WHO IS OUT.
AS IN MASTER ONCE DREW A CIRCLE
IN THE GROUND WITH HIS STAFF.
THEN HE TOLD HIS DISCIPLES.
IF YOU STAND INSIDE THE CIRCLE I
WILL HIT YOU WITH MY STAFF.
IF YOU STAND OUTSIDE THE CIRCLE.
I WILL HIT YOU WITH MY STAFF.
THE STUDENTS WERE PERPLEXED.
EVEN STANDING ON THE LINE OF THE
CIRCLE WITH AN ACCEPTABLE.
WHAT WERE THEY TO DO?
THE MASTER WAS TRYING TO TEACH
THEM TO TRANSCEND THEIR JUDGING
MINDS.
THE DISCIPLES WERE ALLOWING A
CIRCLE DROWN DRAWN ON THE GROUND
PREVENT THEM FROM LIVING WITHOUT
JUDGMENT.
INSTEAD THEY CONTINUE TO ASSESS.
THIS IS INSIDE AND THAT IS
OUTSIDE SO WHAT IS RIGHT AND
WHAT IS WRONG.
THIS IS THEN CALL ONE ELIMINATES
THE NEED FOR US TO LET GO OF OUR
CRITICAL MINDS.
AND EXPERIENCE THE ONENESS BE ON
ARBITRARY LINES THE SEGREGATION.
LINES THEY IMPLY.
WHO IS IN IN WHO IS OUT?
WHEN WE TRANSCEND THE LINES IN
THERE YEARS BETWEEN SELF AND
OTHERS?
FEELINGS OF CONTENTMENT WILL
NATURALLY EMERGE AS WE FEEL
DEEPLY OUR SHARED HUMANITY.
THE PERSON SPIRIT POET RUMI.
AND THIS IS A MASTER WOULD SAY.
BEYOND RIGHT AND WRONG.
BEYOND INSIDE AND OUTSIDE.
THERE IS A PLACE OF ONENESS OF
ALL HUMANITY.
WE WILL MEET YOU THERE.
NORMALLY NUMBER TWO WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER CHAO.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MAY TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN THE
SELLING MEDICINE AND I AM ON A
BRAND DALY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST
DISTRICT PRESIDING.
CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK READING CLICK HAVE LAMB
WAS READING.
THE LONGER PLACED ON THE MORNING
ROLL CALL MR TING MOVES MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
EXHORTATIONS EMITATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY FOR
FUNERAL DEATH IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO.
GARCIA
.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ITEM IS TO BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
FIRST.
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THAT IS AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AS ON THE BALL LEVIN TWENTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
DOCTOR WOULD ON THE MEN'S THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF MR COOLEY I RISE
TODAY REVIVED PRESENT AMENDMENTS
TO AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
REGARDING CERTIFICATION OF
ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICERS.
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK
ADDRESSING CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY AND
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS THEY ROOM THEY WILL
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION THE BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AT
YOUR EYE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR THE BILLS OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO TAKE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER. TEN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
TEN AB. SEVEN OH SEVEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MEMBERS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
OH SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
FAMILY MEMBER KALRA.
MISTER KALRA NAY MEMONS THANK
YOU SPEAKER OF THESE MOMENTS
WILL INCREASE SOCCER VALUE
WATERS FORMAL BIDDING THRESHOLD
425-000-50000.
AND CLOSE BY THE USE OF THE
AGENCIES PORTS ACCOUNT TO
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ABOUT OUR SPONSOR IN
OPPOSITION -- IN THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISS KALRA WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THAT BILL IS OUTSPRINTED
BACK ON FILE.
AND NOW MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
JUMP TO FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR THIS IS AB. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS AT SOME LEVEL
FOURTEEN FORTY WITH AMENDMENTS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE THE
SHOW OF IT ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MOMENTS ON A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY REMOVE.
ALL OPPOSITION AND CLARIFY THE
ROLE OF THE VISION OF OIL GAS
AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION ARE
SUCKED OUT FOR A VOTE.
FAMOUS LIVING WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE MOMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE. TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY ONE TO ALLOW MISTER KALRA.
TO TAKE UP.
AB SEVEN SEVEN SIX MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY ONE AB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY
MISTER KALRA.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
BY SONY MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION DATA
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR THE OPTION PRESENT AB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX IT'S A MUCH BE A
MEASURE TO HELP ASSURE THAT HAS
WE HOPEFULLY -- MOVED TO EXPAND
ACCESS EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AND ALIGN DATA SYSTEM FOR
CHILDREN IN THESE PROGRAMS.
IN SO DOING A. B. SEVEN SEVENTY
SIX WOULD BUILD UPON THE STATE'S
EXISTING DATA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HELP TO ADDRESS THE RIGHTNESS
GOT MANY CHILDREN DISPLAY --
WHEN ENTERING KINDERGARTEN IT
WOULD DO THIS BY ENABLING
SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS TO BE
BETTER INFORMED ABOUT HOW TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN?
AND TO BETTER UNDERSTAND A
CHILD'S PATH FROM BIRTH TO ENTRY
INTO THEIR K. TWELVE EDUCATIONAL
CAREER THIS BILL RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN HIS POLICY
AND FISCALLY HEARINGS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THINGS KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF WHO IS OUT OF OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
AND FILE ORDER FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO IS AB SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN GIPSON COVERAGE.
AS LEGAL SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GIPSON AND
EXPLAIN TO ELECTIONS MISTER
GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT -- A. B.
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN WHICH WOULD
HELP PREVENT -- INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAILS --
RECEIVING INFORMATION OR VOTER
REGISTRATION AND VOTER RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA CARS RATES OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ITS
JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF OF THEM
HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED.
OR ON OUR OUR ON SENTENCE DUE TO
EITHER MISS INFORMATION OR A
LACK OF INFORMATION MEANING.
WHO ARE BEHIND BARS DO NOT KNOW
THAT THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES STATE AND
LOCAL JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ASSIST?
AND VOTER REGISTRATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AGED.
WHO ARE WHO ARE OF AGE AND ARE
NOT SERVING A FELONY SENTENCE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT
I VOTE?
ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF OUT.
THIS TAKES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF A CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
AB EIGHT OH THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH THREE
PRICE ONLY MEMBER GETS IN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY SHE GIPSON YOU MAY GET
OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB -- EIGHT OH
THREE WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE
OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH A PEER SUPPORT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE WITH IN
THIS CDC OUR TASKING.
THE KERR THE CREATION AND
UPDATING OF A STANDARDIZED
STATEWIDE POLICY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PEER SUPPORT.
PEER SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE ON IT ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT OH THREE THANKS GIPSON SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE AND THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE IS AB.
EIGHT FIFTY TWO CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY WILL A FIFTY TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
MS BURKE THANK YOU -- MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FIFTY TWO AUTHORIZES A
SUPER INTENDANT OF INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION TO REVIEW
CONTENT SANDERS AND TO GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION ON UPDATES TO
THOSE STANDARDS SHOULD UPDATES
BE NECESSARY.
BY ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR
THE PERIODIC REVIEW AND UPDATING
A STATE CONTENT STANDARDS AB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO INTEREST
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE BETTER
PREPARED FOR LIFE.
BIANCHI THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
ARE.
ARE PRESENTED WITH THE MOST
RELEVANT INFORMATION WHEN
LEARNING A SUBJECT -- AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO SPONSORED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS BURKE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SIXTY FOUR
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX IS A. B. NINE OH
SEVEN BY MISTER GRAYSON COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH SEVEN BY
SOMETHING NUMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO THREATS.
WHICH REYES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
WANT TO SCHOOL OR PLACE OF
WORSHIP IS THREATENED IT CAN
DISRUPT LIVES IN COSTS FOR YOUR
FOR EVERYONE AND ANYONE WHO
SPENDS THEIR TIME THERE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IT IS A CRIME
TO THREATEN TO COMMIT AN ACT
THAT WILL RESULT IN DEATH OR
GREAT BODILY INJURY TO ANOTHER
PERSON AND CAUSES THAT PERSON TO
BE SUSTAINED -- TO BE INSISTING
FEAR FOR THEIR SAFETY OR FOR THE
IMMEDIATE OF FOR THE SAFETY OF
THEIR MEDIA FAMILY.
HOWEVER IN A CAR IN OUR CURRENT
CLIMATE THREATS AREN'T JUST
BEING MADE AGAINST INDIVIDUALS
BUT INSTEAD AGAINST ENTIRE
SCHOOLS SYNAGOGUES MOSQUES AND
CHURCHES.
AB NINE HUNDRED SEVEN WILL
UPDATE OUR PENAL CODE TO BETTER
REFLECT THE INTENT OUR CURRENT
LAW AND INSURER OF OUR CURRENT
LAW AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE
TREATING THREATS AGAINST OUR
SCHOOLS.
AND PLACES OF WORSHIP WITH THE
GRAVITY THAT THEY DEMAND I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I'VE.
THINGS GRAYSON SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
THE CORPORAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE
[inaudible]
THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY AT THE END OF THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
[inaudible]
AB. THREE NINETY TWO DOCTOR
WEBER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY TO
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY THE PEACE OFFICERS.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY
AB THREE NINE TWO THE CALIFORNIA
ACT TO SAVE LIVES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RAISE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL STANDARD FOR
WHEN POLICE CAN USE DEADLY FORCE.
TO MATCH BEST PRACTICES ALREADY
IN PLACE AT SOME DEPARTMENTS AND
THAT WE KNOW WORK TO KEEP BOTH
OFFICERS AND PUBLIC SAFE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
HAVE CLARIFIED ITS MEANING AND
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM NUMEROUS
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUPS INCLUDING.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS PORAC
THE CALIFORNIA STATE WHY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND SEVERAL OTHER
STATEWIDE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS.
I LIKE TO NOT AS LONG FOR TWO
GROUPS AND RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
AND THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY WORK BECAUSE
OF THE BUY IN FROM THE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO'S
WORKED SO VERY HARD ON GETTING
US TO THIS POINT.
I WANT TO THANK THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS SPEAKER
RENDON AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
DEVOTING TIME AND SO MUCH ENERGY
INTO THIS ISSUE.
I WANT TO THANK MY JOINT AUTHORS
AND CO AUTHORS TO STAND WITH
FAMILIES ON THIS BILL.
I WANT TO THANK THE CO SPONSORS
WHO HAVE WORKED SO TIRELESSLY
FOR SO LONG ON THIS ISSUE.
AND LASTLY MOST IMPORTANTLY I
WANT TO UPLIFT THE ADVOCACY OF
FAMILIES THAT HAVE TURNED THE
TRAGEDIES THEY HAVE INDOOR IT UP
INTO A MOVEMENT. TO ENSURE THE
OTHER FAMILIES EXPERIENCE DO NOT
EXPERIENCE THE LOSS OF THEIR
LOVED ONES.
POLICE OFFICERS SHOULD NEVER
TAKE A HUMAN LIFE WHEN THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES.
AB THREE NINE TWO IS ABOUT
PREVENTING UNNECESSARY DEATHS BY
CLARIFYING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OBLIGATION WHEN MAKING THE
DECISION TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
AB THREE NINE TWO REPLACES THE
CURRENT VAGUE STANDARD THAT
OFFICES CAN USE DEADLY FORCE
WHENEVER REASONABLE STANDARDS%
WITH A HIGHER STANDARD THAT
AUTHORIZES DEADLY FORCE.
ONLY WHEN NECESSARY TO DEFEND
AGAINST AN IMMINENT THREAT OF
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
THIS BILL IS SQUARELY IN LINE
WITH BEST PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS RECOGNIZED BY
ACADEMICS AND EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND IS MODELED AFTER
PRACTICES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
PLACE AT SEVERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THESE STANDARDS ARE KNOWN TO
REDUCE SERIOUS USE OF FORCE
WITHOUT HAVING ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OFFICER SAFETY OR
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL ALL
AGENCIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
UPDATE THEIR POLICIES TO INCLUDE
THESE BEST PRACTICES AND IT SURE
THAT OFFICERS ARE TRAINED TO THE
STANDARDS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY OVER
TEN ORGANIZATIONS AND OVER TWO
HUNDRED GROUPS IN SUPPORT.
THE POWER OF POLICE OFFICERS TO
USE DEADLY FORCE IS PROUD
PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITY WE CONFER ON ANY
PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
AND IT MUST BE GUIDED BY THE
GOALS OF SAFEGUARDING ALL HUMAN
LIFE. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I VOTE
FOR AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER MISTER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO A BULLET WHEN
FIRED CANNOT BE CALLED BACK.
ALIVE TAKEN COULD NOT BE
RESTORED.
THAT'S WHY STANDS STRONGLY
BEHIND THE CORE PRINCIPLE OF
THIS BILL.
THAT POLICE ONLY USE DEADLY
FORCE WHEN NECESSARY.
CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS USE
DEADLY FORCE AT A RATE.
FAR HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
AND ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
NEARLY HALF OF THE PEOPLE KILLED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ARE LATINO. FOUR OF THE FIVE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WERE LATINO.
IT ISN'T SURPRISING THAT MANY.
PEOPLE IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY
FEEL THE DISTRESS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP. TO RESTORE THAT
TRUST BETWEEN THESE COMMUNITIES.
BY RAISING THE STANDARD FOR PER
LEASE USE OF LETHAL FORCE FROM
REASONABLE TO NECESSARY.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT GOAL OF POLICING IS TO
PROTECT HUMAN LIFE.
NO MATTER WHOSE LIFE IT IS. TO
THE FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE
IN THE FACE OF OVERWHELMING LOS.
WITHOUT YOUR ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP NONE OF THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE.
MANY THANKS ALSO TO THE
LEADERSHIP ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE.
WE KNOW THE DIFFICULT ISSUES
NEED BOLD LEADERSHIP.
AND A DRIVEN SENSE OF OUR SHARED
WHO HUMANITY.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS ABOUT
LIFE AND DEATH.
AND I ASKED RESPECTFULLY THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN STANDING WHEN THE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES AND VOTE HI AN A. B..
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I STAND TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL --
THREE NINETY TWO BUT I'D LIKE TO
SAY.
THAT AND START OFF BY SAYING
WITH GREAT THANKS AND
APPRECIATION TO AUTHOR FOR HER
TO NOW CITY.
OR HER ARTWORK.
AND HER INCREDIBLE PATIENCE AND
DILIGENCE AND WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES TO BRING RESOLUTION TO
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT RESPECT FOR
THE MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO IS
WILLING AND ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
WITH ALL PARTIES. TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT WHILE MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY OF HER BILL.
AB THREE NINETY TWO MAKES
EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER.
AB THREE NINETY TO PULL
SUCCESSFUL USE OF FORCE POLICIES.
FROM AGENCIES THAT HAVE ADOPTED
THEM AND PUTS THESE BEST
PRACTICES IN THE STATE LAW.
CHANGING THE USE OF FORCE
STANDARD IN CALIFORNIA WILL
CHANGE THE WAY OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED TO PURSUE OTHER NON
DEADLY RESOURCES OR TECHNIQUES
WHEN ENGAGING WITH THE PUBLIC.
AND CITIES RESTRICTOR USE OF
FORCE POLICIES POLICE KILL FEWER
PEOPLE WITHOUT ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACT A LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
COMMUNITY SAFETY.
SEATTLE FOR EXAMPLE SO REDUCTION
IN THE NUMBER OF USE OF FORCE
INCIDENTS AFTER ADOPTING.
A USE OF FORCE THAT ARE LIKE THE
ONE IN AB.
THREE NINETY TWO WITHOUT SEEING
ANY NEGATIVE IMPACT ON PUBLIC OR
POLICE SAFETY.
SAN FRANCISCO ALSO SAW SIMILAR
DECLINES AND USE OF FORCE
INCIDENTS.
SAN FRANCISCO PD HASN'T SHOT
ANYONE IN ALMOST A YEAR AFTER
ADOPTING ITS CHANGE IN POLICY.
WE GIVE POLICE OFFERS OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT POWER WE GIVE
IN A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE.
THE POWER TO KILL.
WE WAS MAKE SURE POLICE USE THAT
POWER JUDICIOUSLY WITH RESPECT
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND ONLY WHEN ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
WE MUST ALSO HOLD POLICE
ACCOUNTABLE WHENEVER THEY MISS
USE THAT POWER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING MR MCCARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HOPE
WE CAN ALL SUPPORT THIS A
MEASURE TODAY I THINK IT'S A
FAIR COMPROMISE.
AND REALLY IT'S TIME FOR CHANGE
IT'S TIME FOR CHANGE TO UPDATE
TO MODERNIZE OUR DEADLY FORCE
RULES AFTER NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
YEARS BUT BEFORE WE GET THAT I I
ALSO WANT.
TO SAY I'M A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR
BUT MORE MORE POORLY I'M PROUD
TO JOIN.
OUR OUR LEADER FROM SAN DIEGO
WHO WAS FEARLESS AND DOG GET IN
GETTING US TO THIS POINT SO I
WANT TO THANK.
HER LEADERSHIP.
AND AGAIN WE WE KNOW IT'S TIME%
FOR CHANGE BECAUSE IT WE SEE IT
WITH OUR OWN TWO EYES.
NO TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO WE SAW
THE VIDEO AND LA OF RODNEY KING
AND IT WAS A RARE OPPORTUNITY
WHEN YOU SAW SOMEONE TAKING A
HOME VIDEO.
NOW WE SEE IT WITH DASH CAMS
WITH BODY CAMS FROM CAMERAS FROM
CELL PHONES FROM INDIVIDUALS
FROM STOREFRONTS WE SEE IT WITH
OUR OWN TO RICE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THERE HAS TO BE.
A BETTER WAY.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE
PARSING THE WORDS AS FAR AS
REASONABLE WHEN NECESSARY AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS BECAUSE
OF THIS LAW POLICE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA LIKE WE'RE
DOING RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AFTER STUFF ON CLARK ARE
FOCUSING ON DE ESCALATION
ALTERNATIVE TACTICS TO DO THEIR
JOBS KEEP COMMUNITIES SAFE
[inaudible]
WHILE ALSO.
SAVING LIVES AND WE HAVE MONEY
IN THE STATE BUDGET TO IMPLEMENT
THESE PRACTICES WE ALSO THE
COMPANION BILL WHICH DEALS WITH
THESE EXACT ISSUES SO THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DE ESCALATION.
AND I KNOW THAT 99% OF THE TIME
LAW OFFICERS DO THEIR JOB.
BUT EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE THERE'S
A 1% WEATHER IS NOT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN LOS ANGELES
LAST YEAR AN INDIVIDUAL POLICE
OFFICER SHOT AN INDIVIDUAL.
IN THE BACK A HOMELESS MAN I
BELIEVE IN YOUR DISTRICT.
THE POLICE CHIEF OF THE CITY OF
LA THE SECOND LARGEST CITY IN
AMERICA SAID THE OFFICER SHOULD
BE FIRED.
AND PROSECUTED THE POLICE CHIEFS
AT THIS [inaudible]
RARE OCCURRENCE.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAID I
CAN'T DO IT THE LAW DOESN'T
JUSTIFY THAT SO THERE ARE.
INDIVIDUAL STORIES WE KNOW THAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. FIFTY MILES
DOWN THE ROAD A RANCH RECORD OF
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAD
INDIVIDUAL CORN ON A FREEWAY HAD
A BARRICADE A CAR THE
INDIVIDUALS THROWING ROCKS.
THEY THEY THEY DISCHARGE THE
WEAPON INDIVIDUAL DIED OUR
FORMER POLICE CHIEF OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO DID INVESTIGATION
AND SAID THAT.
THE ACTIVITIES PUT THE PUBLIC AT
RISK IT WAS UNNECESSARY AND
THERE WAS AN ALTERNATIVE WAY OF
GOING ABOUT IT.
BUT AGAIN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SAID.
THE LAW SAYS WE CAN'T HOLD
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS INSTANCE
SO WE DO KNOW THERE ARE RARE
OCCASIONS SO THIS ISN'T ABOUT.
PROSECUTOR LOCKING UP
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DOING THEIR
JOB BUT WHEN THERE IS SOMEBODY
DOES CROSS THE LINE THERE SHOULD
BE ACCOUNTABILITY SO THIS IS
WHAT THIS MEASURE IS.
BRINGS ABOUT MODERNIZATION TO
OUR PRACTICE IS FOCUSED ON DE
ESCALATION AND BRINGS ABOUT
REASONABLE ACCOUNTABILITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY TWO
NOW I WANT TO THANK.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
CHAMPIONING AND FOR LEADING THIS
ENTIRE BODY.
ON THIS VERY -- DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING. FOR THE LAST.
RECENT YEARS YOU KNOW AS A
FORMER PROSECUTOR FOR MAY.
I I APPROACHED.
DOCTOR WEBER EARLY ON YOU KNOW
MY MAIN CONCERN WHICH IS WELL.
WE ALL I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS.
AN URGENT ISSUE THAT -- THAT WE
MUST CONFRONT [inaudible]
AND THAT.
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
BUT MY CONCERN WAS ALWAYS FOR MY
EXPERIENCE AS A PROSECUTOR MIGHT
MY WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
THAT THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
ARE PEOPLE THAT WENT INTO THAT
THAT BECAME LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
HELP THE COMMUNITIES THEY WANT
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITIES AND
THEY WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
AND SO I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE OFFICERS OF GOOD FAITH
[inaudible]
WE'RE NOT [inaudible]
PUNISHED. FOR HAVING TO MAKE THE
OFTEN DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT
THEY HAVE TO MAKE.
IN THE LINE OF DUTY TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO.
DOCTOR WEBER I WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
FOR CHAMPIONING AND ESTABLISHING
ONE OF THE STRONGEST STANDARDS
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT WE WILL
HAVE THROUGH AB.
THREE NINETY TWO WHILE MAKING
SURE.
THAT WE ARE NOT PUNISHING.
OUR MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS OF GOOD FAITH.
GORGEOUS GOING OUT EVERY DAY
TRYING.
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SERVE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI MISS
KOREA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS IF
YOU LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED PLEASE
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES NOW.
MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER COURAGEOUS
POSITION ON THIS BILL I AM PROUD
TO HAVE JOINED.
AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR I'D
LIKE TO JUST SHARE THAT PRIOR TO
JOINING TO THE LEGISLATURE I WAS
WORKING AS A JOURNALIST.
I COVER THE POLICE SHOOTINGS OF
FREDDIE GRAY.
FLANNEL CASTEEL [inaudible]
ALTON STERLING [inaudible]
ERIC GARDNER.
AND TO MERE RICE WHO WAS ONLY.
TWELVE WE MUST SAY THEIR NAMES
AND WE MUST REMEMBER WHO THEY
ARE.
AND THESE ARE JUST A FEW
[inaudible]
OF MANY.
WHAT I SAW AS A JOURNALIST WAS
THE CONTINUOUS VIDEOS PLAYED
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER?
TO THE POINT THAT WE HAVE BECOME
INCREDIBLY DE SENSITIZED AS A
SOCIETY WHEN WE LITERALLY SEE
SOMEONE BEING SHOT.
IN OUR LOCAL NEWS.
THE MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT OF THAT.
TO THE RECEIVER TO THE VIEWER TO
THE FAMILIES.
AND TO THE OFFICERS THEMSELVES.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO MUST
ADDRESS.
I WOULD GO HOME AT NIGHT AND
JUST WANT TO SHUT DOWN.
AND I WASN'T NECESSARILY THE ONE
IMPACTED I JUST HAD TO COVER IT
AND SEE IT OVER AND OVER.
YOUNG KIDS THAT I'VE SPOKEN TO
IN MY COMMUNITY IN THE FIFTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
HAVE SIMILAR FEARS.
YOUNG BOYS OF COLOR IN MY
COMMUNITY.
WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO LIVE AND
THRIVE AND LIVE IN DIGNITY?
AND NOT BE AFRAID.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THEIR OWN FEARS.
ABOUT THE HARSH REALITIES OF THE
JOBS THAT THEY DO.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CIVILIANS MAY NOT NECESSARILY
KNOW WHAT THEY DO EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
BUT I AM THANKFUL THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE TAKEN HAVE
GONE TO THE POINT WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECOGNIZED.
THE IMPORTANT CRITICAL POSITION
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY LIVING IN.
AND TOOK A POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING.
WHICH IS A GREAT BOLD NEW STEP
FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THE NATION.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION PERHAPS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONE THAT WE WILL
VOTE.
IN THIS YEAR.
OR PERHAPS IN MANY YEARS TO COME.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA CAN CERTAINLY
SET THE TONE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE REALITY OF
THIS WORK AND THE IMPACT THAT IT
HAS HAD ON FAMILIES?
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
I HOPE THAT THE CONVERSATION CAN
CONTINUE SO THAT WE COME TO
RESOLUTIONS.
AS TO THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAS
HAD ON FAMILIES.
THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAS ON THE
JOB OF ACTUALLY BEING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
AND HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS JUSTICE.
AND THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDED FOR BOTH SIDES.
IS AVAILABLE.
AND A RESOURCE SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND I'M AN
AYE VOTE AND I AM SO HONORED AND
PROUD TO HAVE JOINED AS A
PRINCIPAL COOPER ON THIS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS CARILLO MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I WAS GOING TO BE A VERY STRONG
NO.
ON AB THREE NINETY TWO AS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED.
BUT I WANT TO SAY TO THE AUTHOR.
THAT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
THE WAY THAT YOU'VE GONE ABOUT
THIS PROCESS -- I I I JOKED WITH
YOU THE OTHER DAY.
THAT.
WE'RE PART OF THE OLD SCHOOL
CAUCUS.
AND I SAY THAT WITH PRIDE
BECAUSE I THINK IN THIS BODY WE
CAN SHOW HOW WE CAN DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY.
THAT -- THAT WE CAN GET OUT OF
OUR SILOS.
ON BOTH SIDES.
AND NOT APPROACH POLICY MAKING
FROM THIS THE STANDPOINT OF MY
WAY OR NO WAY.
IN TRYING TO RAILROAD THROUGH A
POLICY WITHOUT.
GETTING ALL THE INPUT AND YOU
DID THAT I WATCHED YOU WORK
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
MEETING WITH COUNTLESS MEMBERS
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
LISTEN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
[inaudible]
COMMUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT'S VERY LAUDABLE
NEEDS TO BE COMMENDED.
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SPENT A LOT
OF HOURS WORKING THROUGH MANY OF
THESE ISSUES.
AND I AS I THINK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE -- WE CERTAINLY CAN'T
IGNORE WHAT'S GOING ON OUT IN
SOCIETY WE CANNOT IGNORE.
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN TRAGIC
DEATHS OF UNARMED CIVILIANS.
BUT WE ALSO CANNOT IGNORE THAT
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
BEING TARGETED.
AND THERE'S BEEN FAR TOO MANY
OFFICERS.
WITHOUT ANY NOTICE SHOT AND
KILLED TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND WE NEED TO SAY THEIR NAMES.
TO DAVID MOBILE YO.
FROM RED BLUFF [inaudible]
NATALIE CORONA.
FROM OUR BUCKLE [inaudible]
AUSTIN STEPHENS.
THE CHP OFFICER WHO IS JUST
DOING A ROUTINE STOP.
AND WAS SHOT AND KILLED TAKEN
AWAY FROM HIS FAMILY A YOUNG
MOTHER.
IN PALM SPRINGS.
WHO SIMPLY WENT? TO A DOMESTIC
DISTURBANCE CALL.
OFFICERS ARE BEING TARGETED SO I
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION.
DOESN'T PUT OUR OUR OFFICERS
LIVES IN JEOPARDY.
AND I WAS ORIGINALLY DRAFTED IT
DID.
PUTTING THAT NECESSARY STANDARD
IN PLACE.
WAS GOING TO PUT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN JEOPARDY.
AND I WANT TO READ.
FROM THE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL.
I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THE DECISION BY A POLICE BY A
PEACE OFFICER PERMISSION TO READ --
WITHOUT A JUST BIGGER.
THE DECISION THE DECISION BY A
PEACE OFFICER TO USE FORCE SHALL
BE EVALUATED FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A REASONABLE
OFFICER IN THE SAME SITUATION.
BASED ON THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES KNOWN TO OR
PERCEIVED BY THE OFFICER AT THE
TIME.
RATHER THAN WITH THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IT SHOULD NOT BE TO THIRD
PARTIES WHO ARE UNTRAINED.
WHO WERE NOT THERE?
WHO DIDN'T KNOW THE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO SECOND GUESS
WHAT AN OFFICER DOES?
IN THESE HIGHLY DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS.
IT HAS TO BE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A TRAINED
[inaudible]
REASONABLE.
OFFICER AND THE OVERWHELMING
[inaudible]
MAJORITY [inaudible]
SUPERMAJORITY.
OF OUR OFFICERS ARE WELL TRAINED
AND THEY HANDLE THEMSELVES WITH
CIVILIANS.
SAFELY AND THEY DO IT HONORABLY
AND THEY PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
ON A DAILY BASIS.
IN THIS STANDARD RECOGNIZES THAT.
AND THE A COMPANY BILL THAT WILL
COME ENSURES THAT THERE IS
PROPER TRAINING.
THAT WE EXPAND UPON OUR TRAINING.
SO THIS BILL I BELIEVE.
WITH THE COMPROMISES MADE.
STRIKES THE RIGHT STANDARD DO I
LIKE EVERYTHING IN IT.
NO.
BUT THIS IS HOW POLICY SHOULD BE
DONE.
BY SITTING DOWN BY A COMPROMISE.
AND THE AUTHOR LISTEN TO THE THE
VERY LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY WHILE
ALSO TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE FUTURE TRAGEDIES.
LIKE WE HAVE THE STUFF ON CLERK
[inaudible]
AND I RECENTLY SPOKE AT THE UC
DAVIS CAMPUS AND I WAS THERE
BECAUSE I WAS CALLING OUT THE
VICTORY ALL.
OF THE UC DAVIS PROFESSOR.
WHO HAD STATED?
COP SHOULD BE KILLED THIRTY
SACCHI SAID OWNER.
COP SHOULD NOT BE REFORM THEY
SHOULD BE KILLED THIS IS THE
KIND OF RHETORIC THE GOING.
THAT IS CAUSING MORE MORE
DIVISION AND VIOLENCE.
BUT I WAS THERE AND I SAID THIS
VOTE FOLKS I SAID [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
IS.
IS THE HEARTACHE ANY LESS. FOR
STUFF ON CLARK'S MOTHER.
AS IT IS FOR THE MOTHER OF
NATALIE CORONA [inaudible]
NOW.
THEY BOTH OF LOS SOMEONE THAT
THEY'LL NEVER GET BACK.
AND THAT'S WHY I SING COMMITTEE
WE DO SOMETHING THAT DOES
SOMETHING FOR BOTH.
THEY PROTECT BOTH SIDES.
IN A POLICY THAT JUST TRIES TO
PUSH THROUGH AND STEAM STEAM
ROLL THROUGH ONE SIDE OF THE
EQUATION IS NOT A FAIR POLICY IT
IS THE DUTY OF THE LEGISLATOR.
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS JUST
LAWS.
AND SO I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
FOR FORTUNE WHAT I THINK IS A
REASONABLE COMPROMISE.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THAT
PROTECTS THE LIVES OF OFFICERS
AND THE LIVES OF THE PUBLIC
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE WAS GALLAGHER MS GONZALEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THING KILL
ARISES OF HOW CO AUTHOR OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT I
WATCHED -- MY COLLEAGUE AND MY
NEIGHBORING ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
WE WE LITERALLY LIVE A FEW NOT
WET MILE AWAY FROM EACH OTHER --
I'VE SEEN OUR WORK ON THIS FROM
FROM THE DEEPEST PART OF HER
SOUL.
AN ISSUE THAT SO FEW PEOPLE
WOULD TAKE ON I WANT TO BE CLEAR
BECAUSE I HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR PEACE
OFFICERS.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN ONE WAS SHOT
MY DISTRICT WE NEED TO BRIDGE
AFTER -- WE UNDERSTAND WE MOURN
WE PROSECUTE THOSE.
WHO ENGAGE IN THAT BEHAVIOR AND
THIS ISN'T?
THIS BILL ISN'T NECESSARILY
ABOUT BOTH SIDES WE WE DO THAT
TYPE OF HONORING AS WE SHOULD.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT THE
COMMUNITIES WE LIVE IN.
WHEN I FIRST GOT TO LEGISLATURE
USED TO TELL PEOPLE I DIDN'T
HEAR A LOT ABOUT POLICE
BRUTALITY MY DISTRICT AND I
DIDN'T?
I HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE BORDER
PATROL.
I HEARD A LOT ABOUT BORDER
PATROL SHOOTINGS.
BUT OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS IT'S
LIKE THERE'S BEEN SUCH A CHANGE
THAT EVEN AND AND MY COMMUNITY.
WHICH DOESN'T ALWAYS IT SEE THE
REALITY OF BROWN FOLKS BEING THE
SAME SUBJECT OF POLICE BRUTALITY
IS BLACK FOLKS.
THAT HAS CHANGED.
AND WE LIVE IN A COMMUNITY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE IN FEAR IN THE SAME
WAY WE USED TO TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
BEING FEAR NOT CALLING POLICE
BECAUSE POLICE MY CALL
IMMIGRATION.
WE HAVE PEOPLE BEING IF YOU'RE
NOT CALLING POLICE BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID.
THAT THAT PERSON MIGHT GET
SHOCKED.
OR THAT THEY THEMSELVES MIGHT BE
MISTAKEN AND BE SHOT.
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN OVER AND OVER
UNARMED INNOCENT INDIVIDUALS.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE BY POLICE
OFFICERS.
OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS THIS BILL TO
REBUILD THAT TRUST THAT'S
NECESSARY TO KEEP US ALL SAFE.
I THINK DOCTOR WEBER I'M SORRY
MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM ACROSS THE ROAD.
STRUCK THE PERFECT BALANCE.
SHE ADAMANTLY AS PROTECTING A
COMMUNITY THE DESERVES THAT
PROTECTION.
SHE'S PROVIDING A VOICE FOR A
COMMUNITY THAT FOR TOO LONG.
HAS BEEN STIFLED.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE WORKED
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S TRAINING.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
IN THIS BODY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ADEQUATE RESOURCES FOR
THAT TRAINING.
BECAUSE CHANGE DOESN'T HAPPEN
JUST BY LAW.
IT HAS TO HAPPEN BY THE WAY
PEOPLE ARE TAUGHT TO IMPLEMENT
THAT LAW.
SO TODAY I HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FOR THE
HARD WORK -- THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
HAS DONE IT WE DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT WE MEET ALL FEEL SAFE WHEN
WE CALL THE POLICE.
THAT WE MAY ALL HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR PEACE
OFFICERS OF ONE THAT WE BELIEVE.
IT IS IS PURSUING SAFETY FOR ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM.
FAMOUS GONZALEZ MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY
TWO AS A PROP CO AUTHOR.
AND AS THE CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS AN
INCREDIBLE IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARD CHANGING
LAW ENFORCEMENT BEHAVIOR
SPECIFICALLY DO USE OF DEADLY
FORCE AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR CONTINUED ADVOCACY ON THIS
ISSUE AND COMMITMENT TO WORKING
WITH STATE OAK HOLDERS I
APPRECIATE THE WORK IS
STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES WHO
WERE WILLING TO ROLL UP THEIR
SLEEVES.
AND DO THE HARD WORK TO MOVE
THIS ISSUE.
FOR AS I HAVE BEEN IF I HAVE
SAID SINCE COMMITTEE IF WE WANT
TO SEE TRULY IMPACTFUL CHANGE.
WE JUST WE CAN'T JUST CHANGE THE
STANDARDS WE NEED TO ENSURE
THOSE CHANGES ARE IMPLEMENTED BY
COMMITTING RESOURCES TO TRAIN
OFFICERS AND NEW POLICIES AND
BEST PRACTICES.
TODAY'S VOTE GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION PROVIDING A
COMMONSENSE UPDATE TO OUR USE OF
FORCE STANDARDS.
AS I SAID IN COMMITTEE WHAT GOOD
IS A POLICY WITHOUT THE BUY IN
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT GOOD ARE REVISED TRAINING
STANDARDS WITHOUT TO TROOP
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT?
TODAY'S VOTE BOTH UPDATING OUR
OUTDATED STANDARDS IN A WAY THAT
IS WORKABLE FOR THOSE TASKED
WITH ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY.
TODAY WE CONTINUE TO HISTORIC
WORK ON THIS ISSUE RAISING THE
CURRENT REASONABLE STANDARD TO
ONE THAT STATE DEADLY FORCE IS
PERMISSIBLE WHEN NECESSARY WHEN
CONSIDERING THE TOTALITY.
OF THE SITUATION.
ALSO AS I SAID EARLIER FEAR.
HERE'S BEEN ARE OUR MAIN
CHALLENGE WHEN WE COME TO THIS
ISSUE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY ALL
WANT TO GO HOME.
WIVES AND FAMILIES THE HUSBANDS
AND FAMILIES.
BUT ALSO AS A BLACK MAN.
THE BLACK MAN THAT'S PART OF
THIS INSTITUTION.
WHO IS TAUGHT WHEN HE WAS
SIXTEEN GETTING HIS DRIVER'S
LICENSE I WOULD DO DRIVER
TRAINING?
WHAT THE DRIVER EDUCATION?
AND THEN I WENT TO BLACK DRIVER
TRAINING.
WHICH IS BASICALLY WHEN YOU GET
BEHIND THE WHEEL LAW ENFORCEMENT
STOPPED YOU IT'S TEN O'CLOCK TWO
O'CLOCK.
DON'T MAKE ANY SUDDEN MOVES.
DON'T DO ANYTHING DON'T REACH
FOR THE GLOVE COMPARTMENT COULD
YOU MAY NOT GET HOME.
I AM SIXTY TWO YEARS OLD HAVE
BEEN STOPPED RECENTLY.
AND I STILL DO TEN O'CLOCK
[inaudible] TWO O'CLOCK.
I STILL DON'T MOVE QUICKLY.
BECAUSE I KNOW I MAY NOT GO HOME
ONE DAY BY DO WHAT IS PERCEIVED.
AS THE WRONG THING.
I STILL WORRY AS I'M UP HERE I
HAVE A SON WHO'S A TEACHER IN
WHAT.
I HAVE A SON WHO TAKE THE BUS
HOME IS SEVENTEEN TAKE THE BUS
HOME EVERY DAY.
I'M MORE CONCERNED.
ABOUT WHAT MAY HAPPEN IF MY SON
JUST STOP BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT SOMETIMES THE GANGSTER IN
WHAT'S.
OR THE GANGS AROUND MY COMMUNITY.
THAT IS NOT.
THE WAY THEY SHOULD BE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT I HAVE A ONE
YEAR OLD GRANDSON.
I DO NOT WANT TO TEACH HIM TEN
O'CLOCK TWO O'CLOCK FIFTEEN
YEARS FROM NOW. FIFTEEN YEARS
FROM NOW.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE STARTED A
PROCESS.
THAT NOT ONLY HE'LL SEE
COMMUNITY.
BUT ALSO REMOVES THAT FEAR.
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
FIFTY NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT OF
SOUTH LA STILL HAS [inaudible]
COLLEGE GRADUATE.
I STILL HAVE THAT FEAR THAT I
MAY NOT GO HOME WHEN THOSE
LIGHTS ARE BEHIND.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT STILL HAS THE
FEAR THAT IF THEY STOP SOMEONE
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME.
THAT THEY MAY NOT GO HOME.
WE NEED THE END THAT WE NEED IN
THAT WITH THE TRAINING.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
IMPACTFUL.
YESTERDAY I HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN MY OFFICE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
AND IT AFRICAN AMERICAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
REPEATED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THAT WE MUST MAKE SURE.
WE HAVE RACIAL BIAS TRAINING.
AS THE FOR FRONT.
OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO AS FAR AS
TRAINING.
AND AS I TRY TO MOVE ON TO OTHER
SUBJECTS HE PULLED ME BACK IN
AND LOOKED ME STRAIGHT MAY I TO
SAY I AM PLEADING WITH YOU. TO
ENSURE THAT WHAT EVER TRAINING
WHERE WE MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS IS THIS JUST SETS STANDARDS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GETS DONE.
BUT IT'S STILL HARD WORK IS
COMING FORWARD AFTER THAT WHICH
IS THE TRAINING AND
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND SO I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT.
THIS BILL AND ASKED THAT MY
COLLEAGUES TO PUT TO PUT IT IN.
TO PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO AND
JUSTLY DIE AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
UNDER EACH AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MISTER
MATHIS YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I TO AGREE IT'S TIME FOR A
CHANGE.
IT'S TIME THAT.
WE ADDRESS THE SOCIETAL PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE.
WE TALK ABOUT.
THIS NEED TO REDUCE THE FEAR OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT [inaudible]
AND MAKE SURE OUR CITIZENS ARE
AFRAID OF THEM.
AND YOU KNOW THIS FIRST MAKES ME
THINK OF SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING BACK HOME WITH MY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
WHERE THEY'RE REACHING OUT TO
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES?
AND OUR DEPUTIES ARE WORKING AS
COACHES [inaudible]
IN TEACHING.
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE TO BE FEARED.
BUT I'VE ALSO GOT I WONDER.
YOU KNOW WE WE TEACH OUR YOUTH.
NO MEANS NO.
BUT WHEN ARE WE GOING TO TEACH
THEM STOP MEANS STOP.
FREEZE MEANS FREEZE.
WE'VE LOST THIS FUNDAMENTAL
RESPECT. FOR OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
WE'VE GONE INTO THIS SOCIETAL.
CHANGE OF VICTIMHOOD.
INSTEAD OF PAYING THAT SIMPLE
RESPECT.
NOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA
MENTIONED.
THE TEN INTO IN THE FEAR.
AND I AGREE WITH THEM THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT.
BUT WE ALSO.
IN.
A AS A PROUD WHITE GUY ONE OF
THE KEYS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
I TEACH MY KIDS THE SAME THING.
RESPECT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DON'T MAKE ANY SUDDEN MOVES.
BECAUSE I ALSO KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THAT.
AS A PROUD VETERAN.
WHO'S BEEN IN COMBAT SITUATIONS.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IT MEANS? TO HAVE
TO DRAW WEAPON OUT ON SOMEBODY.
TO ASK THEM TO STOP. TO ASK THEM
TO FREEZE.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO PULL THE TRIGGER.
I DON'T KNOW ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN THAT I'VE EVER MET THAT I'VE
EVER TALKED TO YOU.
THAT WAKES UP IN THE MORNING AND
SAYS I WANT TO GET UP AND GO
SHOOT SOMEBODY.
NO THEY GET UP IN THE MORNING.
THEY KISS THEIR FAMILIES GOODBYE.
THE DROP THEIR KIDS OFF AT
SCHOOL.
AND THEN THEY GO ON PATROL.
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN
PROTECTING AND SERVING.
OFFICE.
AS MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE A DUTY. TO REALIZE THAT THE
WORDS THAT WE SAY.
CHANGE HOW SOCIETY IN THE PEOPLE
WE REPRESENT [inaudible]
LOOK IT.
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE DAY TO DAY?
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO OUT THERE AND
TELL THEM FEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY'RE GONNA BELIEVE THAT LIKE
GOSPEL.
WHEN WE GET OUT?
AND WE SAY.
NO WE NEED TO WORK AND HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY BELIEVE THAT
MEMBERS WHAT WE TELL OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IS WHAT THEY TURN AROUND AND DO.
BECAUSE THEY LOOK TO US FOR THAT
LEADERSHIP.
NOW I WANT TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND ALL
OF THE WORK THAT SHE'S DON.
AND THE ART OF COMPROMISE.
IN GETTING THEIR BECAUSE THAT
SHOWS.
TRUE VALUE AS A LEGISLATURE IT
SHOWS THAT.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM NICOLAS
SAID WORK.
SHE'S NOT TRYING TO STEAMROLL
THIS BILL.
BUT I THINK THAT AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE CONVERSATION.
AND REALLY SAY WHAT ARE WE DOING
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY. TO BRING
THAT.
COMMUNICATION THAT RESPECTS.
BACK TO OUR CHILDREN.
SO THEY KNOW DON'T FEAR THE
OFFICERS THEY'RE THERE TO HELP.
WE SHOULD LOOK TO THEM WE SHOULD
RESPECT THEM.
AND WHEN THEY PULL YOU OVER FOR
THEY TELL YOU TO STOP.
FOLLOW THEIR INSTRUCTIONS THEY
SHOULDN'T BE A MATTER OF FEAR.
IT SHOULD JUST BE A MATTER OF
DOING THE RIGHT THING.
IN TEACHING OUR NEXT GENERATION.
THAT IT'S OKAY.
HOW YOU MIGHT JUST HAVE A TAIL
LIGHT OUT?
YOU DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE NEED TO TEACH THAT
RESPECT AND GRAIN THAT BACK INTO
OUR CHILDREN AND WE'VE LOST IT
WHICH IS LED US TO THIS POINT
THE WE'RE AT TODAY.
SO MEMBERS ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU.
THERE WAS ROUGH AS MR STONE.
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL FACT I WAS A
CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL LAST YEAR.
AND KUDOS TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO WHOSE PATIENCE AND
PERSISTENCE HAS BROUGHT THIS
BILL TO US TODAY.
AND IN FACT IT'S BàN
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND
DIDN'T BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT
OF FEAR TO COME TO THE TABLE
ABOUT WHAT THIS REPRESENTED.
A LOT OF BULLYING.
AT A PERSPECTIVE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE THIS CHANGE
SERIOUSLY THIS BODY TODAY I HOPE
SAYS TAKE THIS CHANGE SERIOUSLY.
LOT OF QUESTION WHETHER.
THIS BILL GOES FAR ENOUGH IN
SETTING THE STANDARD.
LEGITIMATE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION BUT WHAT'S
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE BILL TODAY
BEFORE US AND IT WILL RESONATE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IS THIS IS
ONE OF THE FIRST ATTEMPTS IS A
STATE WIDE LEVEL TO SAY WE NEED
TO CHANGE.
THE OUTCOMES OF WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING.
IS NO MISTAKE ABOUT THE
STATISTICS WHO'S ON THE OTHER
END WHEN A POLICE OFFICER PULLED
THAT TRIGGER PRIMARILY YOUNG MEN.
BLACK AND BROWN.
AND UNTIL WE TAKE THE NEXT STEPS
AFTER THIS BILL AND BELIEVE ME
THIS BILL SETS A STANDARD.
BUT OPENS UP THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN NEXT WHICH
IS WHAT TO OUR POLICE FORCES
LOOK WHY.
DO THEY LOOK LIKE THE REST OF
OUR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
CURRENTLY THEY DON'T.
AND UNLESS WE ENHANCE NOT JUST
TRAINING BUT GO BACK INTO THE
STANDARDS OF WHO'S ACCEPTABLE TO
BE ABLE TO APPLY TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER
WHO WERE WILLING TO HAVE IN
THOSE FORCES THE INTERNAL
CULTURES WON'T CHANGE?
WE ALSO NEED TO HOLD AND THIS
COMES FROM POLICE CHIEFS IN MY
DISTRICT I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
HOLDING POLICE CHIEFS
ACCOUNTABLE. TO THE CULTURE
CREATED IN THEIR OWN
ORGANIZATION.
SO THESE ARE AMONG THE NEXT
STEPS THAT ULTIMATELY NEED TO
HAPPEN.
BUT THAT.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AND A
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE A CHANGE IN
THE STANDARD FOR WHAT'S EXPECTED
IN THE USE OF FORCE CONVERSATION
THAT MESSAGE WILL RESONATE
ACROSS THIS STATE.
AND ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
THAT WILL ENABLE THE NEXT SETS
OF CONVERSATIONS TO HAPPEN TO
TRULY CHANGE WHAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES HOW
ARE POLICE FORCES LOOK AT ACT
AND BE SENSITIVE.
TO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE
INTERACTING WITH THAT'S HOW WE
REDUCE THE FEARS.
THAT'S HOW WE DO.
CHANGE THE BIAS CALCULATION THAT
HAS BEEN MADE IN THEIR NUMBER
BILLS MOVING THROUGH RIGHT NOW I
THINK THEY'RE ALL OFF ON THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS THAT THAT BIAS
TRAINEE THAT INHERENT BIAS.
THAT WE ALL CARRY WHICH IS ONE
THING.
THE OTHER IS HOW WE ACT ON IT
AND THIS BILL SETS A BETTER
STAGE FOR ENSURING THAT HOW
POLICE FORCES ACT ON THAT BY IS.
IS DIFFERENT MAKE NO MISTAKE
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IT
WILL SEE A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
WHETHER IT'S GONE FAR ENOUGH
WHETHER IT'S GONE TOO FAR BUT IS
UP TO US TO EMBRACE.
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US? TO BE
GRATEFUL TO AN AUTHOR WHO HAS
HAD THE PERSISTENCE AND THE
PATIENCE TO STAY WITH US AND
GUIDE US THROUGH A SET OF
CHANGES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
VERY VERY NECESSARY.
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH LOS ANGELES
FOR SPEAKING HONESTLY ABOUT FEAR
AND THAT INTERACTION THAT IS
SOMETHING I DO NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
PART OF MY EXPERIENCE.
SO WITH OUT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SOUTHWEST SANDERS WITHOUT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
MEMBERS OF THE BLACK CAUCUS
LATINO CLOCK IS BEING A PART OF
THIS IN THE WOMEN WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE.
WITHOUT THEIR GUIDANCE AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVE WE WOULD STILL HAVE
A GOOD OLE BOY LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE THAT IS PASSING LAWS
THAT DO NOT REPRESENT THE CHANGE
THAT WE'RE SEEING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS AND I ASKED THAT ALL OF
US BE PART OF THE NEXT STEPS OF
POLICY THAT NEED TO CHANGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN COMPLETE SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINE TWO I AM.
HONORED THAT I AM ABLE TO SIT ON
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WHERE THIS.
FIRST WAS HEARD THIS YEAR -- AND
SHARED MY OWN STORY ABOUT BEING
TRAUMATIZED -- COMING HOME TO
DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT MY HOUSE
ALARM HAD GONE OFF I WAS MET BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO WERE THERE
TO REALLY HELP ME BUT ALL OF MY
TRAUMA.
ALL OF MY FEARS BUBBLED UP
DURING MY INTERACTION WITH THEM
I HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO SIT.
WITH DOCTOR WEBER AS MY SEAT
MATE TO SEE HER RUMINATE.
THIS ENTIRE SESSION ON THIS ONE
BILL.
AND EVERY DAY HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS BILL
AND THE IMPACT THAT IT CAN HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE FEARS THE CRIES.
THE TESTIMONIES OF ADVOCATES OF
VICTIMS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
THE NECESSITY FOR THIS BILL.
AND THE REALITY IS [inaudible]
YOU NOW.
THAT IT IS A GAME CHANGER IN THE
SENSE THAT IT IS ASKING US AS
THE STATE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE FACT THAT SO MANY BLACK
AND BROWN ON ARMED MEN.
ARE BEING AND HAVE BEEN SHOCKED.
AND KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH OUT THEIR CRIES FOR HELP
BEING HURT.
BUT THE REALITY IS IT'S NOT THAT
MUCH OF A GAME CHANGER BECAUSE
THE AUTONOMY IT IS STILL LINKED
TO THE ECONOMY THAT IS HELD BY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THEY STILL HOLD THE
SAFEGUARDS AS IT RELATES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE NOT GONNA WAKE UP.
ON THURSDAY. TO A WHOLE NEW
WORLD.
BUT HOPEFULLY WE WILL WAKE UP.
AND SAY THAT WE HAVE OPEN THE
DOOR FOR REAL CONVERSATIONS TO
HAPPEN ABOUT HOW OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS PROBABLY OVER
WORKED.
AND NOT PROPERLY TRAINED AND
OVER TRAUMATIZED.
HOW ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT NO
LONGER HAS THE TRUST OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE ASKED TO
PROTECT?
AND PROBABLY HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
FEARS FOR THEIR LIVES WHEN THEY
GO INTO THOSE VERY SAME
COMMUNITIES.
THAT FORMULA IS COMBUSTIBLE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
SO MANY BLACK AND BROWN AND POOR
COMMUNITIES WANT TO CALL THE
POLICE WHEN SOMETHING'S GOING ON
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR HELP.
BUT THEY'RE AFRAID TO BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THAT CALL TO
TURN INTO SOME OTHER
CONVERSATION THAT ENDS UP IN
THEM BEING ARRESTED OR KILLED.
I WANT MY FAMILY TO BE PROTECTED
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE'S.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE BAD PEOPLE
ARE KEPT AT BAY JUST LIKE ANYONE
ELSE.
AND LORD KNOWS I WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BELIEVE IN ME.
BECAUSE OF THEY BELIEVE IN ME.
THEY WILL PROTECT ME.
AND I WILL SEE THAT AND IT WILL
RESONATE AND I WILL THEN WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE ALL
LIVING IN THAT WE ALL LOVE.
ARE SAFE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT VAX.
THIS BILL IS THE FIRST STEP IN A
NUMBER OF STEPSTHAT DO TALK
ABOUT RACE THAT TALK ABOUT CLASS
THAT TALK ABOUT BIAS THAT TALK
ABOUT FEAR.
WE ARE AFRAID WE ARE AFRAID OF
EACH OTHER WE ARE AFRAID OF
OURSELVES.
AND INSTEAD OF TALKING.
WE ARE RUNNING FROM [inaudible]
OR SHOOTING.
AND ALL GOOD PEOPLE [inaudible]
LOSE.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE EQUATION.
WHEN THAT BECOMES THE NORM?
SO I AM HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL
IS GOING TO GET OFF THIS FLOOR.
I AM GLAD THAT THE HEAVY HITTERS
HAVE JOINED YOU.
AS JOINT CO AUTHORS TO SAY WE AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
GOING TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS REGARDLESS OF HOW
WHO THEY LOOK LIKE.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME OR
COLOR OR STATURE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT THEM ALL.
SO I THANK YOU FOR KEEPING THIS
GOING.
AND FOR YOUR TOLERANCE.
AND I STAND WITH YOU ALWAYS IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE MS BAUER KAY AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB -- THREE
NINETY TWO ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE I HAD THE HONOR OF
SITTING NEXT.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
AS WE SAT THERE [inaudible] FOR
HOURS.
IT'S HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE CAME AND
SPOKE.
THE USE OF FORCE AND HOW IT
AFFECTED THEM OR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
HOURS WE STARTED EARLY IN THE
MORNING AND IT KEPT GOING PAST
LUNCH TIME.
AND THE AUTHOR OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO SAT THERE AND
LISTEN TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE PEOPLE.
WHO SHE WAS ADVOCATING FOR THAT
DAY?
AND WE ALSO HEARD FROM A POLICE
OFFICER.
WHO HAD LOST HER COLLEAGUES IN
THE LINE OF FIRE?
WELL THEY WERE ON A CALL.
AND HOW IT HAD LEFT HER UNABLE
TO CONTINUE TO DO HER JOB.
AND I SPOKE THAT DAY OF HOW IT
WAS SO CLEAR FROM THE TESTIMONY.
THE PENDULUM.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY HAS SWUNG
WAY TOO FAR. TO YOU THE ABILITY
TO USE FORCE WHEN IT WAS
UNNECESSARY.
BUT I HAD CONCERNS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS THAT THE
BILL IS WRITTEN SWUNG THE
PENDULUM TOO FAR IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
AND WOULD PUT LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
DANGER AS WRITTEN.
AND I WANT TO I RISE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
THE ADVOCATES LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERSHIP FOR WORKING TOGETHER
TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE HAVE
REALLY GOOD POLICY THAT WE CAN
VOTE ON TODAY.
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THAT WILL
STRIKE THAT APPROPRIATE BALANCE.
AND THERE IS NO QUESTION TO ME
WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES SPOKE
TO FEEL SAFE IN RELATIONSHIP
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT WE ARE SAFER.
WHEN THEY HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP
AND THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE?
AND THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO FEEL SAFE IN
DOING THEIR JOB AS WELL.
AND THAT IS THE BALANCE THAT
THIS AUTHOR HAS WORKED SO HARD
TO STRIKE AND I THINK DONE SUCH
INCREDIBLE JOB OF SO I THINK HER
AND I'M PROUD TODAY TO BE
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MS BAUER CAM MS RACE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR HER HARD WORK.
WHILE ALL OF THIS IS GOING IT
WAS HAPPENING I HAD A YOUNG.
CONSTITUENTS OUR PERMISSION TO
USE PROP [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE YOUNG GIRL LEO MY FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD FROM ERROR VIEW MIDDLE
SCHOOL THE CAME TO SEE ME. TO
URGE ME TO VOTE HI.
ON THIS BILL.
SHE HAD A PIECE OF PAPER.
THE NAMES OF VICTIMS. SEVEN
CLARK. TWENTY TWO TO MERE RICE.
TWELVE ANTOINE ROSE.
SEVENTEEN MICHAEL ALTON STERLING.
THIRTY SEVEN LOOK QUAN MCDONALD.
SEVENTEEN TRAYVON MARTIN.
OSCAR GRANT.
TWENTY TWO WILLIE MCCOY TWENTY I
ANA MODE MONET'S STANLEY JONES.
I SPOKE TO OUR GREAT LENGTH.
I TOLD HER MOTHER THIS ISN'T
WHAT I WANT OUR FOURTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO BE WRITING
NOTES WITH THE NAMES OF ALL OF
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS.
BUT I ALSO TOLD HER MOTHER AND I
ALSO TOLD LIAM I HAVE A SISTER
WITH THE SET WITH THE SAN
BERNARDINO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WHO'S NOW RETIRED.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT HER AND HER
COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
BUT THIS.
THIS I DON'T WANT TO SEE ANYMORE.
I AM SO SO GRATEFUL.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR WORKING SO SO HARD.
BECAUSE SHE KNEW WHAT EVERYBODY
OF THE TURMOIL OF ALL OVER
COLLEAGUES.
AND SHE WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THE END.
THROUGH HER PATIENCE PERSISTENCE
YOUR PERSEVERANCE.
AND HER BELIEF.
THE WE WOULD HAVE A SAFER AND
BETTER SOCIETY. FOR EVERYONE.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I STAND
IN SUPPORT WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
THEY WITH RESPECT FRAZIER.
YOUR ATTENTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES -- I RISE
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK OF
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
AS YOU KNOW WHEN SHE GETS HER
TEETH INTO SOMETHING SHE DOES
NOT LET GO.
SHE'S A PASSIONATE INDIVIDUAL
WHO I APPRECIATE SERVING ON THIS
FLOOR WITH.
MY ISSUE IS THAT THIS BECAME A
PARTISAN ISSUE IN THE BEGINNING.
AND IT SHOULD NEVER BE.
I HAVE RIDDEN WITH EVERY POLICE
DEPARTMENT SHERIFF DEPARTMENT
AND HIGHWAY PATROL IN MY
DISTRICT.
ON FULL SHIFT TWELVE HOUR SHIFT
RIDE ALONGS.
SO I COULD UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
POLICE OFFICERS NEEDS WERE.
SO WHEN IT CAME TO ME IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS.
I COULD BE A BETTER LEGISLATOR.
I WILL TELL YOU [inaudible]
THAT EVERY.
POLICE DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERSTAFFED.
OUR HIGHWAY PATROL.
IS SEVERELY UNDERSTAFFED BUT WE
ASK THEM TO DO MORE WITH LESS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO ADD LAWS AND
AND DUTIES TO THESE DEPARTMENTS.
WITHOUT REALIZING THE IMPACT.
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING [inaudible]
THESE OFFICERS.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE ALSO?
IS THAT WE HAVE QUIRK MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS INTERVENTION
RESPONDING. TWO CALLS RATHER
THAN OUR POLICE OFFICERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT TRAINED.
BUT YET WE EXPECT THEM TO BE THE
RESPONDING [inaudible]
AGENCY.
WE NEED TO LISTEN TO THEM ALSO
AND AGAIN.
MY SPEAKER.
I CAN'T BE MORE PROUD OF
ENGAGING ON THIS HUGE ISSUE THE
PRO TEM IN THE GOVERNOR.
THIS IS THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK WHEN OUR LEADERSHIP
REPRESENTS US SO VERY WELL.
INTO A SOLUTION THAT EVERYBODY
COMES TOGETHER.
NOW EVERYBODY NOT MIGHT NOT BE
HAPPY.
THE COMPROMISES WAS MADE AND IS
MADE.
ON THEIR EFFORTS.
ALL I CAN SAY IS PLEASE WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHEN IT COSTS.
ADDITIONAL MONIES [inaudible] TO
REPRESENT.
PUBLIC SAFETY WE ALSO HAVE TO
TAKE THAT IN CONSIDERATION.
UNLESS YOU'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
AFFECTED.
AND BEEN HELPED BY SOMEBODY
[inaudible]
IN POLICE [inaudible]
SERVICE.
YOU REALLY DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR VALUE.
I DO REMEMBER.
THAT ONE ON MY RIGHT ALONG AS
MOST OF THE ISSUES WERE CUSTOMER
SERVICE RELATED.
INSTEAD OF ENFORCEMENT.
NOW YOU CAN SAY THAT BECAUSE I
WAS IN THE CAR THEY CHANGE THEIR
ATTITUDE OR THEIR WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS.
POSSIBLY.
BUT THE DAY THAT I WAS WITH THEM
I WAS VERY PROUD.
THAT THEY DID.
THE THINGS THAT THEY DID FOR THE
PEOPLE.
THAT I REPRESENT.
WHAT I WOULD HOPE [inaudible]
GOING FORWARD.
IS THAT WE CONTINUE. TO WORK
TOGETHER WE'VE PUT IN CHARGE OF
HELPING AND PROTECTING US
[inaudible]
UNDERSTANDING [inaudible]
THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT JOB.
THEY'RE DOING THE JOB.
THAT WE SUPPORT THEM ALSO IN
THEIR NEEDS.
AND THERE ASK I'VE ATTENDED.
ALMOST EVERY FUNERAL FOR THE
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS BECAUSE
IN MY ROLE AS A CHAIRMAN
TRANSPORTATION.
I HAVE THE HONOR OF OVERSEEING I
WOULD PATROL IN THAT POLICY.
THE WINDOWS THAT I'VE I'VE
SPOKEN.
TO THE FAMILIES THAT I'VE SEEN
AFFECTED ALSO.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AND UNDERSTAND
THIS TWO SIDES TO EVERY STORY
AND I DON'T I'M NOT TRYING TO
MAKE EXCUSES. FOR ALL OF THE BAD
OCCURRENCES THAT HAVE HAPPENED
THAT'S A HUMAN FACTOR.
HAPPENS IN EVERY ENTITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOT JUST IN [inaudible]
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE GOOD WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
AND LEADERSHIP.
AND I'M PROUD THAT THIS WORKED
IN THIS FASHION [inaudible]
THIS DAY.
BECAUSE IT WAS SUPPOSED TO COME
OUT LIKE THIS.
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS FRAZIER MISTER
PATTERSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I'M.
I MUST I MUST SAY THAT THIS HAS
BEEN AND CONTINUES. TO BE A VERY --
PERSONAL AND THE DEEP.
AND IN MANY WAYS SORT OF
CONFLICTING.
A PROCESS IN DECIDING.
HOW TO VOTE ON THIS BILL -- MANY
OF YOU KNOW THAT MY OLDEST SON
BJ'S VIETNAMESE WHEN HE WAS.
SIXTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
AND WAS DRIVING HIS AUTOMOBILE
FOR THE FIRST [inaudible]
FEW TIMES.
WAS PULLED OVER.
JOHN DOWN ON BECAUSE HE LOOKED
LIKE.
A CAR THIEF ANY WAS IN A CAR
SIMILAR TO THE CAR THAT WAS
STOLEN.
AND HE WAS IN THE LOCATION.
I REMEMBER SITTING ON THE BED
WITH HIM THAT NIGHT.
TALKING WITH HIM ABOUT.
HOW OFTENTIMES LIFE CAN BE
UNFAIR?
AND CAN BE SCARY [inaudible]
AND THAT.
IT WASN'T HIS FAULT [inaudible]
THIS WAS.
LONG BEFORE I BECAME MAYOR
FRESNO.
BUT I TOOK IT WITH ME AND
CARRIED IT WITH ME. FOR THOSE
EIGHT YEARS.
AT THE TIME I WAS ELECTED FRESNO
HAD ONE OF THE LOCK THE SMALLEST
A PER CAPITA POLICE FORCES.
IN THE UNITED STATES FRANKLY.
WE HAD A HUNDRED HOMICIDES IN
ONE YEAR. FIFTEEN THOUSAND CARS
BEING STOLEN THESE WERE
DIFFICULT TIMES [inaudible]
WE MADE [inaudible]
THE DECISION AND TO DOUBLE THAT
POLICE FORCE.
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT WE NEEDED
TO GET.
IT ANOTHER OFFICERS SO THAT WE
COULD BE PROACTIVE RATHER THAN
REACTIVE OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
FRESNO HAS A STRONG MAYOR FORM
OF GOVERNMENT.
FOR THE BUCK STOPS ON MY DESK.
YOU HIRE THE POLICE CHIEF AND
YOU LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE
OFFICER'S BIOGRAPHY AND YOU
INTERVIEW THEM.
I DID THAT OVER AND OVER.
AND OVER AGAIN.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THESE
POLICE OFFICERS.
WHEN THEY MAKE THEIR DECISION?
TO BE A POLICE OFFICER.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE BEST HUMAN
BEINGS YOU CAN POSSIBLY FIND.
AND THERE.
BIOGRAPHIES ARE RIFE WITH.
BEING IN THE MILITARY OR
MILITARY POLICE ARE BEING AND
ANOTHER POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
AND ALL OF THAT.
AND WE ENDED UP [inaudible]
HIRING AND CRIME WENT DOWN.
AND COMMUNITIES THAT WERE AFRAID.
OF THE FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT
BECAME.
ALLIES.
IT WASN'T EASY.
BUT IT WAS BECAUSE WE DID HAVE
THE RESPECT.
OF THE COMMUNITY AND WE HAD A
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT WAS LED BY A SUCCESSION OF
CHIEFS THAT INSTILLED
[inaudible]
IN THEM.
THE NECESSITY TO USE THAT FORCE
WITH WISDOM.
AND SO I RISE WITH.
A SIGNIFICANT DEGREE
[inaudible]
OF EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
WHEN IT?
COMES TO THE ONE OR TWO TIMES.
WHEN A POLICE OFFICER?
HAD TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT A
TROUBLED THAT POLICE OFFICER OF
A BIT IS A TROUBLED ANYBODY ELSE
AND AND TROUBLED ME.
BUT WHERE I AM CONFUSED HERE.
IS THAT I AM TRYING TO SEE.
WHAT IS IT IN THIS BILL?
THAT IS SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
DEPARTURE FROM THE STATUS QUO.
THAT IT BECOMES A GAME CHANGER.
FOR MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN THAT
THE STANDARD HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND
THE PRACTICE HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
THAT WE THAT THERE WOULD BE A A
REASONABLE.
A REASONABLE PASSED
REASONABLENESS.
THAT THERE THAT THERE WOULD BE A
NECESSITY.
AND THAT WHEN IT WAS PUT TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THE PROCESS IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE LOOK AT THE
TOTALITARIAN. TO COUNTY.
OF THE PARTICULAR INCIDENT.
THIRTY SECONDS MISS PATTERSON
AND SO I TO ME I LOOK AT THE
BILL AND I HEAR.
GAME CHANGER I HEAR.
THIS CHART SO HOLD NEW COURSE.
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW THAT ACTUALLY IS IN?
BODY IN THE BILL. FOR IT IS
CLEAR THAT THERE IS A STANDARD A
NECESSITY.
THERE IS A STANDARD OF OF
REASONABLE LESS.
AND THAT CONTINUING TO PLACE
THIS IN THE HANDS.
OUR FOR THE KIND OF JUDITH
ADJUDICATION OF A WHETHER IT'S A
A A A A A BAD.
SHOOTING RECORD OR NOT.
REST WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WHICH MEANS TO ME THAT THERE IS
THIS.
PROCESS THAT LOOKS AT THE
TOTALITY OF OF THE INCIDENT
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I FOR WHATEVER IT'S WORTH -- I'D
LIKE I'D LIKE.
TO DRAFT ACT ASK THE AUTHOR
MAYBE OTHERS COULD COULD COMMENT.
ON HOW.
WHY IS THIS BILL SUCH A?
DEEP SEA CHANGE.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
OUTLINE OF THE BILL AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
A STE ESSENTIALLY KEEPS.
THE REASONABLE STANDARD AND AND
THE THE SESAME STANDARD.
ARE.
ALSO SUGGESTED THERE NEEDS TO BE
A TOTALITARIAN TOTALITY OF THE
INFORMATION -- THAT TENDS TO BE
THE STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURE
AT LEAST OF THE FRESNO POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN LOOKING AT THOSE.
KINDS OF SHOES AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN OUR AREA TIME IS SO
FAST SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
PERHAPS CENTER AT HER CLOTHES OR
SOMEBODY.
SOMETIME OTHERS COULD COULD
COULD MENTION.
WHAT'S THE BIG DIFFERENCE HERE
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND ANNA PERHAPS ONE OF
THE ANSWERS TO THE SEA CHANGE IS
THE COURT VERY CONVERSATION
WE'RE HAVING -- I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN LACKING
OVER.
THE LAST THE LAST SEVEN YEARS I
WOULD SAY ME PERHAPS -- WE
CONTINUE TO SEE OF A RISE AND
POLICE INVOLVED SHOOTINGS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE A RISE I
THINK IN IN -- OVERALL VIOLENCE
AND THESE CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE THE VIDEOS THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SEE THESE OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND CONTINUE TO TAKE SIDES.
AND I THINK THIS IS A PRIME
EXAMPLE OF NOT STAYING AND
TAKING SIDES BUT COMING TOGETHER.
COMING TOGETHER FOR THE GOOD OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
I AM A WE WERE DONE -- I'M MUST
SOCIAL WORKER RIGHT SO I HAVE
BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF ISSUES
AROUND SOCIAL JUSTICE MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
I HESITATED AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS BILL AND ONE ALSO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE.
WHO I AM HONORED TO SHARE A
FLOOR WITH? TO PLEASE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
GET A COMPROMISE.
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN'T HAVE
EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
IMPLEMENT A POLICY.
WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND TO COME
TO AGREEMENTS WERE PERHAPS NOT
EVERYBODY IS HAPPY.
BUT THE PUBLIC GREATER GOOD IS
SERVED.
AND ISN'T THAT WHAT WE'RE REALLY
ALL HERE.
FOR BECAUSE I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK.
DOES JUST AN AVERAGE CITIZEN.
ONE OF MY CITIES EVEN IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU LIVE SOMEWHERE ELSE
YOU'RE ALL UP HERE DURING A
MAJORITY THE WEEKEND SO YOUR IN
MY MY NEWS CHANNELS.
AND SO YOU KNOW I REPRESENT THE
CITY OF STOCKTON.
AND YOU'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
AT ALL YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A
SPIKE IN CRIME.
LIKE WE HAVEN'T HAD IN QUITE
AWHILE.
TEXTING WITH MY CHIEF SINCE
MONTH SINCE -- OVER THE WEEKEND
WITH THREE MURDERS. ONE OF THEM
ON I FIVE ALL OF THESE ARE BY
SHOOTINGS.
I CAN'T COUNT THE AMOUNT OF
SHOOTINGS ARE PROBABLY HAD OVER
THIRTY GUN RELATED SHOOTINGS.
WHO HAD AT LEAST SEVEN MURDERS
SINCE THE BEGINNING?
OF THIS OF THIS MONTH ONLY.
SO WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE ISSUES
AROUND VIOLENCE AND AS A AND
LAST NIGHT WAS TRUST NOT MY
HOUSE WHERE THE TRASH ON THE AND
EVERY TIME WE HEARD A NOISE MY
LOOK GIRLY WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S
THAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE ALSO LIVING IN A
HEIGHTENED AREA FEAR WHEN WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S VIOLENCE
OCCURRING AROUND US.
AND IF SOMETHING HAPPENS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE CALL.
911- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
GOING TO BE SAFE AND THE POLICE
OFFICERS ARE GOING TO BE.
HESITATING WHEN THEY COME.
BUT WE KNOW.
THAT IN ORDER TO GET TO THOSE
PLACES WE NEED THE TRAINING WE
TALK ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
EXIST.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THE TRAINING
HAS TO BE THERE SO THEY CAN DO
THEIR JOB TO THE UP MOST OF
THEIR ABILITIES AND US HAVING
THESE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS.
ENSURE THAT THOSE PRECAUTIONS.
CAN OCCUR OFFICERS ARE SAFE.
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE KILLED ON
THE STREETS.
AND THE PUBLIC STILL HAS THE
TRUST.
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE LOOKED
AFTER.
TO I THINK THESE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
CONCERN OURSELVES WITH AND WHY
IT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THAT WE ARE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
ALSO WE TALK ABOUT FUNDING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SHOULD BE
ON THE FRONTLINE WE'RE GOING OUT
TO DEAL WITH AND BUT ONE PERSON
WHO IS MENTALLY ILL I THINK THIS
LAST WEEK THAT WAS SHOT.
WAS.
IN VERY AGGRESSIVE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WENT OUT ON
THOSE BUT I MEAN WE NEED TO WORK
MUCH CLOSER WITH US SO.
I RISE IN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
WANT TO THANK ALL SIDES TO BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER ON THIS
AND I WAS WE GO FORWARD AS
LEADERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HAVING THESE COURAGEOUS
CONVERSATIONS WE MAKE SURE THAT
ALL VOICES IN OUR COMMUNITY ARE
REPRESENTED.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE
NINETY TWO AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
PATIENTS HER TENACITY.
HER WISDOM AND EVERYBODY ELSE
FOR COMING TO THE TABLE THAT SHE
SET AND INVITED THEM.
TO THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN MS
WICKS [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER SPEAKER --
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
I'M A FRESHMAN HERE AND I HAD
THE HONOR OF WATCHING DOCTOR
WEBER WORK THIS BILL -- AND
WATCHING HER COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND TO THIS
ISSUE WHICH IS NOT AN EASY ISSUE
TO DEAL WITH AND SHE'S REALLY
TACKLE THAT AND SO.
I LEARNED A LOT FROM HER IN THIS
PROCESS AND WANT TO THANK HER
FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW I TO SIT ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I ASKED TO
BE ON THAT COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
WANTED.
TO BE IN THE THE THICK OF THESE
TOUGH ISSUES AND I BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT WE NEED CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM IN THE STATE AND
THAT WE CAN LEAD THE WAY IN THIS
COUNTRY ON THOSE ISSUES.
AND I SAT IN THAT COMMITTEE
HEARING -- AS MUCH AS MIGHT
NEIGHBORING COLLEAGUE HAD
MENTIONED.
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE
MOTHERS WHO HAD LOST
[inaudible]
THEIR CHILDREN.
AT THE HANDS OF GUN VIOLENCE
FROM POLICE.
AND THEY HELP THOSE PHOTOS UP.
AND IT WAS INCREDIBLY MOVING TO
SEE.
AND VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE.
AND I THINK WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT STRIKES AT THE HEART.
AND TRIES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS.
THAT WE SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE TRUTH THAT.
BROWN AND BLACK MEN PRIMARILY
ARE THE ONES WHO WERE KILLED AT
THE HANDS THE HANDS OF POLICE.
PEOPLE WITH MY SKIN COLOR.
OR NOT.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO PEOPLE WERE KILLED
AT THE HANDS OF POLICE.
LESS THAN HALF OF THEM WERE
ARMED.
AND OF THOSE THAT WERE KILLED
WHO WERE UNARMED. 75% WERE
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND I THINK WITH THIS BILL TRIES
TO DO IS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN BOTH
BELIEVE.
WE CAN HOLD IN IN OUR HEARTS THE
IDEA THAT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF POLICE ARE
TRYING TO DO A GOOD JOB.
AND THEY ARE BROTHERS AND OUR
SISTERS AND OUR MOTHERS AND OUR
FATHERS.
AND OUR CHILDREN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO A GOOD JOB.
THEY'RE ALSO.
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA AND STRESS.
AND DON'T ALL OF THEM HAVE THE
TOOLS TO DO THE GOOD JOB THAT WE
KNOW THAT THEY CAN DO.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT MISTAKES ARE
MADE.
AND ALSO THE UNCOMFORTABLE
TRUTHS THAT I THINK THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
AND I THINK THE WAY THAT WE
REBUILD TRUST IN OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT GOOD
POLICING IS BASED ON THE WAY WE
DO THAT IS WE HAVE MORE
COMMUNITY POLICING WE HAD
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING.
WE HAVE DE ESCALATION TRAINING
AND WE HAVE THE LEGAL TOOLS IN
OUR TOOLBOX. TO HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THESE TRAGIC
MISTAKES HAPPEN.
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS WORK
I PROBABLY VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EVERYONE ELSE TO GIVE US AN
IPHONE.
THANK YOU WAS WITH MISTER RIGHT.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I WENT TO BED [inaudible]
OUR CHRISTMAS.
NIGHT THIS PAST YEAR IN MY HOME
TOWN OVER SAID.
HAVING SPENT THE DAY WITH MY
FAMILY.
AND I WOKE UP.
ON DECEMBER TWENTY SIXTH. TO
READ ABOUT A THE THIRTY THREE
YEAR OLD MAN.
THE WIFE AND YOUNG CHILD. FIVE
MONTHS OLD.
GUN DOWN.
IN MY COMMUNITY.
HE WAS GUNNED DOWN [inaudible]
PATROLLING.
THE STREETS OF THE WEST SIDE
MERCED COUNTY.
AS A YOUNG OFFICER.
PULLING SOMEONE OVER ON A DEAL I
STOCK.
ANOTHER YOUNG MAN IT STOPPED AT
A CONVENIENCE STORE WAS
INTOXICATED THE CONVENIENCE
STORE CAR OWNER CALLED AND THIS
OFFICER PULLED THAT YOUNG MAN
OVER AND WAS SHOT AND KILLED.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
LOSS OF OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THEIR DISTRICTS.
ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT COIN
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH BRIGHT FUTURES
MISTAKENLY GONE DOWN.
LIVES LOST.
TRAGIC.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT ISSUE.
AND THAT'S WHY RISE.
THE COMMAND THE AFTER.
THAT THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
LEADERSHIP NOT JUST IN THIS BILL.
LEADERSHIP IN OUR COMMUNITY HERE
ON THE FLOOR [inaudible]
MY CALLING FROM FRESNO RAISE THE
ISSUE WHAT'S DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
TODAY.
THEN THE STATUS QUO HOW ARE WE
MOVING THE ISSUE FORWARD.
AND I WOULD SAY I'M STRUCK.
BY THE SUPPORT ON THIS FOR THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SUPPORT FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FROM COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
TRAGEDIES.
DIFFERENT SIDES OF THIS
DIFFICULT STICKY ISSUE WITH A
LOT OF EMOTION.
AND TOO OFTEN.
IN OUR POLITICS [inaudible]
OF TODAY.
IT'S EASY TO RETREAT.
BACK INTO VILIFIED THE OTHER
SIDE.
TAP POLITICAL POSTURING
[inaudible]
RHETORIC.
THAT SOME OF THAT RHETORIC HELPS
MANY OF US IN OUR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICTS ON THE RIGHT AND THE
LEFT.
WHAT'S HARD IS SITTING DOWN.
AND RECOGNIZING THE HUMANITY ON
ALL SIDES AND BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER THAT'S A DIFFICULT
THING TO DO AND IT'S MADE MORE
DIFFICULT.
BY THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SUCH A
DIVISIVE POLITICS IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
WE GET A LACK DIDN'T COME UP TO
SACRAMENTO WE IMMEDIATELY DIVIDE
OURSELVES INTO PARTY'S.
AND THEN WE DIVIDE OURSELVES
FURTHER [inaudible]
MEANWHILE.
CONSTITUENTS IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS FOR
PROBLEM SOLVERS AND DOCTOR WEBER.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
COMES FROM A A PLACE WHERE.
SHE COULD EASILY [inaudible]
RETREAT [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
TWO RHETORIC [inaudible]
AND PARTISANSHIP.
BUT SHE CHOSE NOT TO THIS ISSUE
IS TOO IMPORTANT.
SHE SPENT THE TIME AND I HAD
WEEKLY CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
SENSITIVE ISSUE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND YOU CAN IMAGINE.
WITH THIS YOUNG MAN GOT DOWN
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO THE
SENSITIVITY.
WITH THOSE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE CONSISTENT DRUM BEAT.
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANDY --
PUSHING THE ISSUE FORWARD
TOGETHER BRING EVERYONE ALONG.
CHANGING MINDS EVOLVING THINKING.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
MENTIONED FEAR DIVISION TRUST.
WHAT PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS WE'RE BUILDING TRUSTS?
WHERE THE LEADERS MEMBERS WERE
HERE TO REPRESENT?
OUR COMMUNITIES AND HOW WE
CONDUCT OUR POLITICS.
BUILDS TRUST.
TEARS DOWN DIVISIONS.
MAKES THINGS LIKE THIS BILL
POSSIBLE TODAY.
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFEST WHEN THAT
TRUST EXIST.
BETWEEN THOSE THAT PROTECT US.
AND THOSE THAT THEY PROTECT.
AND I THINK TODAY MEMBERS WITH
THIS BILL.
WITH THE SUPPORT.
WE'VE MOVE THAT FORWARD AND I
WOULD URGE AND I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU MISS GRAY MISTER
GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS [inaudible]
I STRUGGLE.
WITH THIS BILL [inaudible]
I TOILED.
WITH THIS BILL.
AS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER.
AS A BLACK MAN.
AS A BLACK MAN HAS [inaudible]
TO YOUNG SONS [inaudible]
I STRUGGLE.
WITH THIS BILL.
BEING IN THIS POSITION.
AT THE STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL.
WHO PARTNER WAS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY?
AS A POLICE OFFICER I STRUGGLE
WITH THIS BILL.
WITHIN A YOUNG MAN AT FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD DIE IN MY ARMS WHILE
ON PATROL I STRUGGLE WITH THIS
BILL.
MAKING SURE THAT I GET IT RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME.
I'M NOT PLAYING WITH THIS.
MY TEAM BOTH THE CAPITAL AND THE
DISTRICT TEAM WENT HOURS AND
HOURSDISSECTING THIS BILL.
ASKING QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
AN AUTHOR STAFF.
BECAUSE WE GOT TO GET IT RIGHT
THIS TIME.
THIS LAW HAS NOT BEEN CHANGED
SINCE.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO AND NOW
WE'RE TAKING ALL THIS GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY. TO MAKE A CHANGE.
BUT I CAN'T DO NOT DENY.
AS A BLACK MAN [inaudible]
THE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE DYING IN OUR STREETS?
I COULD NOT DENY.
THE YOUNG MEN.
WHO ARE NOT ONLY BEING KILLED BY
POLICE OFFICERS BUT ALSO BEING
KILLED BY?
BUT GETTING MEMBERS AS WELL.
I CAN'T DENY THAT.
THOSE ARE REAL.
VIVID IMAGES IN MY MIND.
AS A PARENT.
AS A PAIR MAKING SURE THE CHILD
GETS HOME ON TIME.
UNDERSTANDING MAKING SURE THAT
WHOEVER MY SON GETS IN THE CAR
WITH.
YOU TAKE CARE OF YOU TAKE A
PICTURE THE LICENSE PLATES AND
SEND IT TO ME.
MAKING SURE THAT DO NOT A HOME
AT TWELVE O'CLOCK YEAH BUT I
WANNA KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
BECAUSE I AM CONCERNED I DON'T
WANT TO BURY NOT ANOTHER CHILD
BECAUSE I HAD A BETTER.
ONE BUT I'LL BE IF I'M GOING TO
BEAR ANOTHER.
ONE SO I HAD TO GET IT RIGHT
THIS TIME.
SO I LISTEN TO ALL OF YOU WHICH
COMMENTARIES AND AND WHEN WORDS
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE MY
KIND OF EXPERIENCE.
THE GREW UP POOR I GREW UP.
AND I WORE THE UNIFORM.
I TOOK THE OATH OF OFFICE THE
SERVER PROTECT MY COMMUNITY.
AND I DID IT.
SO THOSE OF YOU WORE UNIFORMS.
WHATEVER REASON BUT YOU'RE NOT
SAYING ANYTHING THAT'S ON YOU.
BUT I'M GOING TO SAID NOR DOES
SERVE AS LONG AS YOU IN UNIFORM.
I DIDN'T STUDENT TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF THIRTY SEVEN THE THIRTY
YEARS THAT SO MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS FLOOR START TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT I TOOK THAT RESPONSIBILITY
EVERY MAN AND WOMAN THAT WEAR A
BADGE AND A AND PUT ON A UNIFORM
WITH A CLOSE THAT LOCKER ROOM
DOOR.
THAT MAY BE THE LAST TIME.
WHEN I KISSED A WISER CHILDREN
THAT MAY BE VERY WELL THERE LAST
TIME?
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO MAKE SURE I
GET A RIGHT SO I GREW THE AUTHOR.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT.
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME MY SON
THE BOND AND JORDAN AND ALL THE
OTHER KIDS THAT ARE CALLED MY
SON'S.
WHETHER NO MY DNA IS MATCHING
THERE'S A NOT MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE WHETHER NOT I KNOW
THEIR NAMES MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
TO ME THEY'RE ALL MY CHILDREN I
KNOW MY BROTHER'S KEEPER.
AND SO WHEN WE TAKE THIS
BUSINESS REPORTS TODAY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT SOBERLY
[inaudible]
I THOUGHT [inaudible]
IN MINE.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHANGING SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
BEEN TOUCHED SINCE.
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AND SO I WANT.
TO SIMPLY SAY THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS DONE HER DUE DILIGENCE.
SHE PUT THE TIME IN.
SHE HAS STILL OF THE COURSE.
THE WHITE OUR STATE ON HER
SHOULDERS.
BUT SHE HAS BROUGHT PEOPLE
TOGETHER WHO WOULD NOT TALK
BEFORE.
BROKERED A COMPROMISE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT OUR WORK IS
NOT FINISHED YET.
AND I THINK THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE LAWN
FORCED WAS PROTECTED.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR YOUNG MEN.
IN MY COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE PROTECTED AS WELL.
THAT'S ALL I WANNA THANK THIS
AUTHOR FOR STANDING UP DOING
SOMETHING VERY COURAGEOUS.
BY BRINGING THIS CONVERSATION SO
THIS FLOOR AND SO I COMMEND YOU.
BUT WE CANNOT ALSO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THREE NINETY
TWO WITH ALL TALKING ABOUT SB
TWO THIRTY AS WELL.
BECAUSE TO THIRTY IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT TALKS ABOUT THE
TRAINING THAT'S NECESSARY FOR
THIS NEXT GENERATION OF POLICE
OFFICERS YOU CANNOT HAVE ONE
WITHOUT THE OTHER. THIRTY
SECONDS GIPSON.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY.
BUT ALSO BE ASKING MY COLLEAGUES
THOSE WHO CO AUTHORED THIS BILL.
SO ALSO SUPPORT.
TO THIRTY BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
NO I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE
AND TAKE THIS AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL BEFORE US
TODAY.
THANK YOU MS GIBSON [inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I WAS GOING TO SPEAK.
BUT I FELT LIKE.
THEY'LL BE A BETRAYAL TO THIS
ISSUE.
IN MY ENTIRE ELECTED EXPERIENCE.
NEVER HAS A BILL.
CONSUMED MY THINKING AS THIS
HOUSE.
AND THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF MY LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
BEING DIFFERENT THAN MOST IN
THIS BODY AS IT COMES TO THIS
ISSUE.
WE TALK ABOUT.
CHANGES THAT NEED TO TAKE PLACE
IN ORDER TO BRING.
RESOLUTION TO A VERY
[inaudible]
DIFFICULT MATTER.
AND WE TALK ABOUT.
THE KINDS OF CHANGES NEED TO
TAKE PLACE.
WITHOUT HAVING A BALANCED VIEW
OF OF THE CHANGE NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE.
COLLEAGUES I WOULD TELL YOU THAT
WE NEED A CULTURE CHANGE.
AND PART OF THAT CHANGE THAT
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE IS THE
COMMUNICATION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE BECOME SO
POLARIZED IN OUR THINKING AND
THERE'S SO MUCH ANGER AND SO
MUCH EMOTION.
THAT HAS FILLED OUR HEARTS.
AND A LOT BECAUSE OF
MISUNDERSTANDING A LOT BECAUSE
OUR CULTURE HAS.
CHOSEN A PATHWAY THAT IDENTIFIES
AND DIFFERENCES INSTEAD OF
COMMONALITIES WE ARE THE UNITED
STATES.
AND WE NEED TO BECOME UNITED
CULTURE WE NEED TO BECOME UNITED
[inaudible]
STATE.
AND MORE TO THIS ISSUE.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT MY
BIGGEST CONCERN.
IS NOT THAT WE HAVE NOT.
HAD UNNECESSARY VICTIMS BUT THE
WE DIDN'T TURN THE TABLE.
AND MAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNNECESSARY VICTIMS.
BECAUSE IT'S MY OPINION THAT AT
ONE STAGE OF THIS BILL WE WOULD
HAVE DONE THAT.
BUT I WON ALSO THANK SOMEBODY.
THAT I DON'T OFTEN THANK AND
THAT IS OUR GOVERNOR. FOR TO
TAKING A PERSONAL INTEREST IN
THIS MATTER.
AND FOR HAVING A VERY POWERFUL
INFLUENCE ON REACHING WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TODAY.
I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
ONE DESERVED STORY.
AND ONE REASON WHY I AM SO
[inaudible]
EMOTIONALLY ATTACHED. TO THIS
ISSUE.
YOU SEE.
DEADLY FORCE IS SOMETHING THAT
VERY FEW.
PEOPLE CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU NEVER HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGREES
TO PUT THEMSELVES IN THESE
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND WHEN THEY HAPPENED THEY
HAPPENED SO FAST.
AND THE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
ARE SO QUICK.
THE VERY FEW CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT MEANS.
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED SO FAST THAT
YOU DON'T THINK.
YOU REACT.
AND YOU RELY UPON.
THE PIVOTAL PIECE OF WHAT WE
NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON AND THAT
IS TRAINING.
BECAUSE MOST OFFICERS A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF OFFICERS
EVER FACED THIS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING MAYBE.
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
AS DEADLY FORCE IS RARELY
[inaudible]
CALL UPON.
BUT WHEN IT IS IT IS THE MOST
CRITICAL THING THAT CAN HAPPEN
IN ONE'S LIFE.
BOTH FOR THE OFFICER.
AS WELL AS THE PERPETRATOR THE
PERSON THAT'S THE OTHER HALF OF
THE EQUATION.
AND I HAVE TO SHARE WITH YOU.
THE OFFICERS DON'T GO OUT WITH.
WITH.
A PERSPECTIVE A PREDATION WE'RE
NOT PREDATORS SPOKES AND WHEN I
SAY WE HAVE NO LONGER AN OFFICER
BUT WHEN I WAS AN OFFICER THAT
WAS FURTHER STATE FOR OUR MIND.
WE ARE WILLING TO DIE FOR PEOPLE
WE'VE NEVER MET.
AND THAT'S THE COMMITMENT THAT
NEEDS TO BE VALIDATED AND NEEDS
TO BE COMMUNICATED AND NEEDS TO
BE [inaudible]
DISCUSSED.
BECAUSE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
SOMEONE WHO IS A VERY BIG PART
OF MY LIFE.
HAD TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
HE WAS SHOT DURING THE ENCOUNTER.
BUT FROM THAT DAY HE WAS NEVER
THE SAME INDIVIDUAL.
BECAUSE HE HAD TO USE.
THE FORCE HE WAS TRAINED TO USE
AND THAT THAT DECISION AND THAT
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE CALLED UPON.
BUT HE WAS NEVER ABLE TO ADAPT.
TO THAT.
CHALLENGE AND HE ENGAGED IN SOME
DESTRUCTIVE.
COPING MECHANISMS TO THE POINT
TO WHERE HE ENDED UP TAKING HIS
OWN LIFE.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS MATTER
EVERYONE.
I'M THANKFUL THERE I THINK WE'VE
COME AT AND THIS BILL STILL HAS
SOME THINGS TO TROUBLE ME.
BUT IT'S WHAT HAS BROUGHT US
TOGETHER WE NEED TO BE. TO HAVE
BALANCE AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
WHEN WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
BRINGING US TOGETHER AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL DOES THAT
AND SO WILL OR MY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW IT THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT BILL FOR ME TO TO
DISCUSS.
BECAUSE I'M A PARENT OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER I THINK MANY
OF YOU MAY HAVE.
TALKED TO MY SON BEFORE AS HE
VISITS HERE AT THE CAPITOL FROM
TIME TO TIME.
AND BEING BACK IN MY DISTRICT IN
THE CITY OF POMONA.
THE LAST THREE YEARS THERE'S
BEEN TWO OFFICERS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY [inaudible]
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO. TO BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION.
BUT TO CONTINUE HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION AS THIS BILL LOOKS TO
MOVE FORWARD -- WE TALK ABOUT
THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS AND
AND ALL THAT HAVE DIED WHETHER
IT'S STEP ON CLARK.
OR NELLY CORONA -- ONE LIFE THAT
WE LOSE IS ONE TO MANY.
AT OF THE TALK ABOUT PERRANCE
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE NOT ONLY AS
A LAWMAKER BUT COMING UP TO
SACRAMENTO EVERY WEEK.
LOOKING OUT MY SON BEFORE HE
GOES TO WORK.
AND I WONDER AT TIMES I HOPE
THIS IS NOT THE LAST TIME I SEE
MY SON.
AS I COME TO SACRAMENTO.
BECAUSE I WOULD HATE TO GET THAT
PHONE CALL WHILE I'M UP HERE.
THE MY SON HAS DIED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY I THINK OF WHEN MY
COLLEAGUES TALKED ABOUT.
PUTTING THEIR LIFE.
ON THE LINE TO PROTECT US AND I
SEE MY SON DOING THAT AS WELL.
THAT HE WOULD GIVE HIS LIFE TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT HE
SERVES.
NOT ONLY HIM BUT ALL THE OF
OFFICERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- SO WITHOUT SAID.
I JUST HOPE THAT AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE DIALOGUE WITH BOTH
SIDES.
BECAUSE MY SON LIVES MATTERS AS
WELL AND I HOPE TO GOD AND PRAY.
THAT NO ONE ELSE DIES.
ESPECIALLY THAT I NEVER GET THAT
PHONE CALL THE TELLS ME THAT MY
SON WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
A THOUGHTFUL THOUGHTFUL DEBATE.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINETY TWO AND WANT TO THANK ALL
THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
AND AND DISCUSS IT AT THAT
TOUCHING.
COMMENTS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PAST FORTY FIVE MINUTES.
FAMOUS SAYING TELLS US THAT
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED.
BUT WE COULD JUST AS ACCURATELY
SAY THAT ANY PERPETUATION OF
INJUSTICE.
LASTS TOO LONG. FOR DECADES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
SUFFERED INSTANCES OF INJUSTICE
WHEN THEY INTERACT WITH THE VERY
PEOPLE CHARGED WITH PROTECTING
THEIR SAFETY.
NOW THE CAMERAS ARE UBIQUITOUS.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO SEE
THE ON JUST TAX.
THE TIME TO DO SOMETHING IS
OVERDUE.
TODAY.
THE POLICY ON USE OF FORCE IN
CALIFORNIA WAS WRITTEN IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO AND IT NO
LONGER SERVES ITS PURPOSE.
I WANT TO JOIN THE CHORUS IN
THANK YOU THE MEMBER FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR ONCE AGAIN.
ALLOCATING THE ISSUE OF JUSTICE.
AND WE SHOULD BE GRATEFUL THAT
HER PERSISTENCE HAS BROUGHT THIS
TO THE FLOOR TODAY.
TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS THE CHANCE
AS IN SO MANY OTHER POLICY AREAS
TO SET AND NATION LEADING
STANDARD.
WE SHOULD NOT MISS THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO STAND
ON THE SIDE OF TRUE JUSTICE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
DOCTOR WEBER FIVE MINUTES ON THE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU -- MISTER SPEAKER AND
AND TO ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU.
FOR TOLERATING ME OVER THE LAST
YEAR.
IN TERMS OF WORKING ON BUT I AM --
THREE ONE AS WELL AS THREE NINE
TWO AND LISTENING TO ME YEAH I
GOT A CHANCE TO VISIT MANY
PLACES I HADN'T BEEN BEFORE
WHICH IS SOME OF YOUR OFFICES --
AND TO SIT WITH YOU.
AND HOPEFULLY HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS WAS
IMPORTANT.
IT IS OBVIOUS TO SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT THE CURRENT REASONABLE
STANDARD. FOR USING FORCE AND
SPECIFICALLY DEADLY FORCE SET
FORTH IN CALIFORNIA'S AW.
AND US CONSTITUTION DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE SANCTITY OF HUMAN
LIFE OR PROTECT PEOPLE'S
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHTS.
THAT IS WHY COMMUNITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY NEED TO HOLD
THEMSELVES TO A HIGHER STANDARD.
UPDATING THEIR USE OF FORCE
POLICIES TO ADOPT BEST PRACTICES
LIKE REQUIRING DE ESCALATION
WHEN FEASIBLE USING FORCE WHEN
IT IN PROPORTION TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OBJECTIVE.
AND GROUNDING THEIR POLICIES IN
THE SAME TO T. OF LIFE.
THE AUTHORIZING PEACE OFFICERS
TO USE DEADLY FORCE ONLY WHEN
NECESSARY TO DEFEND AGAINST AN
IMMINENT THREAT OF DEATH OF
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
AND CONSIDERING THE ACTIONS OF
OFFICES LEADING UP TO USE OF
FORCE AB.
THREE NINE TO BRING CALIFORNIA
UP TO THAT HIGHER STANDARD.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS SOMEONE
MENTIONED EXPRESSED EARLIER THAT
WE BE FOCUSING ON AYE HINDSIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY VISION IN TERMS OF
WE DID THAT COULD.
MAKING THEM.
BASICALLY SECOND GUESS
THEMSELVES.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS CHANGED
ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE BECAUSE
THAT WAS NEVER THE INTENT.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS ASKED TO
TAKE THIS BILL -- WITH ALL OF
THE SPONSORS AND THE PEOPLE
BEHIND IT.
I TOOK IT WOULD GREAT
[inaudible]
GREAT CONCERN.
BECAUSE MOST OF YOU KNOW I'M AN
EDUCATOR AND I CAME OVER TO DO
EDUCATION STUFF.
AND YET I'VE DONE A LOT OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE WORK AND I GUESS
THAT'S A PART OF IT AS WELL.
BECAUSE OF OF MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF OF ALWAYS FIGHTING
FOR THOSE WHO ARE BEING LEFT OUT
AND BEEN IGNORED IN THE SYSTEM.
AND SO WHEN I WAS ASKED TO TAKE
THIS BILL.
I LOOKED AT IT AND I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT.
DIDN'T SEEM VERY COMPLICATED TO
ME.
SIMPLE SAYING YOU DON'T TAKE
LIFE UNLESS IT'S NECESSARY WHICH
SOUNDS TO BE WHAT MOST OF US
THINK IS THE NORMAL PRACTICE.
BUT AS MANY THINGS THAT I
REALIZE ABOUT TO BE DEFERRED
DIFFICULT.
I REALIZE IS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
THAT WE HAVE MADE CHANGE IN THIS
COUNTRY NOT JUST BECAUSE OF OUR
WORDS AND OUR ACTIONS.
BUT BECAUSE OF OUR SPIRIT.
AND SO I IMMEDIATELY WENT TO MY
CHURCH.
AND I ASKED THEM AND TOLD THEM
WHAT THAT I WAS BEING ASKED TO
DO SOMETHING REALLY DIFFICULT.
THE KIND OF EXPLAINED IT TO ME A
LITTLE BIT.
AND I SAID I WANT YOU TO PRAY
FOR ME.
SO THAT I CAN MAKE A GOOD
DECISION AS TO WHETHER NOT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I SHOULD DO.
IT WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
NEXT WEEK MANY OF THEM CAME TO
ME AND SAY THAT.
WE'RE PRAYING.
THAT YOU WILL DO IT.
WE ARE PRAYING THAT YOU WILL DO
THIS.
THEY SAID BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK
AROUND WHAT IS AVAILABLE YOU
PROBABLY HAVE THE GREATEST
AMOUNT OF STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE.
THEN ANYBODY ELSE THAT WE KNOW.
THAT YOU ALWAYS FIGHT THESE
BATTLES AND YOU HANG IN THERE
AND YOU DON'T GET WORRIED.
AND SO I'VE HAD TO GO TO THE
MANY TIMES OVER THE LAST YEAR.
TO SAY PRAY FOR ME.
HOLD ME UP BECAUSE THIS IS
DIFFICULT.
AND IT HAS BEEN AN AMAZING
EXPERIENCE IS THE HARDEST THING
THAT I HAVE DONE ON THIS FLOOR
IN TERMS OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT IS SO VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO PERSONALIZE
I DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE IT ABOUT
ME I WANT TO MAKE IT ABOUT THE
ISSUES.
AND I WANTED TO BE AWARE OF ALL
THE PIECES THAT WERE PART OF IT
AND SO I THINK THOSE WHO HELPED
WRITE THIS BILL.
I THANK THOSE FAMILIES WHO WHO
BELIEVED IN ME ENOUGH TO IN
TRUST ME. TO MAKE A CHANGE FOR
THEM IN THERE AND THAT THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT
THE DEEP AND PROFOUND HER THAT
SO MANY OF THEM FEEL.
THAT IS YEARS AND YEARS OLD THE
FEELING THAT THEY DIDN'T GET.
THEY WERE AT HER THEY DIDN'T
HAVE JUSTICE AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND THAT WAS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
SO I THANK HIM FOR IN TRUSTING
ME TO CARRY THIS FOR THEM.
I ALSO THINK LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
THEIR OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE THEIR OPPOSITION HELPED
ME TO UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH OF
THEIR CONCERN.
AND HELP ME ALSO TO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THIS HAD TO BE A
BILL THAT HAD SOME BALANCE.
AND I KEPT SAYING THAT THIS BILL
WILL MAKE IT SAFE BEHIND AND IN
FRONT OF THE BAD.
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT THIS
IS NOT A AS SOME OF THE EARLIEST
I SAID THIS WAS NOT ABOUT TO GET
TO BE ILL.
I DON'T WANT TO CATCH FOLKS I
WANT TO PREVENT THE ACTIONS AND
ONE IMPROVE THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT EXISTS IN COMMUNITIES WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT MY COMMUNITY DESERVES TO
HAVE THE LUXURY.
OF CALLING THE POLICE AND
KNOWING THAT LIFE GETS BETTER AS
A RESULT OF THEM COMING.
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T FEEL THAT
THEN THEY WILL NOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
AS I WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
STOOD WITH ME EARLY IN THE GAME
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED WITH.
NINE THREE ONE AND THOSE WHO
HUNG IN HERE THIS TIME.
THE HUNDREDS OF ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE FAMILIES WHO SHARED AND CARE
AND WILL WILLING ALSO TO
SOMETIMES SUSPEND THEIR PERSONAL
DESIRES FOR US TO REACH A
CONCLUSION.
THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE TO THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM.
BECAUSE THEY WANT CHANGE.
THEY WANT TO BE SAFE THEY WANT
TO KNOW THAT THEIR CHILDREN WILL
COME HOME IN THE EVENING.
THEY WANT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT HEALTH AND THEY DON'T WANT
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO LEAVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY WANT GOODS POLICE OFFICERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES TO MAKE
THEM SAFE.
AND SO THIS IS A THIS IS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR ME.
MUCH OLDER THAN A HUNDRED AND
THEN EIGHTEEN OF FIFTY I THINK.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE OH SEVEN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THIS IS A
FOUR HUNDRED YEAR CHALLENGE TO
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BECAUSE OF THE DEFINITION OF OUR
LIVES AND THE BONE ABILITY OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS WHETHER WAS
DEALING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
WEATHER WAS DEALING WITH LYNCH
MOB TO WHAT IT WAS.
IT WAS THAT WHOLE ISSUE THAT WE
HAD ALL OUR LIVES TO ALWAYS BE
CURIOUS.
AND COULD EASILY BE TAKEN
WITHOUT ANY JUSTICE OR ANYONE
FIGHTING BACK.
AND SO I TOOK THIS
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE I RESPECT YOU.
AND I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE WERE DOING.
THAT THIS IS GOING TO MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT IS ALL THE
AND AND AND ALL OF THE ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THIS WILL BE THE MOST
POWERFUL FORCE OF THE STRONG
THIS BILL.
ABOUT WHEN YOU USE LETHAL FORCE
IN ANY STATE.
IN THIS NATION.
AND I'M JUST GRATEFUL TO ALL OF
YOU WHO LISTEN TO ME.
WHO HUNG IN THERE WHO ASKED ME
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER AGAIN?
BUT I'M ALSO BLOW EQUALLY WAS
THANKFUL TO MY CHURCH.
THAT RAY FOR ME.
BECAUSE WHEN THIS WHEN THE WHEN
THE TIDES TURN LAST WEDNESDAY
AND SOMEONE SAID THEY WERE
LOOKING AT TELEVISION AND THEY
SAW THIS.
THEY SAID LOOK AT GOD.
AND THAT WAS PROFOUND FOR THEM
THAT THIS WAS A FORCE THAT
SOMEHOW ANOTHER THIS ONE LITTLE
WOMAN OUT OF EIGHTY THISBILL
WITH HER COLLEAGUES.
AND THAT A FORCE IS ALWAYS BEEN
BEHIND US TO MOVE US FORWARD THE
THE FORCE OF JUSTICE THE FORCE
pTHE FORCE OF BREAKING THIS
NATION A BETTER NATION EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
AND SO I'M THANKFUL TO THEM.
BUT I'M ALSO MOSTLY THANKFUL TO
TO LOOK HERE TO INSPIRE ME EVERY
DAY.
AND THE NAME IS COULD DEAR
ANGELA HILL.
MY GRANDSON'S WAS.
SEVEN FIVE BECAUSE I'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT THAT I NEVER WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
THE LIFE IS IDEALLY.
THEY HAVE GREAT FRIENDS OF ALL
COLORS THEY ENJOYED LIFE AND
THEY BELIEVE AT THIS POINT.
THAT THEY HAVE JUST AS MUCH
RIGHT AND RESPECT AS ANY OTHER
CHILD IN THIS NATION.
AND THAT SHOULD NEVER CHANGE.
AND FOR THEM WOULD YOU WILL AND
COULD DEAR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I VOTE FOR AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE A LUNCH TIME
CAUCUS WE WILL RECESS ON A CALL
THE SPEAKER.
OR TWELVE FIFTEEN TO ONE PM
REPUBLICANS LUNCH IN THE RULES
ROOM THIS IS A RECESSED CENTER
CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
UNTIL ONE PM SESSION WILL RESUME
PROMPTLY AT ONE PM
THE HOUSE
WILL BE BRIEFLY RECONVENED.
WE'LL ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGE AT
THIS TIME.
RAMOS WILL CHANGE FROM NO TO NOT
VOTING ON AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS AS LEGAL
THREE NINETY TWO NOTES NOT
VOTING
MATT THIS AB THREE NINETY
TWO AND VOTE CHANGE.
NO TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
VOTE CHANGE AS FOR ME WELL THREE
NINETY TWO NO IT'S NOT VOTING
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE VERY HAPPY LITTLE
BUSINESS BEFORE US PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
TAKING UP BUSINESS PLEASE RETURN
OF THE FLOOR.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
WE ARE GOING TO THE TOP OF THE
FILE.
I SEE DOCTOR REGULAR AT HIS DESK
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THIS IS AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR BY DR
ARAMBULA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
FOUR BY SIMPLY MEMBER RANDY
ANOTHER SNACK RELATING TO ****
TO THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
DOCTOR RAVEN LE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I PRESENT AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IN STATUTE.
THE PARTNERSHIP'S MISSION IS TO
CONNECT COLLABORATE AND ADVOCATE
AROUND ISSUES FACING THE EIGHT
COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
ITS VISION OF A PROSPEROUS
ECONOMY QUALITY ENVIRONMENT.
AND SOCIAL EQUITY THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE PARTNERSHIP IS MADE UP OF
BOARD MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR THEY MADE UP OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CABINET MEMBERS.
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND BUSINESS LEADERS
FROM EACH SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE TODAY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS PHONE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIX AND
SEVEN WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT AB THREE EIGHTY FOUR
COVERAGE.
SOME PEOPLE THREE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER CHAO ACKLEY TO
PRIVACY MR CHOW.
YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD IMPLEMENT REASONABLE
REGULATIONS FOR THE USE OF
DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEMS
INCLUDING ITEMS KNOWN AS DIGITAL
PILLS.
THESE DIGITAL PILLS CAN COMBINE
INJECTABLE MICROCHIP SENSORS
WITH THE PHARMACEUTICALS AND
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PATCH
DEVISED THAT COLLECTS
INFORMATION AND SINCE IT TO AN
OUT.
SIMILAR TO A FITBIT.
THIS BILL IS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
THIS HOUSE PASSED LAST YEAR.
IT IS A BILL THAT WOULD DEFINE
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY DIGITAL
HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEMS HAS
MEDICAL INFORMATION AND REQUIRED
TO MANUFACTURERS AND OPERATORS
OF THE SYSTEMS TO YOU COOK THEM.
WITH REASONABLE SECURITY
FEATURES.
WHILE TECHNOLOGY STANDS TO
IMPROVE HOW HEALTH CARE IS
DELIVER.
THESE ADVANCEMENTS DO NOT COME
WITHOUT RISKS.
HEALTH AND MEDICAL INFORMATION
IS BY ITS VERY NATURE DEEPLY
PERSONAL AND SENSITIVE.
NEW TECHNOLOGY MAKES MEDICAL
INFORMATION EASILY AND QUICKLY
ACCESSIBLE VIA APPS AND WEBSITES.
AND THAT MEDICAL INFORMATION
HELD BY MOBILE DEVICES IS
PROTECTED UNDER ALL PRIVACY LAW.
MY TEAM AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS AND WE RECENTLY VISITED.
THEIR FACILITY IN HAYWARD.
AND HAD A PRODUCTIVE
pMEDICINE.
THE RISK -- I BELIEVE THERE IS
COMMON GROUND TO BE REACHED AND
I'M GLAD TO SEE HOW THIS BILL
WOULD IMPROVE WITH THE
INDUSTRIES EXPERTISE AND AND PUT.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I PUT -- I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SHALL SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE
.
MISTER CHALMERS A CALL.
THERE WAS ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM. NINE WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM TEN THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ELEVEN AB [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN KERKORIAN.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY INOCULATED
CONSUMER PRIVACY.
MR DAILY EMAIL MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBER
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA -- WHO IS --
WHO WAS ILL?
AND THIS BILL -- THIS BILL
PERMITS BUSINESSES TO COMPLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACT.
WHILE CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WITH
INFORMATION ESSENTIAL TO
PREVENTING FRAUD AND OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THIS IS ALL BASED ON THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
LAST YEAR -- ADDITIONALLY UNDER
THIS BILL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS PERSONAL
DATA CONTENT TO CONTINUE
OPERATING MANDATED PROGRAMS.
AGAIN I HIGHLIGHT MANDATED
PROGRAMS BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL INCLUDES A FOR YOUR
SUNSET DATE AND IS SUPPORTED BY
FOSTER CARE ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND FRAUD PREVENTION
ENTITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ON MISTER COOLIES BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS -- I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
WHAT THIS BILL IS ESSENTIALLY
DOING?
IS EXEMPTING.
THE GOVERNMENT.
FROM THE PROTECTIONS OF THE CCPA.
A WHEN WE PASS THAT LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR THAT LANDMARK
LEGISLATION WE SAID THAT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
NEED THIS PROTECTION THEY NEED
THESE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
AND WE DIDN'T SAY THEY WERE
GOING TO EXEMPT OUT GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS.
YEAH WE'VE BEEN SAYING WE WE
DON'T LIKE HOW BIG BUSINESS.
IS USING OUR DATA.
AND WAY MORE UPSET ABOUT THAT WE
WANT TO PUT.
REGULATIONS AND RESTRICTIONS
UPON THAT. ONE ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS PRIVACY DATE IS
PROTECTED FROM BEING SOLD
WITHOUT THEIR PERMISSION EXCEPT
FOR BUT IN THIS BILL WE'RE
SAYING HEY BUT IF GOVERNMENT
NEEDS THAT FOR A PROGRAM.
NO PROBLEM.
CONSUMER PRIVACY RIGHTS.
TAKE A BACKSEAT. TO GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS AND ALSO THIS WAS
EXPRESSED IN COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE STILL HASN'T REALLY BEEN
ANY SHOWING OF HOUSE CCPA IS
GOING TO SOMEHOW UNDERMINE.
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO DO ITS
JOB AND CARRY OUT PROGRAMS.
CCPA SIMPLY SAYS THAT HEY IF IF
YOU'RE A CONSUMER YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ASK.
WHAT DATA IS BEING COLLECTED
FROM YOU YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
OPT OUT?
OF YOUR DATA BEING TRANSMITTED.
AND THERE'S BEEN NO
DEMONSTRATION YET THROUGH THIS
BILL.
AS TO WHY GOVERNMENT NEEDS THIS
THIS PROTECTION OR TO CARRY OUT
ITS GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS IS
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
NOW THE AUTHORS SAID HE WAS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BUT THIS BILL STILL
HASN'T CHANGED MORE ESSENTIALLY
PASSING OVER TO THE SENATE.
A BIG BLANKET EXEMPTION FOR
GOVERNMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
PRIVACY RIGHTS.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT AND I
DON'T THINK THIS BODY SHOULD BE
OKAY WITH THAT.
I REGION OF THE DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOUR RECOGNIZE YES -- I JOIN MY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I JOIN THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY
CALIFORNIA'S FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY.
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION AN
ELECTRONIC FOUND FRONTIER
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION.
MY CONCERN IS THAT THERE IS JUST
SO MUCH DATA.
IN PARTICULAR GOOGLE MAPS KNOWS
EVERYWHERE I'VE BEEN
[inaudible]
AND I'M SORRY I DO NOT WANT THE
GOVERNMENT TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
AND THIS WOULD GIVE IT TO THEM.
I ASK YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MR DAILY MAKE
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES I HIGHLIGHTED THERE
ARE COUNTLESS SUPPORTERS OF THIS
OF THIS BILL INCLUDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND FOSTER CARE ORGANIZATIONS
AND VARIOUS FRAUD PREVENTION
ENTITIES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON THE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
DALY.
MR DAILY MOVES A CALL OF THE
CALL THANK YOU.
SPEAKING OF CALLS I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL.
ON THE PREVIOUS ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB.
THREE EIGHTY FOUR CLARK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS FLOW.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
TWO KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THE RISER GET MEMBERS WHETHER
YOU'RE ON THE FLOOR YOU'RE NOT
ON THE FLOOR WE GOT A LOT OF
BILLS TO DO WE GOT ANOTHER
HUNDRED FIFTY WE ALL ARE VERY.
WE HAVE WE ALL HAVE A LOT OF
COMMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
OUR TIME IS GOING TO BE TOMORROW
WELL I CAN STICK TO THE TIME
THAT I GAVE YOU BUT IF YOU'RE
NOT ON THE FLOOR.
THINGS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO GO ON CALL YOU'RE
NOT HERE TO TAKE UP YOUR BILL
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US MORE TIME
SO IF YOU CAN MAKE SURE YOU'RE
ON THE FLOOR IN YOUR SEAT VOTING
SO WE'RE NOT HAVING TO CONTINUE
PUT THINGS ON CALL.
EVERYBODY WOULD APPRECIATE IT I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT AND REALLY
HELP THE FLOW BUSINESS.
WHAT HE SAID?
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEMS TWELVE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN OH ONE
COVERAGE.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN A ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY THE CHILD WHERE FOR
SERVICES.
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
PRESENT TO YOU AB THIRTEEN OH
ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
COOLEY.
THE PRIVATE TO AGENCY ADOPTION
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM OR PARK.
WAS CREATED NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR TO HELP INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE
ADOPTION FOR CHILDREN WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE REMAIN IN FOSTER CARE.
CURRENTLY PRIVATE ADOPTION
AGENCIES ARE REIMBURSED UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHILD
FOR COSTS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE UNREIMBURSED WHEN AGENCIES
RECRUIT AND FIND ADOPTIVE
FAMILIES.
SINCE PARKS CREATION AS A STATE
WE HAVE SEEN MAJOR CHANGES WITH
THE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT AND THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM IN CHILD WELFARE.
AB THIRTEEN A ONE SIX TO
RESTRUCTURE THE PARTNER PROGRAM
TO HELP CONTAIN COSTS TO THE
COUNTIES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PRESERVING THIS MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING MECHANISM. FOR PRIVATE
ADOPTION AGENCIES WHO DO THE
CRITICAL WORK OF FINDING PERMIT
FAMILY PLACEMENTS FOR CHILDREN
IN NEED.
UNDER THIS BILL COUNTIES WILL
TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COMPENSATING ADOPT ADOPTION
AGENCIES FOR THEIR OTHERWISE
UNREIMBURSED COSTS IN FINDING
AND PLACING A CHILD WITH A
FAMILY.
WHILE SHIFTING SOME OF THE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE DOWN TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THIS WILL ALSO GIVE THE COUNTIES
AND PROVIDERS MORE FREEDOM FOR
REIMBURSEMENT BECAUSE FOR OTHER
ACTIVITIES AND PERMANENCY
PLACEMENTS AND NOT JUST THE
LIMITED ADOPTION COSTS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
COOLEY.
THANK YOU MS RACY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE --
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE OF
THOSE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ALL FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
WE'RE A FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
FIVE BY MS GONZALEZ CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE BY SHOULD
REMEMBER GONZALEZ AND I RELATE
TO EMPLOYMENT MAKING IT A
PROBATIONER.
FOR MS GONZALEZ EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
BEEN OVER A YEAR SINCE THE
SUPREME COURT HAS DECIDED THE
DYNAMICS DECISION THAT WE'VE ALL
I'M SURE HEARD A LOT ABOUT.
THEY DECIDED AT THAT POINT THAT
THERE HAD BEEN ENOUGH DISCUSSION
ABOUT OF PREVIOUS CARRILLO TEST
AND THAT THEY WERE GOING TO MAKE
IT CLEARER.
WHO WAS AN EMPLOYEE AND WHO WAS
NOT?
THE TRUTH IS COLLEAGUES THAT
MISS CLASSIFICATION IS SOMETHING
THAT OUR STATE HAS BEEN DEALING
WITH FOR DECADES AND AS A RESULT.
WE LOSE UPWARDS OF EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
BECAUSE OF LOST WAGES LOST TAXES
BECAUSE IT EXPENDITURES WE HAVE
TO MAKE IT THE STATE WHEN
BUSINESSES MISCLASSIFIED THEIR
WORKERS.
HIGHER THAT DECISION LEFT A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTIES.
AND SO WHAT AB FIVE DOES IS
CODIFY THAT DECISION SO THAT
WE'RE NOT STUCK IN COURT OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS.
DETERMINING EACH INDIVIDUAL
SMALL INDUSTRY AND HOW IT
APPLIES SINCE THE SUPREME COURT
HAS BEEN CLEAR WE KNOW HOW TO
APPLY.
AND TO ADD CERTAINTY TO OUR
BUSINESSES THAT HISTORICALLY
HAVE BEEN OUTSIDE OF TRADITIONAL
WAGE ORDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTSIDE OF THIS IDEA OF NEEDING
TO PROTECT WORKERS.
THERE INDUSTRIES BY AND FAR
WHERE WORKERS MAKE -- MORE THAN
TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE ARE
STANDARD FOR BEING ABLE TO BE
EXEMPT FROM OVERTIME.
AND WAIT CHEN MEAL BREAKS.
THEIR INDUSTRIES THAT ARE.
THAT CAN ACTUALLY SERVE AS
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES WHERE
THEY'RE NEGOTIATING THEIR OWN
SALARIES NOT JUST ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY BUT ACTUALLY ABOUT
THEIR SAID IN THEIR OWN RATES.
IN ENSURING THAT THEY CAN
OPERATE AND WILL OPERATE AS
RESPONSIBLE SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO OUR BILL IS WORK IN PROGRESS
IT'S NOT COMPLETE.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD IN ORDER TO GIVE
CERTAINTY TO BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. TO GIVE CERTAINTY
THE WORKERS THAT ARE SO THAT WE
SEEK TO PROTECT.
NOT ONLY IN THIS BILL BUT THAT
THE SUPREME COURT SOUGHT TO
PROTECT IN THEIR DECISION.
IN CERTAINTY TO TAXPAYERS THAT
THEY'RE NO LONGER GOING TO BE ON
THE HOOK FOR INDUSTRIES IN FOR
BIG BUSINESSES THEY REFUSE TO
ADEQUATELY PAID THEIR WORKERS.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORKING POOR IN CALIFORNIA.
WORKERS WHO HAVE TO RELY ON
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THAT RELY ON
FOOD STAMPS.
WE HAVE TO RELY ON EMERGENCY
ROOM CARE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE HEALTH CARE.
IN SO MANY OF THESE WORKERS ARE
MISCLASSIFIED AND THAT'S A
BURDEN ON TAXPAYERS THAT WE NEED
TO RELIEVE AS WELL.AB FIVE SIX TO DO THIS.
BY CODIFYING THE DYNAMICS
DECISION BUT PROVIDING CLEAR
EXEMPTIONS FOR CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES.
THAT WE DON'T WORRY ABOUT AS
MUCH ALTHOUGH THEY'LL STILL BE
HELD TO THE PEARL OF STANDARD.
THESE INDUSTRIES INCLUDE
PHYSICIANS INSURANCE AGENTS
FINANCIAL ADVISORS AND DIRECT
SELLERS.
REAL ESTATE LICENSEES.
HAIRSTYLES A BARBER'S TO
FUNCTION AS SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
IN OUR FREE FROM THE DIRECTION
AND CONTROL THE SALON WHERE THEY
LEASE THEIR SPACE.
IN INDIVIDUALS WHO ACTED SMALL
BUSINESSES PROVIDING SERVICES
THAT REQUIRE A LICENSE IN LAW.
DENTISTRY ARCHITECTURE
ENGINEERING AND ACCOUNTING OR
REQUIRE AN ADVANCED DEGREE THAT
INVOLVES SPECIALIZED COURSE OF
STUDY AND IN MARKETING OR HUMAN
RESOURCE ADMINISTRATION.
AGAIN THIS BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
GET. TO EVERYBODY'S -- CONCERNS.
WE PROBABLY CAN'T.
BUT I WOULD ASK YOU TO ASK
YOURSELF ARE WE BETTER OFF.
WITH THIS BILL THEN THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT'S IN THE LOT
TODAY.
AND I THINK WE ARE AND I THINK
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN CONTINUE
TO PUSH IT WE WILL BE EVEN MORE
SO.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
TODAY TO KEEP THIS DISCUSSION
GOING TO KEEP MOVING TO PROTECT
WORKERS TO GIVE CERTAINTY TO
BUSINESSES AND TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MR MEDINA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE LEGISLATURE CANNOT TURN A
BLIND EYE TO COMPANIES WHO
EXPLOIT WORKERS BY INTENTIONALLY
MISS CLASSIFYING THEM AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
THESE COMPANIES CALL THEM
WORKERS SMALL BUSINESSES IT
CONTINUE TO SET THE WORKERS
RATES DIRECT HOW THE WORKER MUST
DO THEIR JOB
AND IMPOSE DISCIPLINE UPON THEM
EVEN WHILE THE WORKER IS DOING
THE MAIN WORK OF THE BUSINESS.
EVERY DAY WORKING CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE BASIC PROTECTIONS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES THIS BILL IS A
NECESSARY STEP.
TOWARD REBUILDING OUR MIDDLE
CLASS.
AB FIVE STRIKES A FAIR BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING CALIFORNIA
WORKERS FROM BEING DENIED THE
RIFLE WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS.
AND HOLDING BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE AND ALLOWING TRUE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND GOOD
COMPANIES TO STAY IN BUSINESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS COMMON SENSE
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA DOCTOR
QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I KNOW WHO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB -- FIVE AS THE MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO SAD.
YOU MAY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THIS
BILL BUT NO BILL AT ALL WOULD BE
FAR WORSE.
WE DON'T WANT THE COURTS MAKING
ALL THESE DECISIONS FRANKLY AS I
READ THE DYNAMICS DECISION.
WAS CLEAR TO ME THAT ALMOST
NOBODY COULD BE AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR.
THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW SOME
PEOPLE TO BE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
FURTHER AS SOON AS THAT DECISION
WAS MADE I HAD MANY MEMBERS OF
MY MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS COME
TO MY OFFICE WHO ARE INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS.
MOSTLY SOUTH ASIANS PARTICULARLY
THOSE FROM THE SIX COMMUNITY.
THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO CONTINUE
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS --
AND I AGREE WITH THEM.
I IN TALKING WITH BUSINESS IS MY
AREA FOR EXAMPLE IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
JUST SILVA GROUP WHICH BILLS
MANY HOMES WILL ONE DAY NEED A
THOUSAND TRUCKERS AND THE NEXT
DAY NEED.
FIFTY AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY.
SO I AM ASKING YOU TO WORK WITH
ME TO GET THIS BILL UP TO THE
SENATE.
AND FIRST ALL TO TO CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE MEMBER FROM
SAN DIEGO ABOUT THE THINGS WE
WANT CONTINUED IN THE BELL.
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE PERFECT
BUT IT'S MUCH BETTER THAN NO
BILL AT ALL SO AGAIN I URGE YOU
TO VOTE I ON AB.
FIVE MR FRAZIER.
YOUR RECKONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY BUT CONTINUE TO HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS.
I LIKE TO SEE THE BILL CONTAINED
A BROADER EXEMPTION FOR BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS.
INSTEAD OF CARVING OUT VERY
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES WE HAVE OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED EMPLOYMENT
CENTERS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND TO DO THIS
WITH THIS BILL.
WOULD BE PUNITIVE.
IF TO INDEPENDENT --
INDEPENDENTLY FOR BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INDUSTRY
WISH TO ENGAGE EACH OTHER IN
PROVIDING SERVICES THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DO SO.
UNDER THE TRADITIONAL
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS SAYS.
MEMBERS I WAS A CONTRACTOR FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS.
PAYING ALL THE FEES [inaudible]
INSURANCES BARNES AND HIRING.
APPROPRIATE CONTRACTORS WOULD
LICENSES AND CLASSIFICATIONS. TO
DO MY SUB WORK.
WHAT I'M HOPING WE DON'T DO?
HIS DESTROY ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
THAT WOULD BE CRIMINAL.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS THE BACKBONE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND AND EMBRACE.
TAKING THE RISK [inaudible]
NOT US.
THEY'RE GOING OUT THERE AND
PUTTING THEIR CAPITAL AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD ON THE LINE EVERY DAY.
AND SO I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT THESE BUSINESSES.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
REGULATION TO SUPPORT AND ALSO
HELP THEM [inaudible]
BUT UNDERSTANDING.
THAT I'VE DONE BILLS FOR MISS
CLASSIFICATION WORKER ANIMAL ALL
POLL OF INDUSTRIES OR ANYBODY
WHO DOES THAT.
JUST LIKE ANYBODY ELSE.
I DO NOT SUPPORT THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
AS A CONTRACTOR WHO PAID ALL OF
HIS FEES.
INAPPROPRIATE MANNERS.
I WANT THIS LEGISLATURE TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE SMALL BUSINESS MATTERS AND
IF WE DON'T SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESS OR BUSINESS IN GENERAL.
STILL HAVE NO REASON TO EMPLOY
THE EMPLOYEES THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO BE PROTECTED.
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS CONCERNED.
HER TALKING TO SEVERAL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS CAUCUS AND
TAKING THE TIME AND
UNDERSTANDING.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND I OR
HER WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS THOSE
AS SHE GOES FORWARD [inaudible]
BUT MEMBERS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO CONTINUALLY EMBRACING
CALIFORNIA IS THE CONCERNS OF
SMALL BUSINESS WITH THIS ALL BE
SUPPORTING AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THIS TIME.
THIS COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
ARISES BOARD OF AB.
FIVE CALIFORNIA'S ESTIMATED TO
HAVE NEARLY TWO MILLION
RESIDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO WORK THE
DEPEND CONTRACTORS.
AFTER DOT NET DECISION CAME OUT
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
CONFUSION AND MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WERE QUITE
CONCERNED.
I RAISE THOSE CONCERNS EARLY ON
ABOUT HOW THIS LAW WOULD AFFECT
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTORS REALTORS
AND TRUCKERS IN MY DISTRICT.
I APPLAUD LABOR BUSINESS FOR
COMING TOGETHER AND WORKING ON A
COMPROMISE BILL.
A BILL TO PROTECT THE WORKERS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES HOWEVER LET'S
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY HELP WITH
THE BROADER EXEMPTION LANGUAGE
WHEN THE BILL RETURNS IN THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS ALL THOSE.
RIVER LEE INCLUDED IN THIS
DECISION [inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB -- FIVE I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT THIS IS AN ACTION THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO TAKE.
I THOUGHT WAS VERY INAPPROPRIATE
FOR THE SUPREME COURT TO ATTEMPT
TO LEGISLATE THIS ISSUE AND IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE
TAKING THIS ACTION.
HOWEVER I HAVE SOME DIRE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
WOULD MEAN FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES.
AND I'D LIKE TO ILLUSTRATE MY
CONCERNS WITH AN EXAMPLE FROM MY
OWN LIFE MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT.
I OWN A VIDEO GAME DEVELOPMENT
STUDIO YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW I
STARTED THAT STUDIO THIRTY YEARS
AGO OUT OF MY DORM ROOM AT CAL
TECH.
I ANSWER ONE ADD ON A BULLETIN
BOARD I STARTED WRITING VIDEO
GAMES AND THIS WAS AT A TIME
WHEN THE GAMES WERE SIMPLE IT
WAS POSSIBLE FOR ONE PERSON TO
DO EVERYTHING.
SO I TRIED TO DO EVERYTHING I
DID THE THINGS THAT I WAS GOOD
AT THE DESIGN OF THE PROGRAMMING
I DID THE THINGS I WAS NOT GOOD
AT THE ART THE ANIMATION AND I
DID THE THINGS.
I'M EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT I
WAS TERRIBLE AT I TRIED TO DO
THE SOUND THE MUSIC MYSELF.
AND MY PUBLISHER CAME BACK TO ME
THEY SAID THIS GAME YOU'RE
WRITING IT'S FANTASTIC IT'S
REALLY FUN TO PLAY WITH THE
MUSIC IS HORRIBLE.
AND SO I THOUGHT TO MYSELF MAYBE
THIS ISN'T AN OPERABLE BUSINESS
STRATEGY TO DO EVERYTHING MYSELF
SO I FOUND ANOTHER STUDENT.
WHO ACTUALLY HAD SOME TALENT IN
MUSIC AND ASKED THEM IF THEY'D
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW DOLLARS
WRITING THE MUSIC FOR MY GAME
AND THEY DID AND THAT ACTUALLY
LEAD TO A WHOLE CAREER FOR THEM?
WRITING MUSIC AND VIDEO GAMES
AND IT LED TO ME MAKING AN
ACCEPTABLE GAME IN THE NEXT GAME
I WROTE.
I CONTRACTED OUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THE STUFF THAT I WASN'T
GOOD AT AND THEN AS WE GOT
BIGGER OVER THE YEARS I
CONTRACTED OUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I WAS GOOD AT AND
THEN EVENTUALLY WE GOT BIG
ENOUGH AND STABLE ENOUGH THAT WE
COULD OPEN.
A BRICK AND MORTAR LOCATION TO
BRING PEOPLE ON HIS EMPLOYEES
AND NOW THIRTY YEARS LATER WE
DON'T DO ANY OUTSOURCING AT ALL
ALL OF OUR WORK IS DONE BY OUR
EMPLOYEES.
BUT IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN TODAY
AND THE CURRENT DYNAMICS
DECISION WAS THE LAW OF THE LAND
IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUBCONTRACT ANY OF THAT INITIAL
GAME THAT I WROTE BECAUSE IT
WOULD VIOLATE THE SO CALLED B.
PILLAR.
IN THE DYNAMICS DECISION WHICH
SAYS THAT THE WORK THAT YOU
CONTRACT CANNOT BE RELATED TO
THE CORE BUSINESS THAT YOU'RE
PERFORMING AND CERTAINLY DOING
MUSIC FOR A GAME OR ANIMATION
FOR GAME IS RELATED.
SO I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT.
AND THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WHAT
I WOULD HAVE BEEN LOTS OF A LOST
MY CONTRACT FOR THAT FIRST GAME.
AND MY COMPANY WOULD NOT EXIST
TODAY.
AND THE MARKET HITS AVOID SO MY
COMPANY WOULD HAVE BEEN STARTED
BY SOMEBODY ELSE.
BUT IN A DIFFERENT STATE OTHER
THAN CALIFORNIA AND HUNDREDS OF
JOBS OF MY COMPANIES GENERATED
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS OF
WILL HAVE BEEN LOST.
AND I WOULD HAVE A PRETTY MINOR
CONSEQUENCE FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
OTHER START UPS THAT HAVE FOUND --
THEIR THEIR GENESIS HERE THAT
WOULD NOT BE SO MINOR I'M
TALKING ABOUT COMPANIES LIKE
APPLE GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HONOR
THAT SPIRIT OF ENTREPRENEURIAL
ISM THAT WE HAVE IN THE PAST AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THAT THIS
BILL IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
THAT WOULD NOT BE TRUE.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
THREE THINGS AS AS BILL MOVES
FORWARD FIRST OF ALL IT'S VERY
CLEAR TO ME.
THAT -- THE DEFINITION OF
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES NEED TO BE
EXPANDED SO THE AUTHORS ACTUALLY
BEEN VERY CONSCIENTIOUS SHE'S
BEEN VERY DILIGENT ABOUT TAKING
A LOOK AT THESE ISSUES.
LAST WEEK THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT
TO THE BILL THAT ADDED AN
EXEMPTION FOR PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES BUT IT'S WORDED VERY
NARROWLY IT'S ONLY IF YOU HAVE.
A LICENSE FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OR IF YOU'RE IN THE PRESS THE
FIELDS OF HUMAN RESOURCES ARE
MARKETING.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE MY
INDUSTRY WOULD BE VERY INSULTED
IF WE TOLD THEM THAT THEY
WEREN'T PROFESSIONALS I THINK WE
NEED TO BROADEN THAT. TO INCLUDE
PEOPLE THAT DO HIGHLY SKILLED
WORK AND A DEGREE OF ADVANCED
DEGREES INDICATION OF THAT BUT
IS NOT A REQUIREMENT OF THAT.
I ALSO THINK THAT THIS BILL
NEEDS A AN EXEMPTION FOR SMALL
BUSINESS IF YOU HAVE NOT VERY
MANY EMPLOYEES MAYBE LESS THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS GROSS REVENUE
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES --
I IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
TO COMPLY WITH THE RESTRICTIONS
PLACED IN THIS BILL I KNOW THAT
WHEN I WAS IN MY DORM ROOM
THERE'S NO WAY I COULD HAVE
HIRED AN EMPLOYEE I DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OUR
WORKERS COMPENSATION -- WAGE
LAWS -- BENEFITS OR VACATION
TIME OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPOSSIBLE SO I
THINK WE SERIOUSLY NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT TO MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE CAN STILL START
BUSINESSES HERE.
AND LASTLY I THINK THAT THIS
BILL BADLY NEEDS A BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS EXEMPTION.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ENJOY BEING
EMPLOYEES BUT THERE ARE ALSO
SOME PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
LIKE BEING INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
AND IF YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE AND YOU'VE TAKEN THE
TROUBLE TO INCORPORATE YOUR OWN
COMPANY OR TO USE VIOLENCE A DBA
AND DO BUSINESS AS A SOLE
PROPRIETORSHIP IF YOU HAVE A
BUSINESS LICENSE.
THEN I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR CURRENT MODE OF WORKING.
SO I UNDERSTAND THIS IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS THIS IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO ACT ON
BUT I HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY WORDED I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
MISTER DALLI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I TOO MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY IMPACT MY OWN
BUSINESS.
I ALONG WITH MY CALLING FROM BIG
BEAR HAD THE SAME.
SITUATION WE HARVEST OUR CROPS.
AND IN TIME WE NEED TO HARVEST
THOSE CROPS WE HAVE TO GET ABOUT
A CERTAIN TIME BEFORE THE
WEATHER CHANGES.
AND SO.
UNFORTUNATELY I AM IN THE
TRUCKING BUSINESS BECAUSE I
COULDN'T GET TRUCKS WHEN I
NEEDED TRUCKS TO MOVE MY
COMMODITIES.
AND AT THAT TIME IN YOUR WEEK.
HIGHER ON INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS -- AND WE MAY
ACTUALLY OWN THE TRAILER AND
THEY BRING THE POWER UNIT IN THE
TRACTOR.
TO PULL OUR COMMODITIES IN SO
THIS ONE AREA THAT'S GOING TO
REALLY IMPACT MYSELF AND MY
NEIGHBORS -- UNDER THIS RULE I
SEE I I'VE BEEN WATCHING THE
AMENDMENTS I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING.
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO IRON OUT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES -- BUT
SMALL BUSINESSES REALLY NEEDED
TO HAVE A BREAK IN THIS AREA.
AND NUMBER -- TWO ALSO I CHECKED
HIM IMAGE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
ALLOW THEM TO GO BACK AND READ
THROUGH AND UNDER THE ORIGINAL
CARRILLO LAW WE WERE.
ASSUMING WE WERE DOING THE RIGHT
THING BUT IF WEEK RETROACTIVE
BACK WE'RE GONNA BE A LOT OF OF
FOLKS IN THE WORLD OF THE LAW
THAT WILL BE GOING AFTER
BUSINESSES WHO AT THAT TIME
THOUGHT THEY WERE DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR --
THERE A LOT OF US WHO WORKED. TO
OBEY THE LAWS AND THEY CHANGE
RAPIDLY AROUND HERE AND TRYING
TO KEEP UP WITH THEM AS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IS VERY DIFFICULT
SO AT THIS POINT -- I WILL BE
NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL AND LOOK
FOR TO SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN
THE SENATE AND HOPEFULLY -- BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT WHERE WE CAN
HELP.
A SMALL BUSINESSES STAY IN
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ALLEY I SEE A
NUMBER OF MICROPHONES MEMBERS
I'D ASK YOU KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
VERY CONCISE DOCTOR EGGMAN.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I ALSO WANT TO THINK -- THE
AUTHOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR HER
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
MR CLASSIFYING VULNERABLE
WORKERS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM NOT
JUST IN THIS STATE BUT ACROSS
THE NATION I HISTORICALLY AND
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
AND CLEARLY AS THE NATURE OF
WORK CONTINUES TO CHANGE -- AS
WE EVOLVE IN OUR ECONOMY OUR
LAWS NEED TO EVOLVE TO TO
MAINTAIN THAT SO I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE --
AS THE AUTHOR STATED MORE WORK
WILL CONTINUE TO BE DONE
REPRESENTING AND DISTRICT IS
LARGELY AGRICULTURE AND IS
MISSED BY.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER TALKED
ABOUT.
MONIES COME IN THEY COME OUT AND
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ENTREPRENEURS OWNER OPERATED
TRUCKERS WHO ARE OUT THERE
HOLDING COMMODITIES.
SHORT TERM SOMETIMES YOU KNOW.
GOT A JOB IT NEEDS TO BE FILLED --
IT WITH A LOT OF THE UNCERTAINTY
WE HAVE KNOWING THAT YOU CAN GET
YOUR CROPS THE MARKET ON TIME OR
THINGS DELIVERED WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE IS.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO AS THIS
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD I LOOK
FORWARD TO START HAVE CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION HOPE ALL THE
PARTY STAY AT THE TABLE AS WE
TALK ABOUT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OWNER OPERATED --
AND I LOOK FOR TO THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD TODAY AND IS
CONTINUE TO HAVE FRUITFUL
DIALOGUES GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
IS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE HOWEVER I
BELIEVE THAT AB FIVE SHOULD BE
BROADER RATHER THAN CARVING OUT
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES.
MANY AND MANY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS ARE TEACHERS WHO
CHOOSE TO WORK AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS SUCH AS TUTORS AND
THEY DO SO IN ADDITION TO THEIR
FULL TIME JOBS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING
THE SUMMER WHEN THESE TEACHERS
HAVE MORE TIME TO WORK
INDEPENDENTLY WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE SUCH
IMPORTANT WORK TO SUPPLEMENT
THEIR INCOMES.
WHILE I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I WANT TO SEE BROADER
EXEMPTION LANGUAGE WHEN THE BILL
RETURNED FROM THE SENATE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE AN
ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT A
NUMBER OF MY OF MY COLLEAGUES.
HAVE HAVE SHARED I HAVE BEEN
HEARING FROM SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT AND
MANY OF WHOM -- BUT THERE ARE
WOMEN THERE WOMEN OF COLOR THEY
ARE ENTREPRENEURS -- AND I THEY
BELIEVE IN THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
IT IS A PART OF THE YOU KNOW
THEIR OWN DESTINY IN TERMS OF
THEIR FUTURE AND THEIR ABILITY
TO TO SUSTAIN THEMSELVES AND AND
BENEFIT THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BECOME
EMPLOYEES MANY OF THEM HAVE
SHARED THAT THEY ACTUALLY TRIED
THIS AS A RESULT OF WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE DYNAMICS
DECISION.
AND IT FAILED MISERABLY IN TERMS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES -- WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROTECTING
THESE WOMEN THESE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THESE ENTREPRENEURS --
THEY'RE LOOKING TO FILL THEIR
FUTURE WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PROTECTING WORKERS
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
ALLOWING WAGE THEFT.
AND OTHER ATROCITIES THAT
CONTINUE TO DEMEAN AND
DEMORALIZE WORKERS -- TO TAKE A
FACT IN THIS ECONOMY SO I AM
HOPING THAT -- MORE
CONVERSATIONS CAN HAPPEN
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THOSE IN THE PERSONAL CARE
INDUSTRIES BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WAS COUNTY MISTER
KALRA.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU
KNOW CODIFYING DYNAMAX IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE -- FOR WORKERS
AND RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS LIKE
THREADING. TEN NEEDLES AT ONE
TIME I REALLY WANT TO THANK AND
COMMEND THE AUTHOR -- AT EVERY
COMMITTEE LEVEL THERE'S BEEN
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS AND
EXEMPTIONS AND THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE -- I WOULD STRONGLY
SUGGEST ESPECIALLY TO THOSE THAT
ARE RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE UP TO
READ DYNAMAX UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
WOULD DO TO OUR EMPLOYERS -- IF
WE DO NOTHING ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THAT SUBSEQUENT COURT CASE THAT
MADE IT RETROACTIVE THERE ARE --
BUT MANY HUNDREDS OF LAWSUITS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE BEING
INITIATED BECAUSE OF THE
CONFUSION AND BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY WITHOUT THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD AND CONTINUING TO
BE WORKED ON IN TERMS OF ADDING
APPROPRIATE.
AMENDMENTS AND FLEXIBILITY OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND OUR
WORKERS GOING TO BE LEFT IN
LIMBO -- UNLIKE ANY SITUATION
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN TERMS OF THE
LEGAL SYSTEM AND SO -- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR I WANT TO
THANK.
EVERYONE THAT'S GIVEN
SUGGESTIONS AND ADVICE I'VE MET
MYSELF WITH MANY MANY DOZENS OF
INDUSTRIES I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR VOICING THEIR CONCERN AND
CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTIONS AND I
BELIEVE VOTING FOR AB BY TODAY
ALLOWS US THAT CONTINUED.
CONVERSATION IN OVER TO THE
SENATE BUT I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY MANY EMPLOYERS IN
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE DEMANDING --
MORE CLARITY AND I THINK AB FIVE
ALLOWS US OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
CLARITY AND PROTECT WORKERS AND
FOR THAT I STRONGLY SUGGEST MY
ABOUT.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MRS ALL SHE MAKE CLOTHES.
AND CLOSE I JUST WANT TO BRING
LIGHT TO A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WERE SAID BECAUSE I'M A LITTLE.
CONFUSED BY SOME COMMENTS AND I
I FEAR THAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND NUMBER ONE THE
DYNAMICS RULING AND WHAT IT
MEANS TO PUT IT INTO LAW.
NOTHING IN DYNAMAX OR IN LAW
WILL PREVENT -- TEN NINETY NINE
INTERACTIONS I MEAN THERE ARE
ACTUALLY VALID INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THERE ARE VALID
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT INTERACT
WITH OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES AND
AND MAY PAGE OTHER THROUGH A TEN
NINETY NINE THIS WILL NOT
PREVENT THAT THERE IS A
CONTRACTOR SUBCONTRACTOR
RELATIONSHIP THAT WILL NOT
CHANGE.
SO THE LOT OF THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP TODAY I THINK --
COULD BE RESOLVED IF MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO COME TO MY OFFICE
AND SIT DOWN WITH ME WE CAN HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS I REALLY AYE
EVERYBODY WAS ASKED FOR IT I
I'VE TRIED.
TO ACCOMMODATE -- AS PART OF THE
PERSONAL CARE INDUSTRY THAT --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
PRODUCT WE I THINK WE OUTLINED
PRETTY CLEARLY WHAT THAT'S GOING
TO LOOK LIKE FOR HAIR STYLIST WE
DO PLAN. TO TO BROADEN NOT IN
THE PERSONAL CARE -- INDUSTRY WE
WE STARTED WITH HERE SALAS
BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S EXISTING
WAGE ORDER LIKE EVERYTHING WE
STARTED WITH IT IT'S THINGS THAT
ARE IN EXISTING WAGE ORDERS
WHETHER THEY'RE DOCTORS OR
INSURANCE AGENT SO.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING FROM THAT.
ASPECT IN ASK THINGS ARE BROUGHT
FOR WE CONTINUED TO WORK ON THIS.
THE WHEN IT COMES TO TRUCK
DRIVERS I THINK WE HAVE TO SAY
THIS THAT IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
I HAVE TO BE HONEST PROBABLY THE
MOST DIFFICULT ISSUE.
I'VE EVER TRIED TO DEAL WITH AND
THE REASON FOR THIS IS BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY THE DYNAMICS
DECISION DON'T WITH TRUCK
DRIVERS WE KNOW THAT IT'S WHEN
THE MOST MISCLASSIFIED
INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT 82% A POOR TRUCK DRIVERS
ARE CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND WE KNOW ABOUT
80% OF OUR MISCLASSIFIED.
SO HOW WE MAKE EXEMPTIONS OR IF
WE DO FOR INDEPENDENT -- OWNER
OPERATORS WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST PROVIDING
ANOTHER AVENUE BY WHICH
COMPANIES CAN CONTINUE.
BASICALLY ARE AT PREVENTS
WORKERS FROM BEING ABLE TO BE
HAVE A SUSTAINABLE LIFE.
ANDSO -- THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY
IS ONE THAT HAS BEEN COMPLEX
IT'S BEEN TOUGH I I HAVE
PROMISED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS I I WANT TO GET
THERE AND I DON'T WANT ANYONE
WHO'S INVESTED A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO A TRUCK.
TO NOT BE ABLE TO USE THAT TRUCK
I AM COMMITTED TO GETTING TO
SOMETHING ON TRUCKERS BUT I WANT
PEOPLETO UNDERSTAND JUST HOW
COMPLEX THIS IS DYNAMICS WAS
WRITTEN BECAUSE THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THE DECISION
ITSELF IS IMPORTANT WE'RE
TALKING I'M A ONE MORE THING
JUST TO BE CLEAR BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS INTERACTION AND WE CAN
CLARIFY THIS IN THE SENATE THERE
IS NOTHING THAT WILL PREVENT A
BIT OF A GENUINE SMALL BUSINESS.
FROM FROM CONTRACTING WITH OR
OUTSOURCING TWO A GENUINE SMALL
BUSINESS WHAT WE WANT TO PREVENT
IS THIS DISTINCTION WHERE
INDIVIDUAL WORKERS WHO TRULY
AREN'T SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE BEING IDENTIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY.
AND THAT SHOULD WORRY YOU
BECAUSE IT COST ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT COST US ALL.
BECAUSE WHEN SOMEONE DOESN'T
HAVE HEALTH CARE AND THEY'RE
HURT ON THE JOB IN THEIR IN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR.
BECAUSE THE MERCHANTS THE ROOM
AND WE ALL PAY FOR THAT.
WHEN SOMEBODY LOSES THEIR JOB AS
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO ZERO
PROTECTIONS THEY DON'T HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND WE
ALL PAY FOR THE SERVICES THAT
THEY HAVE TO RELY ON?
WHEN SOMEBODY DOESN'T HAVE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE OUR PAID SICK LEAVE
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T WORK IN
SOMETIME HAVE TO RELY ON WELFARE
OR FOOD STAMPS SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING FREE LUNCH FOR THEIR
KIDS WE ALL PAY FOR THAT?
IN SOME OF THE COMPANIES
ENGAGING IN THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR WHO ARE REFUSING TO
TREAT THEIR WORKERS THE WAY WE
EXPECT EMPLOYERS TO TREAT
WORKERS IN THE SOCIAL CONTRACT
THAT WE HAVE.
BETWEEN EMPLOYMENT WORKERS AND
TAXPAYERS SOME OF THOSE
COMPANIES ARE DOING JUST FINE.
THEIR CEOS MAKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WHILE WE'RE SUBSIDIZING AS
TAXPAYERS THEIR WORKERS.
THERE IS SOMETHING CRITICALLY
WRONG WITH THAT SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
THIS OUT IN EVERY ASPECT THAT IT.
ALL AND ANY OF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE THAT WE CAN MAKE WE
WILL MAKE.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN MIND.
BECAUSE OUR CONSTITUENT
TAXPAYERS DON'T DESERVE TO
SUBSIDIZE BIG BUSINESS.
AND IT QUITE HONESTLY WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY PLAYS BY
THE SAME RULES.
SO THIS IS A BILL THAT -- IT
KIND OF CONFUSES ME WHEN PEOPLE
SAY I HOPE YOU KEEP WORKING ON
THIS BUT I HOPE YOU BOTH KNOW IF
YOU WILL NO I CAN'T KEEP WORKING
ON THIS.
AND THAT MEANS THE DYNAMAX
RULING STANDS.
AND THE RETROACTIVITY COURT CASE
STANDS AND THAT MEANS THERE ARE
GOING TO BE A TON OF LAWSUITS.
AND A TON ACOSTA BUSINESS.
SO WHAT ARE YOU CARE ABOUT
WORKERS AS YOUR PRIMARY CONCERN
LIKE I DO.
OR WHETHER YOU CARE ABOUT
BUSINESS IS BECAUSE YOU WANT
CERTAINTY AND YOU WANT TO DRESS
RETRACTED BEING YOU WANT TO
DRESS.
SOME SORT OF CERTAINTY OR
WHETHER YOU JUST CARE ABOUT
TAXPAYERS PICKING UP THE SLACK
FOR COMPANIES THAT DON'T DO
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT ANY OF THOSE
YOU SHOULD BE VOTING YES TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS SERVICE OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL IT ABOUT ICE
FIFTY THREE KNOWS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP SUPPORT
SUPPORT ITEMS.
IF YOU HAVE A SUPPORT SUPPORT
ITEM COMING UP IN THE FILE
PLEASE BE READY TO PRESENT.
WHEN I CALL UPON YOU FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB ONE THIRTY FIVE
CERVANTES CLERK WILL READ?
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER CERVANTES
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE CRIMES MR
BY THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IMPORTANT BILL WILL
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE THAT HAS
EMERGED WITH THE GROWING USE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA BY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RINGS.
AB ONE THIRTY FIVE WILL GIVE
LONG FORCED AND MORE TOOLS TO GO
AFTER MIDDLE MEN AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RINGS BY MAKING IT A
FELONY TO CONTACT A MINOR. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ENGAGING IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
CATCHER MADE ON THE ADAM CLARK
LOCAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIRED BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY THIS IS DOCTOR RAM LEFT
FILE I'M THIRTY AB SEVEN FIFTEEN
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE AMERICA
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB SEVEN FIFTEEN AIMS TO RAISE
THE INCOME LEVEL OF THE AGED AND
DISABLED MEDICAL PROGRAM CALLED
THE A AND D. PROGRAM. TWO
HUNDRED AND 38% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE ACA
MOST ADULTS CAN NOW QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL IF THEY HAVE AN INCOME
BELOW A HUNDRED AND 38%.
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THE ACA HOWEVER DID NOT CHANGE
THE INCOME LEVEL FOR THE MEDIC
HOW AGE AND DISABLED PROGRAM.
THIS ALSO MEANS THAT A SIXTY
FOUR YEAR OLD ADULT WITH FREE
MEDICO CAN LOSE IT THE DAY THAT
THEY TURN.
SIXTY FIVE THIS CREATES A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO HEALTH
CARE FOR SENIORS TO ACCESS
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE FORCED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING FOR RENT
AND FOOD. FOR THEIR MEDICAL ALL
AB SEVEN FIFTEEN WOULD ENSURE
THAT THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION
OF LOW INCOME SENIORS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY AND CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE MEDICAL
CARE.
PLEASE HELP US TO AVOID THE
ELDER PENALTY BY VOTING ON A ON
AB.
SEVEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULAR SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK LOCAL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE.
ICE FIFTY NINE OH ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
WORKING THROUGH THE FILE THROUGH
SUPPORT SUPPORT ITEMS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN IS AB NINE TWENTY
SIX MISTER O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
SOME PEOPLE NINE TWENTY SIX BY
SOME MEMORABLE DON JUAN ACCOLADE
OR REVENUE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM PLEASED RISEN AB
NINE TWENTY FIVE WHICH WILL
ELIMINATE THE CAP ON THE OIL
TRUSTS FUN.
AND HELP ENSURE THE CLEANUP OF
ABANDONED OIL WELLS.
THE LONG BEACH AYE THAILAND'S IS
HOME TO THE WILMINGTON OIL FIELD
AND ONE OF THE LARGEST OIL AND
NATURAL GAS FIELDS.
IN OUR NATION.
BECAUSE THESE OPERATIONS ARE
LOCATED ON STATE LANDS THE STATE
RECEIVES A SHARE OF THE NET
PROFITS FROM THESE OPERATIONS
AND WILL BE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE. FOR CLEANING UP THE
SITE WHEN OPERATIONS CEASE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE LAND HAVE
THAT THE STATE LANDS HAS THE
FUNDS NECESSARY TO DECOMMISSION
THE WELLS AND MITIGATE POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF PORTION.
OF THE STATE'S PROFITS ARE
DEPOSITED IN THE OIL TRUST FUND.
HOWEVER THIS ONE HAS A CAP OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT FALLS FAR SHORT.
OF THE OVER NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ESTIMATED COSTS OF
CLEANING UP THE OIL WELLS AB
NINE TWENTY FIVE ELIMINATES THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CAP
ON THE FUN.
WHICH ALLOW THE FUND TO GROW AND
COVER THE EVENTUAL COST OF OIL
WILL CLEAN UP I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THE RESTAURANTS IN YOUR
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
FOR HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TELEVOTE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE WORKING THROUGH
SOME SUPPORT SUPPORT BILLS.
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE IS AB TEN
FORTY TWO BY DR WOULD CORKERY.
SOME MIDDLE TEN FORTY TWO BY
SOME MEMORABLE WOULD BACK LETTA
MEDICO DOCTOR WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TEN FORTY TWO LITTLE WOULD
MAKE TWO CHANGES TO ALLOW
SENIORS ON MEDICARE OUT TO
RETURN FROM A LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY. TO A HOME OR APARTMENT
THEIR COMMUNITY WHEN THEY ARE
ABLE FIRST EVER INCREASED WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE HOLE BUT KEEP
ALLOWANCES SENIORS CAN RETURN TO
THEIR HOME.
SO I WAS IS CURRENTLY TWO
HUNDRED AND NINE DOLLARS A MONTH
IT'S BEEN THAT AMOUNT FOR YEARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THAT AMOUNT
IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO
MAINTAIN A HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
SECOND IT WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW
TRANSITIONAL NEEDS FUND FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO LEAVE A
NURSING HOME BUT CAN'T MOVE OUT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A PLACE
TO GO.
AB TWENTY AT TEN FORTY TWO HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
SIT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS FILE ITEM. FORTY THREE
FIVE FORTY THREE IS AB TEN FIFTY
ONE BY MS SMITH CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER SMITH AN ACCOLADE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TEN FIFTY ONE IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IT WOULD RE ESTABLISH AN
EXEMPTION INITIALLY PUT THE
STATUTE AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
SIX FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING FACULTY TO EXCEED THE
PART TIME FACULTY COURSE LOAD.
ALLOWING FOR MORE CONTINUITY IN
CLINICAL NURSING EDUCATION.
THE AGING BOOMER POPULATION THE
INCREASE OF CHRONIC HEALTH
ISSUES LIKE OBESITY AND DIABETES
AND A GROWING EMPHASIS ON
PREVENTIVE CARE HAS CALIFORNIA
POISED TO EXPERIENCE DRAMATIC
GROWTH IN THE NEED FOR NURSES.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE WOULD PERMIT
FULL TIME CLINICAL NURSING
FACULTY OR PART TIME CLINICAL
NURSING FACULTY TO BE EMPLOYED
BY ANY ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT FOR UP TO FOUR
SEMESTERS OR SIX QUARTERS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE TO
SERVE AT LEAST AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE STUDENTS
PER YEAR IN NURSING PROGRAMS AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE HIRING OF
PRACTICING LICENSE NURSES.
WILL BRING VALUABLE AND RELEVANT
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE TO THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU MISS WITH C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
COR CLUB THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
I RECOGNIZE A FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY IS JOIN US ON THE
GREEN CARPET THE HONORABLE JOHN.
FOR WELCOME BACK SIR.
MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING OF
SUPPORTS FORUMS FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR A. B. TEN FIFTY TWO BY MR
CHIU CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KANSEN CHU AN
ACCOLADE A PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING.
MR CHILL.
THANK YOU MISTER ADDRESS
SPEAKERS SAM MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
STRUCTURES PERCENT AB TâM FIFTY
TWO WHICH REQUIRES THAT PEACE
OFFICERS RECEIVE STENDER.
AND PERIODIC TRAINING ON HATE
CRIMES THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRED BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALL PEACE OFFICERS TO
WATCH A HATE CRIME VIDEO.
THAT WAS SO DEVELOP AND RELEASED
BY THE POST.
AND THIS VIDEO WILL BE
INCORPORATED INTO THE BASIC
TRAINING CURRICULUM FOR THE NEW
CADETS AS WELL.
AB TEN FIFTY TWO ALSO REQUIRES
ALL PEACE OFFICERS TO TAKE A
REFRESHMENT COURSE ON HATE
CRIMES EVERY THREE YEARS AND UP
POSTED DEVELOP AND DO YOU
REFRESH COURSE.
DISCOURSE WOULD INCLUDE THE
TOPIC OF HATE CRIME LAW ALL
INVESTIGATION.
TRANS AM BASS.
FORSMAN PRACTICES THIS BILL HAS --
BART BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND PASS
A POLICY COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK MISS CHIU SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB UP IN THE
ROLE[inaudible]
VETERANS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE --
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
FORTY SIX WE'RE TAKING A FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY DR WOULD CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SOME REMEMBER WOULD ACCOLADE
AMERICA DOCTOR WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
PREVENT LOW INCOME SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN BOTH MEDICARE AND
MEDICARE FROM LOSING THEIR
MEDICAL COVERAGE WHEN THE STATE
BEGINS TO PAY THEIR MEDICARE
PART B. PREMIUMS.
AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN BY WITH BY
HOLDING PEOPLE IN THE SAME PLACE
THEY WERE WHEN THEY APPLIED SO
THEY DON'T BOUNCE OFF THEIR
MEDICARE COVERAGE THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK GOD WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE IS AB TEN NINETY
EIGHT BY MISTER O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
CLICK READ.
SOME PEOPLE TEND NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL WHEN
OTHERS NOT RELATE A SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS INTO CAREERS HERE
UP TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED PERCENT AB TEN NINETY
EIGHT IN NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE VOTERS PASSED THE ADULT USE.
OF MARIJUANA ACT.
A PORTION OF THE TAXES GENERATED
THROUGH THE LEGAL SALES OF
CANNABIS WILL BE DEPOSITED INTO
A YOUTH ACCOUNT.
IS A CALVIN EDUCATION PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT
OF YOUTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CIRCUMVENTS
THE PROCESS IDENTIFIED IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FOR THE
UC THESE FUNDS BUT RATHER IT
SEEKS TO PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
SPENT WISELY AND THE DESIRED
OUTCOMES ARE CLEARLY STATED.
THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDS GENERATED
THROUGH THE TAXES ON THE LEGAL
SALE OF CANNABIS ARGUES AN
EFFECTIVE EFFECTIVE MANNER I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
A MISTER NOZZLE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LIBERAL [inaudible]
SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF
CLARK
WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY SIX DOES YOUR ON
THE BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WORKING THROUGH SUPPORT
SUPPORTS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN GRAYSON
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE FIREFIGHTERS MR GRAYSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN IT'S A
BILL TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY AND USE OF PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES BY ALLOWING FOR
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN FOR TRAIN PEER SUPPORT
PERSONNEL.
AND THEIR FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS
AND APPROVED PEER SUPPORT
TRAINING PROGRAM AND MEANINGFUL
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS WILL
HELP YOUR SUPPORTERS IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL HIGH RISK SITUATIONS
BEFORE CRISIS EVENT OCCURS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THERE WAS GRAYSON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE IS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY MR GRACE
INCORPORATE.
SOME OF ELEVEN SEVENTEEN BY SOME
IMMIGRATION OTHERS NOT RELATED
PEACE OFFICERS GRAYSON YOU MAY
GET OPEN MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN ITS COMPANION BUILD AB.
ELEVEN SIXTEEN RELATING TO PEER
SUPPORT FOR PEACE OFFICERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS GRAYSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO IS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO BY MISTER
FRAZIER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
ACCOLADE A SPECIAL EDUCATION.
MR FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE A
DISTINCT KIND OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
THAT ONLY SERVE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES OR HIGH NEEDS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE SPECIALIZED NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE THE APPROPRIATELY
TRAINED STAFF TO EDUCATE AND
CARE FOR OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
YOU ALSO GET THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
MONITOR AND PROTECT STUDENTS
ACROSS THE NON PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN I HAVE
BROUGHT TOGETHER THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE ALL AGREED
ADDITIONAL MEASURES WILL ENHANCE
THE SAFETY OF STUDENTS ATTENDING
ON PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLLABORATION INPUT OF ALL
PARTIES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
FIGURES FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPOOL OF THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRABLE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TELL ABOUT
AYE.
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE AN FIFTY FOUR THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE A. B.
TWELVE FORTY NINE BY MISTER MAY
CHECK CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE FORTY NINE BY
SOME MEMBER RATES ON AN ACCOLADE
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS THIS
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE
FORTY NINE REPRESENTS AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO CONTAIN
SKYROCKETING HEALTHCARE COSTS.
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE TO FIVE
YOUR PILOTS THE PAIR EMPLOYER
HEALTH BENEFIT PLANS WITH
ORGANIZED INTEGRATED PROVIDERS
IN A MORE ALIGNED RELATIONSHIPS.
TO PRODUCE BETTER CARE AT LOWER
COSTS THE PILOTS WOULD INCLUDE
RISK BEARING PROVIDERS THAT ARE
MONITORED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE FOR FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY IN OPERATIONS.
SELF FUNDED EMPLOYER PLANS WOULD
USE WRIST BASED PAYMENT
MECHANISMS WITH THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR SERVICES
RATHER THAN PURE FEE FOR SERVICE
COMPENSATION.
A STUDY BY THE UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PREDICTED THAT THIS TYPE OF
MODEL COULD REDUCE HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES BY AN ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED AND TEN BILLION OVER TEN
YEARS -- CONTAINING THE RISING
COST OF HEALTHCARE REQUIRES A
NEW WAY OF THINKING AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
MAIENSCHEIN SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL PAROLE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE RESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY A FILE ON A
FIFTY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN AB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT CORKERY.
WE WILL TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN
ACCOLADE A CANNABIS.
MR LACKEY.
YES -- SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
AND A HALF ASSEMBLYMAN COOLEY.
AND WE NEED LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE A CLEAR
DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHO LEGAL
ILLICIT MARKET.
CANNABIS PLAYERS BY FULLY
IMPLEMENTING THE TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM WHEN I WOULD ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THERE IS A LACKEY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT AYE
[inaudible]
SIXTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT A. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX CROCKERY.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE NINETY SIX BY
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACCOLADE
TO ON THE IMMIGRANT ECONOMY.
MS GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY SIX WOULD ESTABLISH THE
TAX RECOVERY IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY CRIME ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
COMBAT BADDIE AN UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
EVERY DAY THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TAKES A TOLL IN SOME THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND ULTIMATELY TAXPAYERS
ARE LEFT SUBSIDIZING ILLEGAL
EMPLOYMENT THIS MULTI AGENCY
APPROACH OUR STATE AGENCIES WILL
BE ABLE TO PULL RESOURCES AND
USE OUR RESPECTIVE EXPERTISE. TO
PROSECUTE THOSE THAT PREY ON THE
MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS AND
AVOID PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE IN
TAXES AB TWELVE NINETY SIX HAS
NOT RECEIVED A SINGLE NO VOTE IN
A SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO SB
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO OR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH PASSED
LEGISLATUREWITHOUT A NO VOTE AS
WELL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE -- CLUB
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS SERVICE OUT OF THEM ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS WERE CEREMONY CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL.
INTELLIGENT OF I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE IS AB.
THIRTEEN OH THREE SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL WHEN
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
MR O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND PRESERVE IT PLEASE
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN OH THREE
WHICH INCREASES FUNDING FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TO HOLD FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
WITH A ONE TO ONE LOCAL MATCH
THIS BILL ALSO CONSOLIDATES CAGE
WILL SEE T. PROGRAMS BY SHIFTING
TO K. TWELVE PORTION OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
DUCATION.
THIS WILL AVOID SIGNIFICAN
HURDLES AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS AT BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS.
HIGH QUALITY CT PROGRAMS IN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE CRUCIAL TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS GAIN THE SKILLS
THEY NEED. TO ENTER THE
WORKFORCE OR EMBARK ON POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
THE STRENGTH OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY DEPENDS UPON A SKILLED
WORKFORCE IN CT PROGRAMS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF BUILDING THAT
WORK FORCE I ASKED FOR AYE VOTE
ON ABC. THIRTEEN OH THREE THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS SIDE OF THEM
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE IS FILE ITEM SIXTY AB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE QUICK READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BY THE COMMITTEE OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS INOCULATED DISABLED
VETERANS.
IS -- WHEN?
YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE STEMS FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO MINIMIZE THE
OCCURRENCE OF PROGRAM ABUSE
INVOLVING DVB SUBCONTRACTORS THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD AMEND THE
STATE LAW TO REQUIRE AWARDING
DEPARTMENTS. TO NOTIFY THOSE DVD
SUBCONTRACTORS WHEN THEIR NAME
ON AN AWARD A CONTRACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I THE NAME
IS IRWIN SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OR GLOBAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TELL A VOTE.
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY DR CHAN
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER CHEN
ACCOLADE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT A CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT BILL THAT WOULD HELP
THE CITY OF BRAND REFER TAX
DOLLARS BACK TO THEIR PERMIT
PROGRAM.
THE OUTSTANDING REDEVELOPMENT
OBLIGATIONS WOULD PAYTO FORM
OTHER AVAILABLE TAX FROM YOU
RESOURCES FROM THE CITY OF BREA.
THIS BILL HAS HAD UNANIMOUS BY
POINT SUPPORT IN BOTH COMMITTEES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RETURN
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S
MS BURKE WHERE ONE RETURN FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT AND WORK THROUGH
SOME ITEMS THAT WE SKIPPED.
MS BURKE THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT AB NINE SIXTY TWO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE HOSPITALS MS BURKE
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REMEMBER EIGHTIES BE NINE SIX
TWO IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT ALIGNS
HOSPITALS AND IT'S MODELING
AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS OF
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND
UTILITY INTEREST FREE TO
INCREASE.
OR TO ENCOURAGE THE PROCUREMENT
FROM DIVERSE AND VENDORS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF
THOSE. SIX FORTY ONE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TADARISE FORTY THREE
KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
BY MS SMITH CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AN ACCOLADE
A SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY.
MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES GOOD AFTERNOON WE
WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OF PRETTY
TENSE CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
FLOOR ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND OUR ROLE IN MOVING FORWARD
IN AN EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING CHARTERS.
SO TODAY I AM BRINGING YOU AB
NINE SIXTY SEVEN WHICH INCLUDES
ALL LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES IN
THE LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN PROCESS.
AND SUPPORTS THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF ALIGNING
CHARTER SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THAT OF
OTHER STATE ELLIE ACE. FOR FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN TASKED WITH DEVELOPING DATA
DRIVEN AND RIGOROUS LOCAL
ENGAGEMENT AND MEANINGFUL
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESSES
IN EL CAP DEVELOPMENT AND
DELIVERY.
AND IN DISTRICTS WHERE THIS WORK
IS FOCUSED AND ROBUST THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SO I STAND HERE TODAY IS
SOMEBODY I'VE TOLD YOU I'M
COMMITTED TO HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE CLOSE
THAT FEEDBACK LOOP OF PROVIDING
ONE COMMON SET OF DATA TO START
TO LOOK AT HOW ALL SCHOOLS ARE
PERFORMING.
SO WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT'S BEST
FOR ALL STUDENTS HOW TO BEST USE
STATE RESOURCES IN EDUCATING ALL
OF OUR KIDS AND THIS MEASURE
HELPS US GET THERE IT ALLOWS
EVERY LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE
CHARTERS.
ADDRESS WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH
THEIR RESOURCES TO SPEAK TO THE
EIGHT STATE PRIORITIES AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS.
FORTY TWO AND FORTY SIX WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT MISTER JONES SAWYER THIS
IS.
AB TEN AT NINETY TO THE
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TEND NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY THE CHILD SUPPORT
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN
NINETY TWO SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
POOREST FAMILIESBY ELIMINATING
THE INTEREST RATE ON CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT -- TO THE STATE IN
CALIFORNIA ONLY FIFTY DOLLARS OF
A CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT GOES TO
THE FAMILY. TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN THE REMAINING BALANCE
GO TO PAY THE GOVERNMENT FOR TO
PARTICIPATION IN PROGRAMS LIKE
CAL WORKS WHEN A PARENT FAILS TO
MAKE TIMELY CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENT.
THEY ARE CRUDE GOVERNMENT DEBT
AND OUR CHART 10% INTEREST ONE
OF THE HIGHEST CHAO SUPPORT
INTEREST IN THE NATION.
DATA SHOWS THAT THREE POINT NINE
BILLION OF THE STATE'S
OUTSTANDING CHILD SUPPORT DEBT
IS UNPAID INTEREST.
AB TEN NINETY TWO REQUIRED TO
STAY TO CHARGE ZERO INTEREST ON
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT TO THE
GOVERNMENT THIS BILL WILL HELP
STOP THE CYCLE PARTY BY INDEED
THE CONTINUE ASSESSMENT.
OF ON COLLECTIBLE DEBT THAT
IMPACTS OUR STATE'S POOREST
FAMILIES MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR DR -- THANK YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
YES MISS MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS BILL
HAS BEEN DUBBED THE DEADBEAT DAD
BILL FOR VERY GOOD REASON
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T.
SEE FIT TO PAY THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT.
TO THE KIDS WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM A BREAK.
THE AUTHOR STATEMENT THAT THIS
BILL SOMEHOW SUPPORTS OUR
POOREST CHILDREN POOREST
FAMILIES IT IS A BUNCH OF
NONSENSE HOW DOES IT SUPPORT
THEM.
IF THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY
THAT IS OWED TO THEM YOU'RE
YOU'RE.
GIVING A BREAK TO SOMEONE IN
SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY
[inaudible]
NEGLECTING [inaudible]
THEIR CHILDREN [inaudible]
DOES.
I JUST I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT MAKES SENSE TO ANYONE IN
HERE.
YOU DON'T REWARD BAD BEHAVIOR.
ASK SOME OF THE MOTHERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET AS A
SINGLE PARENT.
IF THEY THINK THIS BILL IS A
GOOD IDEA. TO GIVE THE PERSON
WHO HAS TURNED THEIR BACK ON
THEIR FAMILY.
WHATEVER THE REASON.
IS THAT THEY'RE NOT AYING THEIR
CHILD SUPPORT AND I KEEPING UP
ON THEIR PAYMENTS ASK THEM IF
THEY THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA.
AND THEN THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE
BILLS THAT ARE PASSED IN THESE
CHAMBERS WHERE WE TALK ABOUT --
EXEMPTING THE TAX ON DIAPERS
EXEMPTING THEY TAX ON FEB BERMAN
HYGIENE PROJECT EXEMPTING THE
TAX ON THIS LOWERING THE COST ON
THAT GETTING RID OF THE PENALTY
FOR THIS.
GETTING RID OF THE PENALTY FOR
THAT ALL TO HELP THE PEOPLE IN
THE LOWER ECONOMIC LEVEL SO.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS YOU
CAN'T SAY WE NEED TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS TO HELP.
POOR KIDS AND THEN TURN AROUND
AND SAY YEAH BUT YOU DEAD BEAT
DADS YOU GET A PASS THIS IS NOT
A GOOD IDEA AYE URGING ABOUT.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MISTER JOHN SIR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LET ME
MAKE THIS VERY CLEAR.
THE MONIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR MONIES THAT GO BACK TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS THE MONEY TO GO BACK TO
ACTUAL PARENTS THIS WILL
ACTUALLY ALLOW.
THE ACTUAL PRINCIPLE TO GO BACK
TO DO TO PARENTS AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE WHO NEED THE MONEY.
THINK ABOUT THIS YOU HAVE CREDIT
CARDS YOU HAVE DEBT AND ALL THE
GHOST INTEREST TO BANKS TO
NOTICE THINGS THIS IS A LIMIT OR
FREE LIMITED INTEREST IN A WENT
TO GO PAY THE PRINCIPAL MONEY
THAT GOES DIRECTLY. TO CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS NOT INTEREST TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
OUR GOVERNMENT THIS WHAT THIS
BILL IS DOING TO ALLOW US TO
GIVE MORE MONEY BACK TO PEOPLE
WHO REALLY NEED IT THOSE ARE
PEOPLE THAT NEED TO CHAO SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE EYE
BOAT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE
[inaudible]
MISTER.
JONES SAWYER.
MOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS WERE RETURN FILE ITEM.
FORTY THIS IS MISTER RODRIGUEZ
FILE ITEM FORTY AB ONE THOUSAND
TWO CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TOTAL TO BUY SOME
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACCOLADES
STATE EMPLOYMENT THIS RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE RIGHT TO PRESENT AB TEN OH
TWO WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTS THE WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN THAT KEEP OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY SECURE.
THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO
MEMORIALIZE THE CCP ALWAYS
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING IN
CASE THE REGULAR BUDGET NUMBERS
NEGOTIATIONS ARE UNSUCCESSFUL.
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT ARE RETIRED OFFICERS
HAVE ADEQUATE BENEFITS AFTER THE
SERVICE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS FOR HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
PARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER WE
ARE PASSING TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
SIXTY ONE WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE OUT FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN BY MS
FRIEDMAN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACCOLADE A WATER.
THIS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS MEMBERS WE
EXPECT TO OUR RESIDENTS TO OBEY
THE LAW AND WE SHOULD EXPECT NO
LESS. FOR FROM OUR PUBLIC
AGENCIES WHEN WE SET
REQUIREMENTS AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AUTHORIZES CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES TO ENFORCE
EXISTING WATER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR AGENCIES
MANY OF THESE REQUIREMENTS HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES I'M
ALL EACH OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE REQUIRED BY
CURRENT LAW THE LAW IS SILENT ON
THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT
REPORTING.
AND AS A RESULT COMPLIANCE FROM
REQUIRED AGENCIES HAS BEEN
SPOTTY WITHOUT EFFECTIVE ****
SANCTIONS FOR NON REPORTING
LOCAL ENTITIES ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR LATE OR MISSING
REPORTS AND PLANS. FOR THE MORE
DATA YOU ARE HAS NOT CREATED OR
PUBLISHED A MASTER LIST OF ALL
THE LOCAL ENTITIES REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH WATER REPORTING LAWS.
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR US
TO KNOW THE RATES OF NON
COMPLIANCE AND WHICH DISTRICTS
ARE ARE CONSTANTLY IN NON
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR REGULATIONS.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN CREATES A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE FRAMEWORK FOR
D. W. R. TO ENFORCE EXISTING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WHEN
THERE IS A FAILURE TO SUBMIT
PLANS.
D. W. R. IS ALSO AUTHORIZED TO
EXTEND DEADLINES OR REDUCE AND
REDUCE AND WAIVE ANY PENALTIES
UNDER SPECIFIC CIRCUMCISIONS
BECAUSE WERE CLEAR IN THE BILL
THAT OUR GOAL IS TO GET
COMPLIANCE NOT TO BE PUNITIVE.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IS SUPPORTED
BY AN OUR DC CLC BE ON THE
SIERRA CLUB AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY TWO NO.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
GOING TO TAKE UP THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
SIXTY FIVE THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
COOKERY.
SOME AGO FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE ENSURES
THAT WORKERS RECEIVE THE
NECESSARY TRAINING TO ADAPT TO
THE CHANGING NATURE.
OF THE GROCERY INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THREE
CERTIFICATIONS FIRST THE PRODUCE
CLERK CERTIFICATION WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING IN HEALTH CODE
VIOLATIONS LOCALLY SOURCED
PRODUCE AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
SECOND THE SERVICE DELI
CERTIFICATION WILL ESTABLISH
TRAINING IN FOOD SAFETY HEALTH
CODE VIOLATIONSAND FRESH FOOD
PREPARATION.
IN THIRD THE NUTRITION CLERK
CERTIFICATION WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING ABOUT FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS NUTRITION EDUCATION AND
BUDGET PLANS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES HAVE THE TRAINING TO
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH ACCURATE
INFORMATION THAT EMPLOYEES HAVE
THE TRAINING TO PROVIDE.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL BE A
GATEWAY TO THE JOINT DEVELOPMENT
OF APPRENTICESHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF WORKERS IN
INDUSTRY ALIKE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR RAMOS SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLICK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS FOR THE SARAJEVO.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
SIXTY SIX PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT IS A. B. FOURTEEN ELEVEN
BY MISTER BLOOM QUICKLY.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOMAN ACCOLADE
ACOSTA RESOURCES MR BLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I'LL TRY TO GO QUICKLY SOME OF
YOU MAY REMEMBER PARTS OF THE
SPEECH FROM YESTERDAY ESPECIALLY
THE MEMBER FROM ANAHEIM AND
WHOSE.
HASN'T LET ME FORGET -- BUT THE
US SANTA MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION.
IS TASKED WITH COORDINATING
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL EFFORTS
TO RESTORE AND ENHANCE SANTA
MONICA BAY AND IT'S WATERSHED AN
A. B. FIFTEEN ELEVEN UPDATES THE
STATUTES GOVERNING THE
COMMISSION.
BY REPLACING THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AS THE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT WITH THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
THE BILL ALSO REVISES THE
PURPOSE OF THE COMMISSION GIVING
IT NEW GOALS THAT ARE IN LINE
WITH -- GOALS THAT WERE APPROVED
BY THE COMMISSION AFTER AN OPEN
AND PUBLIC PROCESS.
THE REVISED PURPOSES THE PURPOSE
AND GOALS OF THE COMMISSION TO
CREATE.
WILL CREATE A NATURAL ALIGNMENT
WITH THE ROLE OF THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY WHO ALSO
PROVIDE.
ASSISTANCE FOR GRANTS AND OTHER
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN WILL
ENSURE A MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACH
FOR THE SUPPORT AND IMPROVEMENT
OF SANTA MONICA BàN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
SAYS EVEN BETTER THAN YESTERDAY
MISTER BLOOM SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS.
YOU DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY SIX
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM.
SIXTY NINE WE ARE FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
O'DONNELL.
QUICKLY ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN BY SOME MEMORABLE
DONALD OTHERS INOCULATED PUBLIC
WORKS MR AT ALL.
IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN DEFINES PUBLIC WORKS TO
INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS.
THIS TO ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO WORK ON THESE PROJECTS
RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE AND
ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT.
FROM A FRIENDSHIP PROGRAMS.
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND IS
FINANCING COURTED BY A PUBLIC
ENTITY SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FINANCING AUTHORITY UNDER
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE ON THESE
BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT PAY
TAXES.
IN TURN THE BORROWER RECEIVES A
LOWER INTEREST RATE.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED BY STATE EDUCATION MONTHS
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER THE
FEEL THAT.
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED WITHOUT
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND DO NOT.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THESE.
THAT THOSE WORKING ON OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES ARE SKILLED AND
QUALIFIED.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
SEVERAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE SERVER CLERK
WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE EYES FORTY NINE
KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I WAS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE AND THIS BRINGS US
FILE I'M SEVENTY TWO AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FOUR AGAIN MISTER
O'DONNELL CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR
BY SOME MEMBER ROLLED ON
ACCORDING TO THE SAN GABRIEL
LOWER LOS ANGELES RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
MR O'DONNELL WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE I'M.
SEVENTY THREE THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY DR WEBER CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME BILL SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
ACCOLADE TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
DOCTOR WEBER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THIS
WOULD BETTER EQUALIZE FUNDING
FOR NON CREDIT CAREER
DEVELOPMENT AND COLLEGE
PREPARATION COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED IN A START AND END DATE
WHICH IS A MANAGE ENROLLMENT.
AUTHORIZING THE TENANTS OF THOSE
COURSES TO BE TAKEN ACCORDING TO
A CENSUS DATE RATHER ON POSITIVE
ATTENDANCE.
ADDITIONALLY BILL WOULD FREE UP
PRECIOUS FACULTY TIMES OF THE
FACULTY CAN BETTER ADDRESS
LEARNING NEEDS OF STUDENTS WE
INTERVIEWED A GREAT GREAT A
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND SUCCESS.
THIS BILL IS HAD NO OPPOSITION
AND AS RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CAR CLUB IN
THE ROLE [inaudible]
THE SERVER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE IS AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE BY MISS
CARILLO CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTY FIFTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
ACCOLADE IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS.
MISS KOREA.
YOU [inaudible]
MAY [inaudible]
MAY.
I HAVE.
NOTHING.
OPEN SORRY MISTER SPEAKER.
TECHNOLOGY FAILS A SOMETIMES.
THANK YOU I AM A PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FIFTY THREE A BILL THAT ENSURES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE IMMIGRATED TO
THIS COUNTRY AND ARE ATTEMPTING
TO BECOME NATURALIZED CITIZENS.
OR NEED HELP WITH THEIR
IMMIGRATION PAPERWORK RECEIVE
LEGAL ADVICE ONLY FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE LEGAL
EDUCATION AND EXPERTISE TO
PROVIDE SUCH ASSISTANCE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT
ACCORDING TO THE U. S. CENSUS
NEARLY 35% OF LA COUNTY. TWENTY
TEN MILLION RESIDENTS WERE BORN
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY MYSELF
INCLUDED.
THE DATA ALSO SHOWS THAT
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN LA COUNTY
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT SOLELY A LOS ANGELES
ISSUE THIS IS ALSO AN ISSUE FOR
SAN DIEGO THE INLAND EMPIRE
CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL COAST.
THE BAY AREA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND EVERY LITTLE PLACE IN
BETWEEN.
THE CURRENT EXPANDED DISCRETION
OF FEDERAL OFFICIALS TO DENY
IMMIGRATION APPLICATION LEAVES
NO ROOM FOR ERROR IN THE
ACCURACY SUBMISSION.
AND COMPLETENESS OF IMMIGRATION
APPLICATIONS AND EVEN IF ERRORS
CAN BE RECTIFIED AFFECTED
IMMIGRANT VICTIMS OFTEN LACK THE
ABILITY TO CORRECT THESE
MISTAKES.
BE IT FOR A LACK OF RESOURCE IF
YOU'RE RETALIATION OR GOVERNMENT
DISTRUST OVERALL.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUES BY MAKING
IT UNLAWFUL FOR A PERSON OTHER
THAN A LICENSED ATTORNEY.
A PERSON ON ORGANIZATION
FEDERALLY AUTHORIZED TO
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS IN
IMMIGRATION MATTERS OR A
PARALEGAL UNDER THE SUPERVISION
OF AN ATTORNEY TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION RELATED SERVICES.
FOR A FEE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG SUPPORT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO THE
SENATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS CREEL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALBOT EYES FORTY
FOUR KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE PASS TEMPORARILY ON A COUPLE
OF MISTER MCCARTY'S ITEMS IF
YOU'RE READY MISTER MCCARTY.
MEMBERS WE ARE RETURNING TO FILE
ITEM.
FORTY SIX THIS IS AB.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY MISTER
MCCARTY CORPORAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOME WE WERE MCCARTY AN ACCOLADE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THIS
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
RELATES TO OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS.
IN OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
RIGHT A GREAT SERVICE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
BECAUSE OF THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE OTHER FACTORS AND
FORTUNATELY THEY'RE BEING
SQUEEZED -- THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SERVING FEWER KIDS TODAY WITH
HIGHER COSTS -- CONVERSELY TWO
YEARS AGO THE VOTERS PASSED PROP
SIXTY FOUR TO LEGALIZE.
TAX AND REGULATE MARIJUANA AND
ON THE BALLOT ARGUMENTS AND THE
TV COMMERCIALS THE MESSAGE IS
PRETTY CLEAR.
WE SHOULD TAX AND REGULATE
MARIJUANA AND USE THE PROCEEDS
TO FUND PROGRAMS LIKE.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
LITERALLY WAS IN THE BALLOT
ARGUMENT THAT LITERALLY WAS IN
THE TV COMMERCIAL WE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HONOR THIS
COMMITMENTS.
AND SO THIS WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CONSIDER AND FRANKLY PRIORITIZE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WITH PROP
SIXTY FOUR REVENUES ASK ME RIGHT
OUT THANK YOU.
MISS MCCARTY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUR TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN THERE WAS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE THIS IS
MISTER MCCARTY IS AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE SOME
PEOPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOMEBODY -- MCCARTY AN ACCOLADE
A PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION THIS MCCARTY MAKE IT
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
PART OF A PACKAGE OF BILLS IN
RESPONSE TO THE RECENT COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL OPERATION.
VARSITY BLUES HOW WE HEARD THAT
SOME OF INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WERE ESSENTIALLY BRIBING SOME
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY OFICIALS TO
HAVE THEIR KIDS BE A SPECIAL
ADMIT ON ATHLETIC TEAMS THEY
EVEN PLAY THE SPORT.
IN OTHER WORDS THAT THEY THEY
LET A KID ON THE WATER POLO TEAM
AT THE SPECIAL ADMIT WHEN THE
KIDS EVEN KNOW HOW TO SWIM.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT THE SANCTITY OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS BECAUSE ONE
KID GETTING DENIED.
IS ONE KID TOO MUCH AND ONE CAN
GET IN THROUGH FRAUDULENT MEANS
IS AS ALSO DENIES THE RIGHT AND
ANOTHER QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA
STUDENT.
SO THIS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CSU AND YOU SEE SYSTEMS THROUGH
THEIR SPECIAL ADMIT PROGRAMS
HAVE ADEQUATE CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE GETTING ON ON
THE VALID MEANS AND NOT FRAUD.
ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
THEY GIVE US REGARDING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK BELOW FOR THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE -- DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
TELL YOU ABOUT I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES -- I
SEE MR GREY.
AT HIS DESK.
THERE'S MORE TO COME WITH THAT
STATEMENT.
BUT I SEE MR GREY AT HIS DESK
AND MISTER VERY WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE OF AN ITEM FOR WHICH WE
PASS TEMPORARILY.
AND THAT IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AN ACCOLADE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY.
MR GREAT.
FAMOUS SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
TO CONDUCT ANNUAL AUDITS OF THE
LOTTERY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS GREAT.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
WELL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
WHAT IS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
THERE IS OUT OF OUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
NEVER GOING.
TO GO TO MISTER O'DONNELL THE
CLEANUP FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO AB.
SIXTY NINETY FOUR CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN NINETY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
ONE ACTUALLY TO THE SAN GABRIEL
AND LOWER LOS ANGELES RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
MR DOLLARS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB IXTEEN NINETY FOUR
WHICH WILL EXPAND THE TERRITORY
OF THE SAN GABRIEL LOWER LOS
ANGELES RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY. TO INCLUDE THE
DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL WATERSHED AND
CATALINA ISLAND.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION TWENTY YEARS
AGO THE RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY HAS SUCCESSFULLY
PURSER PURSUED A MISSION OF
PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND
HABITAT WELL FACILITATING PUBLIC
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
WILDERNESS.
AND WILDLIFE.
WELL THE CONSERVANCY HAS HAD
GREAT SUCCESS WITH NUMEROUS
PROJECTS WITHIN ITS TERRITORY.
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES THE
MINGUS CHANNEL WATERSHED AND
CATALINA ISLAND HAVE NOT HAD THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES.
THE RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY IS A UNIQUE IS IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO HELP THESE
AREAS AND EXPAND THEIR MISSION
OF PRESERVING KELLY IS NATURAL
RESOURCES IN A WAY WE CAN ALL
ENJOY.
AB SIXTY NINETY FOUR WILL OTHER
CONSERVANCY TO DO EXACTLY THAT.
BY EXPANDING THEIR TERRITORY TO
COVER THESE AREAS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DONALD SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FOUR NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SIX WERE MOVED TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER N ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR REQUIRE THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA OLYMPIC
AND PARALYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMAND. TO FACILITATE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SECURITY AT THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES IN LOS ANGELES
THIS MODEL WILL BE BASED ON THE
COMMAND SUCCESSFULLY OPERATED BY
THE STATE OF UTAH.
AHEAD OF THEIR TWO THOUSAND TWO
WINTER GAMES SINCE SALT LAKE
CITY THE INTERNATIONAL OLYMPIC
COMMITTEE AWARDED TO SEE THE LOS
ANGELES TO BID FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT SUMMER OLYMPICS
LAST YEAR.
MAKING A THIRD TIME CITY WILL
HOST THE GAMES PLANNING FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND SECURITY AT
THE GAMES SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE MANY
VIOLENT TERRORIST ACTS THAT HAVE
AFFECTED THE GAMES IN THE PAST.
MUNICH IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
ATLANTIC ATLANTA IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THEREFORE TO ROLL THE
COMMAND WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
ENSURING THAT FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES A
PROACTIVE AT ASSESSING RISK
THREATS AND VULNERABILITIES. TO
ENSURE A STATE OF PREPAREDNESS
AND READING THIS DURING THE
GAMES FURTHERMORE IT WILL ENSURE
THAT NORMAL PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES.
ARE MAINTAINED WITHIN THE HOST
COMMUNITIES LASTLY THE COMMAND
WILL BORDERS TO RECEIVE AND
DISTRIBUTE GRANT FUNDING TO
REIMBURSE STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR PUBLIC.
SAFETY COSTS THIS BILL HAS GONE
THROUGH ASSEMBLY.
G. O. AND ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS AND TOURISM AND INTERNET
MEDIA WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IS RECEIVE NO NO VOTE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
OR PULL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE HI SIXTY ONE OH
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FOR ONE
OF PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH SEVENTY
NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY AB TWO BY MISTER SANTIAGO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TO BUY SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO IN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THINK YOU MISSED SPEAKERS I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THEN THE
CHAMBER FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HELPING US ON WORK ON ON
AB NINETEEN WHICH MADE FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FIRST TIME
FULL TIME.
AND WE REALLY HELP THE LEAD THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION ABOUT DEBT
FREE EDUCATION TODAY I STAND
BEFORE YOU.
ASKING FOR SUPPORT ON AB TWO SO
WE CAN MAKE TWO YEARS OF FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
OFFER ANY STUDENT WHO ATTENDS
BUT THERE'S MORE TO IT THERE'S
ALSO THE STUDENT SUCCESS PIECE
WHICH IS MAKING SURE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE ALL THE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES
WHICH IS MAKING SURE.
THAT EVERY EVERY STUDENT --
WITHIN THESE COHORTS FILL OUT
THE FAST SO FORM WHICH COULD
GIVE ANY STUDENT BETWEEN TEN AND
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS -- EXTRA
BETWEEN PELL GRANTS AND CAL
GRANT OFFER NON TUITION COST SO
I STAND BEFORE YOU ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ON AB TWO FOR TWO YEARS OF FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO MISTER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I I'M A
JOINT AUTHORED WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES THIS IS A GREAT
PROPOSAL IT'S IN OUR BUDGET WILL
BE DEBATING -- THIS WEEK IT'S
REALLY A WIN WIN WIN FOR
STUDENTS FOR OUR COLLEGES AND
FOR CALIFORNIA WE KNOW FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO IT'S A GRADUATE THE
WAY TOO MUCH DEBT.
AND FOCUSING ON MAKING CALLS
MORE DEBT FREE HELPS OUR
STUDENTS FOR OUR COLLEGES SOME
OF THESE COLLEGES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND HAVING THE
TAGLINE FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HELP SOME THIS COLLEGES.
ATTRACT MORE STUDENTS TO MAKE
THEIR COMMITTEE CALL DISTRICTS
MORE VIABLE LASTLY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE GREASE WITH
OTHER CERTIFICATES -- CALLED
DEGREES WERE -- FACING A GAP OF
NEARLY TWO MILLION PEOPLE WITH
FOUR YEAR DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATE DEGREES AND
COMMUNICABLE DEGREES THIS HELPS
OUR PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS OF TODAY AND TOMORROW IN
OUR WORKFORCE.
AND WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE THE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS MCCARTY YES.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
MR SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND THANKS ONE
MORE TIME THE BUDGET COMMITTEE --
MY CALL THE PRINCE I COMMEND ALL
THE JOINT AUTHORS IN THE
GOVERNOR WHO IS ALSO INCLUDED
THIS -- AS WELL IN THE BUDGET IN
THE SENATE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER EXPECT
LASSEN AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS EIGHTY ONE THROUGH.
EIGHTY SIX THAT BRINGS US FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE OH ONE
BY MISTER GIBSON CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE NINE A ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON ACCOLADES
YOU'VE IN AUS MR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB NINE A ONE WHICH
SEEKS TO ENCOURAGE APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION FOR YOUTH WHO ARE
AT RISK.
AS WHO YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK --
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BEING
CRIMINALIZED AS VOLUNTEER
PROBATION.
THESE YOU WHO WITHOUT HAVING --
A COURT HEARING ARE REQUIRED TO
CHECK IN WITH PROBATION OFFICER
SUBJECT TO RANDOM SEARCH --
CURFEW SURPRISE HOME VISITS --
INTERROGATION DESPITE THE
PROGRAM BEING LABELED VOLUNTARY.
AB NINE A ONE WILL LIMIT
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS OVER BROAD
DISCRETION TO INSURE THAT THEY
RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION AND NOT BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR TRUANCY OR
OTHER TYPICAL CHILDHOOD
ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR.
I WANT TO THANK THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF COURSE THE STATE
COALITION PROBATION OFFICERS
WOULD BE WORKING WITH ME -- HE
ANTICIPATES -- ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS ONTO THIS BILL ON THE
SENATE SIDE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE ON
A. B..
NINE OH ONE THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON DOCTOR QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES I URGING AYE VOTE ON A. B.
NINE A ONE I HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
AND I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS
WORKING ON THEM.
AND I URGE YOU BRING THIS ON TO
THE SENATE SO WE CAN NOW TAKE
CARE OF THIS AND I THINK HE WILL
IN THE AND REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
AGAIN PURGING AYE VOTE ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE A
ONE THANK YOU TALKS QUIRK.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO THE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE VOTE
MISTER GIBSON MOVES A CALL.
SEE MR TANG HAS THREE ITEMS IN A
ROW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT AB NINE NINE FIVE
CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE NINE NINETY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER TING ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE OF FOSTER CARE MR TING
EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER NEARLY
40% OF FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WILL
BECOME HOMELESS. TO ADDRESS THIS
VULNERABILITY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
PLUS.
I AB NINE NINE FIVE CLOSE IS AN
ELIGIBILITY LOOPHOLE BY ALIGNING
T. H. P. PLUS EIGHT CARTER WITH
OTHER FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS.
IT ALSO INTEGRATES T. H. C. A.
T. H. P. PLUS FIFTY EXCUSE ME.
INTO LOCAL CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
SO THAT YOU TRANSITION FOR
FOSTER CARE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FLORIDA SERVICES AVAILABLE.
BUT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE THOSE.
FAMOUS TING SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
GLOBAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS FIVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE
AB ONE THOUSAND ONE BY MR TING
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN OH ONE BY SOME
MEMBER TING ANOTHER SNACK LEYVA
SHOCKER.
MISTER KING I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WAS HONORED TO BE A
MEMBER OF OUR SPEAKERS BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ARE EARLY CARE
FOR THE CHILD CARE AND EDUCATION --
AB ELEVEN AB ONE THOUSAND ONE
IMPROVED EXISTING LOCAL EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PLANNING WITH
THREE MAIN ELEMENTS.
CHANGES THE MEMBERSHIP OF LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCILS AND TO NEW
STRATEGIC PLANNING COUNCILS.
THAT'S A CLEAR EXPECTATIONS
RELATED TO DATA COLLECTION
STANDARDS AND RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR BOTH THE COUNCIL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
IT ALSO GIVES COUNTIES
FLEXIBILITY IN THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE COUNCIL TO HELP MAKE THE
SMALL FIT BOTH BIG AND SMALL.
COUNTIES NOT WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I BUILDING
AB.
ONE THOUSAND ONE THANK WHICH
TING SEE NO DISCUSSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I'D FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE TO PASS AND
FOR A TIME FILE ITEM.
NINETY MISTER CHANG HAS FILE
ITEM.
NINETY ONE AB TEN SEVENTY SIX
OPERATE.
SOME PEOPLE TEND SEVENTY SIX BY
SIMPLY REVERTING ACCOLADE
CRIMINAL RECORDS MR TAKE YOU MAY
GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN
SEVENTY SIX WOULD OPEN DOORS TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
WHO FACE BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING BY AUTOMATING THE
PROCESS OF CLEARING IN A REST OR
CRIMINAL RECORD FOR ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS?
CURRENTLY WE FIND THAT OVER 70%
76% OF INDIVIDUALS WITH CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS OR SPORT DISABILITY
IN FINDING A JOB OR HOUSING.
THIS LACK OF HOUSING AS WELL AS
EMPLOYMENT REALLY CREATE A CYCLE
OF POVERTY IN A CYCLE OF
CRIMINALITY WITHIN OUR STATE.
BY ALLOWING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO GET THEIR
RECORDS AUTOMATICALLY CLEARED
THE WAY WE WOULD DO THIS IS ASK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CREATE A
DATABASE.
THE DATABASE WOULD THEN BE SENT
TO OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
SO WHEN PEOPLE ARE DOING THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THE BACKGROUNDS WOULD NOT BE
REVEALED.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE OR ARE
CURRENTLY ALREADY ELIGIBLE TO
HAVE THEIR RECORDS EXPUNGED SO
THIS DOES NOT INCREASE.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE THIS JUST EXPEDITE THAT
PROCESS THIS IS A PROCESS WERE
WERE ACTUALLY STREAMLINING
GOVERNMENT.
WERE HELPING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS DO WHAT THEY'RE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO DO.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THIS WILL
HELP THEM BE ABLE TO GET
EMPLOYMENT.
GET HOUSING REALLY CREATE
STABILITY IN THEIR LIFE --
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU RICH TING SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLICK LIBERAL.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE OF A ALL MEMBER
SERVICE AT A VOTE.
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT EYES FORTY
TWO KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IN FILER FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO IS AB ELEVEN THIRTY
BY MR LEVINE.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
ACCOLADE INFORMATION PRIVACY.
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
THIRTY UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S DATA
BREACH NOTIFICATION LAWS I'M
PARTNERING WITH ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY OR THE SERRA TO UPDATE
THOSE LAWS TO INCLUDE PASSPORT
NUMBERS.
AND BIOMETRIC DATA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LEVINE SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPORAL OF
THE ROLE.
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH
.
ALL MEMBERS VERY SAD ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY ABOUT AYE AYES.
FORTY ONE NO TWELVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
NINETY THREE IS AB TWELVE TWELVE
CORKERY.
SOME REAL TWELVE TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ACCOLADE
AN ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT.
MR LIVING IN THE MAIL BUT
MEMBERS LAST WEEK I TALKED ABOUT
THE NEED -- TO IN HAVE OVERSIGHT
ON STATE INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
BILL HELPS BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS ONE REQUIRES
A NUMBER STATE AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. TO
OUR PENSION BOARDS IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE PENSION BOARD
ACTUALLY ACT ON THAT INFORMATION.
BUT WE SURE NEED TO HAVE
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD PROJECTS THAT WILL NEED
TO INVEST ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE INTERSTATES
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL WILL
HELP I HAVE RESPECT LAST FOR NOW
THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISS LEVINE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARP WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL IT ABOUT AYE
AYES.
FORTY FOUR NOS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MISS MELENDEZ WE HAVE ONE ITEM
WE NEED TO GO BACK AND CLEAN UP
IF YOU CAN JUST WAIT
[inaudible] THIRTY SECONDS.
MR MAYES YOUR GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE ON MISTER COOLIES
BEHALF THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE AB TWO NINETY SIX
THE CORPORATION.
THE BILL TO NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY ANOTHER
SNACK LATER CLIMATE CHANGE
MAKING A PROBATIONER.
FOR MISTER MESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND LIKE YOU SAID MISTER
SPEAKER BY THIS IS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF SOMEONE COOLEY. TO
PRESENT A AB TWO NINETY SIX
WHICH ESTABLISHES A CLIMATE
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
FUNDED BY VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION AND PRIVATE
DONATIONS.
THIS BILL UTILIZES A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS TO AWARD MATCHING GRANT
FUNDS FOR INNOVATIONS THAT
IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY AND
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS ADDS AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
SOURCE TO THE MIX RATHER THAN
PULLING FROM EXISTING DOLLARS
THAT ARE ALREADY HARD AT WORK
INCLUDING THE EPIC FUND OR G. G.
R. F..
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU MISS MAYES SAYING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SERVICE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE ROLE IN TIME OUT EYES
SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW MEMBERS WE WILL BE
TAKING A FIVE NINETY FOUR AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN BY.
MS POLAND AS CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE FOURTEEN BY
SUMMER MELENDEZ AND ACTUALLY THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE FOURTEEN AUSTIN AND IS
ALEX'S Là.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ALEX
PEERS WITH IT WAS A THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD BOY ATTENDING AN END OF
YOUR SCHOOL PARTY IT IS HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HE TRAGICALLY
DROWNED.
ALEX WAS FOUND UNDER WATER.
EXCUSE ME ALEX WAS FOUND UNDER
WATER FOR NEARLY TWO MINUTES
BEFORE HIS FELLOW CLASSMATES
NOTICED HIS ABSENCE AND BROUGHT
HIM TO THE SERVICE TO RECEIVE
CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY ALEX WENT WITHOUT
LIFESAVING CPR FROM A SEVEN
MINUTES FOLLOWING HIS DEATH AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE MARINA
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOUND AN
INSUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
LIFEGUARDS WERE PATROLLING THE
POOL.
THAT LIFEGUARDS ARE OPERATING
WITHOUT PROPER SUPERVISION
ALEX'S Là SIMPLY PROVIDES AT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OFFERS
INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS THAT THEY MUST HAVE
SOMEONE WHO CPR CERTIFIED.
AT SCHOOL EVENTS AT ALL TIMES
AND REQUIRE CPR TO BE OFFERED
DOLLAR ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE I'VE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO CRAP THIS BILL IN A WAY THAT
EVERYONE IS SATISFIED I HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN ME IN VOTING AYE ON
AB.
TWELVE FOURTEEN THANK YOU MS.
ONE SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF A DESIRE TO THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL ME ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE IS
AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE BY MISS
WICKS CORPORAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY NINE
BY SOMEBODY WHO WORKS IN OTHERS
AND ACCOLADES TO NON -- MISS
WICKS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I HAVE A GREAT
BIPARTISAN BILL FOR YOU --
DEALING WITH -- FOSTER KIDS IN
THEIR ACCESS TO FOOD MANY FOSTER
CARE YOUTH INSPIRED HIGHER
EDUCATION -- AND YET ONLY 324%
GET A MAP A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
ONLY 1% GET A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
PART OF THE CHALLENGES ACCESS TO
FOOD.
AND FINANCIAL SECURITY SO MY
BILL AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE ONE
FOR THE FOSTER USE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED BY
EXPANDING THE TYPES OF WORK WORK
OUR OUR HOURS AVAILABLE AND
ALLOWABLE FOSTER USED TO QUALIFY
FOR CALIFORNIA SHE HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
AYE AYES SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY SIX A. B..
TWELVE THIRTY THREE SOME MIDDLE
TWELVE THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AN ACTOR
LATER PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
IS SMITH YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THINKING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
MAKING AN ADJUSTMENT TO THIS
BILL THAT REALLY MAKES IT.
TRULY EQUITABLE FOR ALL THE
STUDENTS IT WOULD SERVE.
THE AP EXAM NOT ONLY PROVIDES OF
STUDENTS WAYS TO BOLSTER THEIR
COLLEGE RESUMES AND ALLOWS THEM
TO BY PASS REMEDIATION AND
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE EARLIER
WITH SMALLER AMOUNTS OF COLLEGE
DEBT.
ADDITIONALLY UNFETTERED ACCESS
TO RIGOROUS AND CHALLENGING
COURSE CONTENT IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY ADVANCED PLACEMENT
EXAM FEES ARE FORTY NOT EXCUSE
ME NINETY FOUR DOLLARS PER TEST
WHICH CAN ADD UP QUICKLY AND
BECOME A PROHIBITIVE COST EVEN
IN JUST ONE YEAR OF A STUDENT'S
EDUCATION.
MEMBERS THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE
AB TWELVE THIRTY THREE WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED PLACEMENT EQUITY
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT ADVANCE
PLACEMENT EXAM FEES ARE FREE OF
COST FOR ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND FOSTER
YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WITH MISS
GONZALES YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU -- I I WANT TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AT WE'VE MADE THE RARE DECISION
APPROPRIATIONS ACTUALLY ADD COST
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE ORIGINALLY
I'M WE WANNA CHARGE A NOMINAL
FEE TO STUDENTS HER POOR BUT
REALITY.
WE KNOW THAT KIDS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD A NINETY FOUR DOLLAR FEE --
COULD HAVE A HARD TIME WITH
THEIR TAKING FOUR FIVE TESTS
EVEN COMING UP WITH THE TWENTY
OR TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND SO
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHOR FOR
UNDERSTANDING -- HOW DEEPLY IN
AND SHE AGREED WITH ME WE WE WE
WORK ON THIS TO BE COME EVEN
MORE EQUITABLE AND I'M I
CONGRATULATE HER ON GETTING THE
ONE BILL OUT THAT WE ACTUALLY?
MADE MORE EXPENSIVE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER MISS SMITH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT
KIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB TWELVE
FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME OF BILL TWELVE FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE BONE AND ACT
LEYVA HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
AS THE MAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWELVE FORTY
SIX CLOSES THE GAP IN STATE LAW
BY ENSURING.
CONSUMERS WITH LARGE EMPLOYER
COVERAGE REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ENJOY
THE SAME HEALTH BENEFITS AS
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ALREADY HAVE.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
CONSUMERS WITH COVERAGE
REGULATED UNDER THE KNOX KEEN
ACT HAVE BEEN GUARANTEED HAVE
BEEN GUARANTEED.
COVERAGE THAT PROVIDE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE INCLUDING BASIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SUCH AS
DOCTOR SERVICES HOSPITAL
SERVICES EMERGENCY CARE AND LAB
IMAGING AND HOSPICE CARE.
THIS BILL CODIFIES THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IT INTO THE
INSURANCE CODE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I PUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT IN
NINETY EIGHT AB TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AN
ACCOLADE OR MENTAL HEALTH MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MAN SPEAKER THIS BILL
WAS TABLETS OUTREACH TEAMS TASK
WITHOUT REGION OF THE HOMELESS.
POPULATION WITH A HISTORY OF
MENTAL ILLNESS WERE UNABLE TO
ACCESS THE URGENTLY NEEDED
MEDICAL CARE THAT THEY NEED AND
DESERVE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR DEVOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
IMMACULATELY TO IN HOUSE IT'S A
GOOD THING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE A
STUDY BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
USE OF CHEMICAL SPRAY IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES.
EXTENSIVE USE OF CHEMICALS AGENT
ORANGE JUICE ON YOUTH IN
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES
NOT NOT ONLY -- PROCEED WITH
MENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS BUT ALSO
INTERFERES WITH THE
REHABILITATION BY ENDANGERING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE U. AND
THE STAFF MY GOAL IS TO GATHER
DATA.
SO THAT IT THE LA -- CAN GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
MISTER GIVE SEND SEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTERS.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT VOTE ICE FORTY THREE
KNOWS TO THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
BY SIMPLY RIVER BONTA ACCOLADE
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE DOWN
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN IN THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE ADDRESSES DATA GAPS AND
INACCURACIES IN CRIMINAL RECORDS.
BY ESTABLISHING CLEAR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
COURTS QUITE SIMPLY THIS BILL
WILL CREATE GREATER ACCURACY IN
CRIMINAL RECORDS WHICH BENEFITS
PUBLIC SAFETY IN GENERAL.
AND HELPS TO ENSURE JUST
OUTCOMES FOR EVERYONE WHO HAS
BEEN ACCUSED OR CONVICTED.
OF A CRIME A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE IS THE FIRST STEP IN
ENSURING WE HAVE RELIABLE AND
COMPLETE.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTERS ALL MEMBERS THAT YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A
TAKES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE SQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE THIS RUN TIME OF THE
CALL.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE NO ONE FILE ITEM ONE OR
TWO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL ONE
ACCOLADE NEW ELECTRICITY.
MR O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO WERE TWO CARS THE P.
YOU SEE TO ESTABLISH A
CENTRALIZED CLEARINGHOUSE.
OF LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
RESIDENTIAL RATE TERRACE AND
PROGRAMS.
THIS WILL ENABLE CUSTOMERS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COMPARE
RATES SERVICES ENVIRONMENTAL
ATTRIBUTES AND OTHER OFFERINGS.
OF ICY I USE CCA'S AND DIRECT
ACCESS PROVIDERS RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES VIOLATE ONE OR
THREE AB FORTINO THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
AND ACT LIKE A PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT.
AB FORTINO THREE WHICH WOULD
CORRECT AN OVERSIGHT AND STATE
LAW TO ENSURE THAT.
DEEPLY IMPOVERISHED INDIVIDUALS
CAN APPLY FOR CRITICAL RESOURCES
WHEN THE CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
KIDS PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
CAL WORKS WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
LEGISLATOR SOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT
CAL WORKS PARENTS MOSTLY WOMEN.
WHO HAVE REACHED THEIR TIME
ALLOTTED FOR ASSISTANCE A FORTY
EIGHT MONTHS BUT ARE STILL
RECEIVING CAL WORK THROUGH THEIR
CHILDREN ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
COUNTY GENERAL ASSISTANCE?
HOWEVER IF THE CHILDREN ARE
UNDER EIGHTEEN AND REMOVED FROM
THE CUSTODY WITH THE PARENT
OFTEN BECAUSE THEY ARE IN FOSTER
CARE OR WITH A RELATIVE.
THE PARENT WHO MAY OFTENTIMES BE
DESTITUTE IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
GENERAL ASSISTANCE.
AB FORTINO THREE WILL CORRECT AN
OVERSIGHT IN THE LAW TO ENSURE
THAT DEEPLY IMPOVERISHED
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
GENERAL ASSISTANCE THERE BY
ALLOWING THEM TO ACCESS CRITICAL
RESOURCES?
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE WITH
ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS REGARDING
COST PRESSURES. TO OUR COUNTIES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DO THEIR
DEVOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE ICE FORTY TWO NO
THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR AB
FOURTEEN TEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SYMBOL FORTY TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA ANOTHER'S
INOCULATED TEACHERS.
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
KNOW MADAM SPEAKER OUGHT AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE ACCESS
INITIATIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPROVING QUALITY AND QUANTITY
OF COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATORS.
AND CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AB FOURTEEN TEN WILL GOVERN THE
AWARDING OF GRANTS TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS AND ENTERTAINING
COMPUTER SCIENCE AUTHORIZATIONS
THIS BILL IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTIES YOU
KNOW ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE BY SIMPLY BERMAN IS
THERE AN ACCOLADE HEALTH
FACILITIES STERN IS THERE AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE WOULD
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO INCLUDE IN ITS
INVESTIGATIONS ARE PROVIDERS A
PANEL OF PEERS.
OF THE PERSON BEING INVESTIGATED
THIS PANEL WOULD REVIEW THE
ALLEGATIONS AND ASSIST THE
OFFICE IN ITS EVALUATION THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
PRIOR TO AN INTERVIEW.
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
MUST MAKE CLEAR TO THE
INTERVIEWEE THE NATURE OF THE
INTERVIEW AND THE FACT THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE INTERVIEW
CAN BE USED IN CRIMINAL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ENSURE A FAIR
PROCESS FOR PROVIDERS AT STATE
HOSPITALS WERE UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT AND ONE OH SIX AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY THE CAL WORKS MR STONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX UPDATES THE EARNED
INCOME DISREGARD FOR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER STAND SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR DEVOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM?
ONE OH SEVEN AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING ANOTHER
SNACK LATER SURPLUS LAND.
THIRTEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX IS AN UPDATE
OF MY TWENTY FOURTEEN BILL
TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE STRENGTHENING THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT. TO MAKE MORE
SITES AVAILABLE FOR FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AS WE KNOW WE'RE IN A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WE CAN REALLY
HELP BY ENSURING THAT PUBLIC
SURPLUS LAND OWNED BY CITIES.
COUNTIES -- DISTRICTS CAN BE
USED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER WE PASSED A
BILL IN TWENTY FOURTEEN CITIES
IN MANY MANY AGENCIES ACTUALLY
TRIED.
EVERY WHICH WAY TO CIRCUMVENT
THE LAW THEN GO AROUND IT WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE BACK TO TO GO BACK
IN TIME THE LAW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SURPLUS PUBLIC LANDS.
IS ACTUALLY BEING MADE FOR
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
WE CLARIFIED EXISTING PROVISIONS
OF THE SURPLUS LAND ACT.
WE ALSO ARE CREATING A STATEWIDE
DATABASE OF LOCAL SURPLUS LANDS
AND WE'RE LEVERAGING HOUSING
ELEMENT LOST BOTH THE UC THE
EFFICACY OF THE SURPLUS LAND ACT.
I WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
FOR A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG SINGING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE AYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES BY LIGHT AND WANT TO WAIT
FOR AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ SOMETHING GO
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
ANOTHER SNACK LEYVA MEDICO.
THANK YOU ARE CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPENS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR CLARIFIES
THAT TELEHEALTH TELEPHONIC IN
SERVICES OUTSIDE A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. FOUR WALLS MUST
BE REIMBURSABLE WHEN PROVIDED
DURING IN WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF
THE CONCLUSION OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP
GUIDANCE ON THIS ISSUE SO THAT
THE STANDARDS AND EXPECTATIONS
OF RICK FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
OF SERVICES PROVIDED DURING
EMERGENCY ARE CLEAR.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE EVEN WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FIR CURRY.
SEEN HERE NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY KNOWS HEROES
MEASURE PASSES.
BY LATE ONE OH NINE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING BILL FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE
COMMUNITY PARA MEDICINE.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH IS
A CONTINUATION OF MY PREVIOUS
EFFORTS TO ENSURE OUR COMMUNITY
PARA MEDICINES AND ALTERNATIVE
DESTINATIONS.
PALA PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE COMMUNITY
PARA MEDICINES ALLOW
SPECIFICALLY TRAINED PARAMEDICS.
TO PERFORM OUTSIDE OF THEIR
TRADITIONAL ROLE TO ENHANCE
ACCESS TO CARE.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR GIVES
LOCAL AGENCIES THE AUTHORITY TO
DEVELOP THESE PROGRAMS AND
REQUIRED THE STATE DEVELOP A
MINIMUM.
A MINIMUM.
MEDICAL STANDARD IT IS A
THOUGHTFUL AND BALANCED APPROACH
THAT GIVES LOCAL AGENCIES THE
FLEXIBILITY WHILE ENSURING A
HIGH STANDARD OF CARE -- IS
BEING DELIVERED.
THIS BILL IS THE ROOT IS RIGHT.
TO ADDRESS THE MOST BARBARA
INDIVIDUALS -- IN OUR COMMUNITY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TEN
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN FIFTY BY
SOME MEMBER BONTA AN ACCOLADE
MEDICO.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY
WOULD EXTEND THE AMOUNT OF TIME
SOMEONE CAN RECEIVE TREATMENT AT
A CRISIS STABILIZATION UNIT FROM
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. TO THIRTY SIX
HOURS THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NOTES
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE ELEVEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOSE
WE'VE ALSO ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
THREE OF US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ESTABLISHES A SCHOOL
PAVEMENT TO PARKS GRANT PROGRAM.
ADMINISTERED UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE APPLYING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FUNDING FOR CONVERTING
PORTIONS OF PAVEMENT ON THEIR
SCHOOL GROUNDS TO LIVING SCHOOL
YARDS AND GARDENS.
PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT
INCORPORATES SCIENCE MATH
LITERACY IN NUTRITION FOR THEIR
STUDENTS.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO
PARTNER WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONSTO MATCH STATE
GRANT MONEY.
PRIORITY WILL BE GIVEN TO
SCHOOLS WITH POOR AIR QUALITY
AND HIGH AMOUNTS OF STUDENTS ON
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
BRING NATURE TO CHILDREN AND
MAKE IT AN EDUCATIONAL JOYFUL
AND INTEGRAL PART OF THEIR DAILY
LEARNING BY CREATING A SCHOOL
PAYMENT TO PARKS PROGRAM.
FINALLY I WILL BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL TO ENSURE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THOSE IN THE BAY AREA WILL
QUALIFY UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THREE VAST SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY SIX
KNOWS ONE'S MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM.
ONE TWELVE FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE
TEACHERS MISTER RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY
THREE WOULD CREATE THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM A
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIP
GRANTS. TO STUDENTS AND TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE SUCH A GRANT
STUDENTS MUST COMMIT TO TEACHING
FOR FOUR YEARS IN A TEACHER
SHORTAGE AREA WHICH INCLUDES
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
BY LEGAL EDUCATION MATH SCIENCE
OR AND STEM -- THE THE STEM
FIELDS.
AB SIXTY TWENTY THREE IS
SPONSORED BY EDUCATION TRUST
WEST AND PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN THE
SPONSORED AND SUPPORTED BY OVER
THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE A THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
REAL SIXTEEN FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD BACK LETTA
MEDICO.
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IN
MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RELEASED TO CRITICAL AUDIT ON
HOW WELL THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
PROVIDES PREVENTIVE CARE TO
CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WILL TAKE A NUMBER OF
STEPS TO COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESSED THE PROBLEMS
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
BY DRESSING STATE PAYMENT RATES
TO PLANS.
INCREASE INCREASING THE PENALTY
FOR CARE TO NILES REQUIRING
PLANS TO ATTEMPT TO FIND A
CLOSER PROVIDER WHEN
BENEFICIARIES HAVE TO TRAVEL
OUTSIDE THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE NOT REACHING
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN A PREVENTIVE
SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOODS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES IRELAND
ONE FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME MIDDLE SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER WEBER AN
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT.
THIS WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OKAY MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
PROTECT CALIFORNIA CALL CENTER
ACT.
IS BECOME COMMON PRACTICE FOR
CORPORATIONS TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF STATE FUNDING AND
SUBSIDIES WHAT THE SAME TIME
EXPORTING JOBS OVERSEAS.
CALL CENTERS SHOULD BE BASED IN
THE COMMUNITIES WOULDN'T THAT
THEY SERVE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYERS SEEKING TO RELOCATE
CALL CENTERS FROM CALIFORNIA. TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY GIVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HUNDRED TWENTY DAY
NOTICE.
IN ADDITION EMPLOYERS TO EXPORT
CALL CENTERS OVERSEE SHOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING ANY
STATE GRANTS GUARANTEED LOANS OR
TAX BENEFITS FOR AT LEAST FIVE
YEARS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE CUT
THE MUTATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
AND SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD SUPPORT OUR
CALL CENTER WORKERS AND
PRIORITIZE STATE GRANTS AND
SUBSIDIES TO CORPORATIONS THAT
RETAIN.
A JOB IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE ICE FORTY TWO NO
SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
INOCULATED PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
AB SIXTEEN A ONE WOULD REDUCE
THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF EMPLOYED
SUPERVISOR.
PEACE OFFICERS A. K. THROUGH
TWELVE INCOMMUNICADO IT'S
DISTRICTS NECESSARY TO FORM
THEIR OWN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
UNIT.
IT'S CURRENTLY AT TWENTY
SUPERVISORY OFFICERS IN ORDER TO
BE HAVE A UNIT BE RECOGNIZED --
THAT MEANS BASICALLY.
ONE ORGANIZATION FED SAT IN THIS
WOULD BRING IT DOWN DOWN -- TO
TO REDUCING THE MINIMUM DOUBTS
TO SUPERVISORY PEACE OFFICERS TO
FORM A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
UNIT WILL GIVE THE OFFICERS ARE
BUT SHE DECIDE WHETHER TO REMAIN
WITHIN THEIR EXISTING UNITS ARE
ESTABLISH OUR OWN EXCLUSIVE UNIT
OF OF PEACE OFFICERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY NINE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME MIDDLE SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
CORRECTIONS MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS A FOLLOW
UP PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
RECENT AUDIT REPORT OR
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THAT CDC
ARE.
THE AUDIT MAKE CLEAR TO CDC OUR
PROGRAMS LACK SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT AND PROGRAM GOALS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE WISE
INVESTMENTS OF STATE FUNDS. FOR
THE AUDIT KNOWS THAT IF PROGRAMS
ARE 11% SUCCESSFUL THEY WILL
PLAY THEY WILL PAY FOR
THEMSELVES SPECIFICALLY IF ONE
NINE INMATES DOES NOT
RECIDIVISTS WE CAN GENERATE OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
STATE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN ANNUAL
REPORTING BY CDC ARE TO ALLOW
FOR ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT BY THIS
BODY THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME MIDDLE SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER BONTA AN
ACCOLADE MEDICO.
SUR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
WOULD ALLOW PUBLIC AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS OR EMT PROVIDERS TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS.
AND COVER THE ACTUAL COST OF
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION
AND WAS ON CONSENT IN POLICY
COMMITTEE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT A ONE NINETEEN AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE SEVENTY
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CAREER ON OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM SO
PROUD TO POST A PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE THE BILL
THE PROVIDES URGENT AN ONGOING
PROTECTION TO OUR CRITICAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION AND SAFETY ASUS
PROGRAMS ARE CORNERSTONES OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA ASUS ASUS PROGRAM
SERVE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AT FORTY TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS
EVERY DAY.
THESE ARE THEIR AGES PROGRAM
SERVING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
EVERY LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT.
HOWEVER OVER TIME COST TO
OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED SENSE
ACES WITH IMPLEMENTED THE
CALIFORNIA MINIMUM WAGE HAS
INCREASED BY 50% OF THE COST OF
LIVING HAS INCREASED BY 30%.
WHAT THE DAILY REIMBURSEMENT
RATE FOR ASUS HAS ONLY INCREASED
BY 9%?
AS A RESULT THESE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE FREQUENTLY
STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN.
WITHOUT A FUNDING INCREASE ONE
OUT OF FOUR PROGRAMS EXPECTS TO
CLOSE THEIR DOORS TO ABOUT
NINETY ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS.
IN BY TWENTY TWENTY ACROSS MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
MEMBERS HERE'S THE HARD TRUTH
SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BILL TWENTY TWO
PRISONS AND ONLY ONE UNIVERSITY.
WE KNOW THAT IF A CHILD CANNOT
READ BY THIRD GRADE READING
LEVELS THAT CHILD WILL MORE THAN
LIKELY DROP OUT.
OR BE PUSHED INTO A VERY REAL
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
ASUS HELPS ENSURE CHILDREN HAVE
AT LEAST A FIGHTING CHANCE WITH
TUTORING AND ADDITIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IN READING WRITING
AS WELL AS X. BE EXPOSED TO
MUSIC.
AND SPORTS.
ENSURING THAT ASUS PROGRAMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA STATE OPEN
BUTTE AND HERBAL AIR IN URBAN
AREAS OR RURAL AREAS IS CRITICAL
FOR THE EDUCATION OF CHILDREN.
ACROSS OUR STATE.
ULTIMATELY AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
FIVE WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS AND HIGH QUALITY
ASUS PROGRAM BY CREATING A
MECHANISM THAT WILL ALLOW ASUS
PROGRAM TO SURVIVE.
FUTURE MINIMUM WAGE AND COST OF
LIVING INCREASES.
THIS BILL IN SHORES THAT ASUS
PROGRAM STAY OPEN.
PROVIDE NUTRITIOUS MEALS AND
IT'S A SAFETY NET FOR CHILDREN
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER -- YES HAS BECOME
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES --
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
WE'VE ALL SEEN OUR DISTRICTS --
THE VALUE OF AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS -- BUT CERTAINLY IT HIT
HOME FOR ME -- THIS YEAR IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE CAMPFIRE -- THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF THE NORTH
VALLEY.
WAS A HUGE CRITICAL PIECE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP GIVE KIDS
WHO HAD GONE THROUGH PURE HELL
WHO HAD GONE THROUGH TRAUMA.
STABILITY AND A PLACE TO GO --
TO SOME OF THEIR FACILITIES WERE
BURNED UP ON THE RIDGE -- THEY
MADE -- ROOM AN ACCESS AVAILABLE
DOWN IN CHICO FOR MANY THESE
KIDS AND THEY WERE THEY WERE A
VITAL LIFELINE -- SO WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THESE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THINK ABOUT THIS AS A
VITAL PIECE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HELPS US -- YOU KNOW BOTH
IN A IN GOOD TIMES AND AND IN
BAD AND SO -- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE NEGATIVE ASPECTS OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES THAT THIS
IS AFFECTING PROGRAMS LIKE.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS -- AND AND
ARE AS YOU KNOW DEVELOP REALLY
DISABLED PROGRAMS WE NEED TO
HAVE INCREASE FUNDING TO ENSURE
THAT.
THESE PROGRAMS CAN REMAIN STABLE
REMAIN THAT THAT PLACES
STABILITY FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NOFURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISS CREEL
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT THESE FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ACCESS. TO A SAFETY NET THROUGH
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO DEBATE ISSUES THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND FUNDING FOR
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO OUR STATE.
LET'S AT LEAST MOVE SOME MONEY
FOR TO MAKE SURE THAT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE VIABLE.
CONTINUE TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
HEARING NO FOR THE RATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTY TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AN
ACCOLADE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES A DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHICH TAKE PLACE ON OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO BE EXCELLENT TOOLS
FOR ENCOURAGING COLLEGE
READINESS.
PARTICIPATING STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMPLETE COLLEGE THAN
THEIR NON PARTICIPATING PEERS
AND CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT HAS
PROVEN PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE
FOR YOUNG MEN OF COLOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SUMMER IS THE IDEAL TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN TWO
ONE MOMENT PROGRAMS AS STUDENTS
ARE FREE OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WORKLOAD
THAT COME WITH THEIR REGULAR
ACADEMIC YEAR.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHO MAY ENROLL IN SUMMER COURSES
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ONLY 5% OF STUDENTS PER GRADE
LEVEL PER SCHOOL ARE PERMITTED
TO ENROLL IN THESE PROGRAMS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE EXPAND
COLLEGE ACCESS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS DURING THE SUMMER BY
REMOVING THE 5% LIMITATION FOR
STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN GENERAL
EDUCATION COURSES THAT TRANSFER
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY OR A
CAREER TECH PROGRAM.
THIS BILL LEAVES IN PLACE
RESTRICTIONS ON PHYSICAL
EDUCATION COURSES AND COURSES
DURING THE REGULAR ACADEMIC YEAR.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
THE ON NUMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT AND 1-218-759-1750 NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY SOME THE RIVER SALAS AND
OTHERS NOT PLAYED A HEALTHCARE
MR SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A PERCENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE WHICH WILL
HELP ADDRESS.
THE GROWING HEALTH CARE WORK FOR
SHORTAGE RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
BY LATE ONE TWENTY TWO AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME BILLS SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY ANOTHER IS NOT GOING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH MR DAILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ADOPT.
BEST PRACTICES FOR OPERATING
RECOVERY HOUSING IN OUR STATE.
RECOVERY HOUSING IS ONE STEP
ALONG A LENGTHY PROCESS FOR
PEOPLESEEKING TO EMERGE FROM
DRUG OR ALCOHOL ADDICTION.
UNLIKE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES WHICH ARE SUBJECT TO
LICENSURE BY THE STATE RECOVERY
RESIDENCES ARE PRIVATE
RESIDENCES THAT ARE NOT LICENSED
OR REGULATED.
DESPITE THE GROWING DEATH TOLL
FROM DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE AND
ADDICTION CALIFORNIA LACKS A
UNIFORM SET OF STANDARDS. TO
GUIDE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
LOVED ONES.
IN IDENTIFYING SAFE RELIABLE
HOUSING ACCOMMODATIONS THAT WILL
BE CONDUCIVE TO RECOVERY.
BY ADOPTING BEST PRACTICES
INCLUDING MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
RECOVERY RESIDENCES OUR STATE
WILL TAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARD INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
RESIDENCES.
THEY'RE SAFE FOR PEOPLE IN
RECOVERY AS WELL AS FOR THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY ARE
LOCATED.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO THE
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY SIX NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
ANOTHER'S NECK LATER EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
PART OF OUR PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
PACKAGES YEAR THIS BILL WILL
MODERNIZE AND UPDATE OUR
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE FOR
OUR STATE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS THROUGH A
SINGLE.
REGION ALLIES REIMBURSEMENT RATE
WE HAVE A COMPANION BILL IN THE
SENATE AND THESE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES AS WE PROBABLY NOW ARE TOO
LOW BUT THE IN IMPACT ACCESS.
OR LAST FOR YEARS FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE INCREASED SLOTS FOR OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
BUT HAD PROVIDERS SAY NO THANKS
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
INADEQUATE A RATE REIMBURSEMENTS
AT THIS WILL MAKE OUR PROGRAMS
MORE VIABLE.
AS WELL AS IMPROVE QUALITY --
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY NINE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE TWENTY FOUR AB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
IMMACULATELY JUVENILES MISTER
CHANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
PERCENT EIGHTY EIGHT SIX ONE A
BILL SUPPORT THE HOMELESS YOUTH
AND CALIFORNIA'S LEFT.
AND FALL OUT OF THE FOSTER YOUTH
SYSTEM AND WISH TO REENTER THIS
WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT A SOCIAL WORKER HAS TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO FILE A
PETITION.
THE JUVENILE COURT FROM THREE
WEEKS TO TEN DAYS THIS HAD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU MISTER CHAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALENT VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS WHEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTIES. SIX AB FORT FOURTEEN
BY MR BONTA THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FOURTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER BONTA AN ACCOLADE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
IS YOUR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
A BEFORE FOURTEEN WHICH
REESTABLISHES THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT'S INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
PENALTY PAYMENTS.
THAT CONGRESS ROLLED BACK THERE
BY ENSURING THAT HEALTH CARE
REMAINS AFFORDABLE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVEHEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S REPEAL
OF THE PENALTY PAYMENT IS
PROJECTED TO RESULT IN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
HEALTH COVERAGE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR EQUITABLE
INCLUSIVE AND AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE FOR OUR RESIDENTS.
WITH THIS BILL OUR SITE WITHOUT
THIS BILL WE WILL HAVE HIGHER
PREMIUMS IN A SICKER COSTLIER
POPULATION WITH THIS BILL WILL
HAVE LOWER PREMIUMS AND
HEALTHIER.
LESS EXPENSIVE POPULATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE STAKES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY THREE
KNOWS TWELVE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AB FOR THIRTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AN ACCOLADE
HOUSING.
MR DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO ESTABLISH A
UNIVERSAL APPLICATION FORM. FOR
SEVERAL OF THE STATE HOUSING
PROGRAMS IT RUNS.
OUR LEGISLATURE IN VOTERS HAVE
APPROVED NEW SOURCES OF REVENUE
FOR HOUSING CONSTRUCTION IN
RECENT YEARS.
THOSE REVENUES OF EITHER
ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING
OR PUMP NEW LIFE INTO EXISTING
PROGRAMS ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
THE UNIVERSAL FORM REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL WILL STREAMLINE THE
APPLICATION PROBLEM PROCESS FOR
THOSE WHO WILL BUILD THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY IN VIOLATED ONE
TWENTY NINE FILE.
AND FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE AB EIGHT
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WORKS IN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE AND ON THE HEEL
VEHICULAR EVOLUTION THIS WORKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WILD FIRES
HAVE A BECAUSE A LOT OF DAMAGE
IN OUR STATE OVER THE LAST
TERRIBLE AIR QUALITY I KNOW MANY
OF US HAVE.
BREATHED IT OURSELVES AND SEEN
IT AND AND FELT IT.
OUGHT TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THESE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS FROM
CONTAMINATED AIR AND AND
POLLUTION -- IDENTIFIED CLEAN
AIR CENTERS WOULD PROVIDE HEALTH
YOUR HEALTH YOUR INDOOR
ENVIRONMENTS TO THE PUBLIC
DURING THESE EMERGENCY AIR
QUALITY EVENTS.
AND MY BILL AB THREE SORRY EIGHT
SIX EIGHT THREE SIX WHAT IS
DOUBLE TO PROGRAM TO IDENTIFY
CLEANER CENTERS -- AND ESTABLISH
A GRANT FUND TO RETROFIT
FACILITIES AND UPGRADE
VENTILATION FOR LIBRARIES
COMMUNITY CENTERS SENIOR SENIOR
SERVICE CENTERS AND OTHERS
PARTICULARLY FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THOSE ARE WHO ARE
ELDERLY WHO ARE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN OUR HAVE.
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WAXING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT
NEWS HEROES MEASURE PASSES
VIOLATE ONE THIRTY TWO AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SWIMMING POOL OF ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE OUTDOOR
RECREATION.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I BRING YOU TODAY AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN ABOUT A BILL THAT HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO NO VOTES THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A NEW OFFICE OF OUTDOOR
RECREATION FOR CALIFORNIA WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN RECOGNIZES AT
THE OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMY
IS TREMENDOUS IN OUR STATE.
OVER NINETY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
COMES INTO OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE
OF OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL SPENDING
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND A
DIRECTLY CREATES MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND JOBS.
AND YET OTHER STATES THAT HAVE A
SIMILAR OFFICES FIND A PER
CAPITA THEY ARE GENERATING MORE
INCOME -- IN THEIR OUTDOOR
RECREATION ECONOMY BECAUSE THEY
ARE INVESTING IN IT AND SOMEONE
SAID TO ME ONCE WHY IS THIS
NECESSARY WOMAN BE OF A GROUP OF
PARK IS FILLED WITH PEOPLE.
YES GRAVERT PARK IS FILLED WITH
PEOPLE IN VENICE BEACH IS FILLED
WITH PEOPLE BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
FROM OHIO ARE TRAVELING TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER OR THE
MCCALLUM NAY HOW MANY TO HOW
OFTEN DO WE PROVIDE TRULY
PROMOTE.
THE WIDE ABOUT ARRAY OF OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES THAT WE HAVE NOT JUST
IN A FEW AREAS BUT IN A LOTS OF
OUR AREAS THAT COULD ABSOLUTELY
USE THAT TYPE OF ECONOMIC
INFUSION BUT DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEMSELVES TO INVEST
IN IT.
I'M WITH THAT I WOULD -- AGAIN
REMOTE REMIND YOU THAT THIS IS
RECEIVE WHY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND ALSO GEOGRAPHICAL SUPPORT
ACROSS THE STATE AND I REQUEST
WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX
KNOWS HEROES MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOMETHING ROLL LEVIN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA OTHERS
AND I BELIEVE THE LOGIC
ESTABLISHMENTS MR COLOR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THE PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC WASTE IS HAVING A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OVERWHELMING
LANDFILLS.
THOSE TINY PLASTIC SHAMPOO
BOTTLES ARE A COMMON HOTEL ROOMS
REPRESENT A SIZEABLE NOT ALWAYS
THAT CAN BE EASILY ELIMINATED.
THROUGH MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
ALTERNATIVES.
SENATE BILL THAT IN SIXTY TWO
WOULD RESTRICT HOTELS OF THE
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS REPLACING
SMALL SINGLE USE BOTTLES OF
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER ABOUT SO.
IN GUESTROOMS OUR BATHROOMS BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOUR
LARGE HOTELS AND GENERATE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FOR HOTELS FIFTY
ROOMS ARE LESS.
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS ELEVEN AB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO AND IS IN LINE
WITH THE INDUSTRY'S EFFORT TO
MINIMIZE ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT.
AND IN FACT WE KNOW THAT SANTA
CLARA SENATE CRUZ COUNTY HAS ITS
OWN ORDINANCE AND WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT OTHER SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS LOOKING AT DOING
THEIR OWN ORDINANCES.
SO THE LOCAL PREEMPTION PIECES
CRITICAL FOR THE INDUSTRY
WITHOUT BEING SUBJECT TO BRING
LOCAL ORDINANCES INDUSTRIES
PREPARED TO COMPLY WITH THE
STATE'S STANDARD AS WORKABLE FOR
AN INDUSTRY THAT'S ALREADY
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
EACH ROOM TO GENERATE UP TO A
THOUSAND TINY BOTTLES PER YEAR
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WASTE
DOESN'T OLYMPOS REMOVING A
SIGNIFICANT?
ALSO IT'S NOT FEASIBLE FOR THESE
POSSIBLE AS TO BE MANAGED AND
RECYCLE BECAUSE THEIR SMALL SIZE
AND RESIDUAL PRODUCT LEFT IN THE
BOTTLES.
UP WITH SO MANY VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES PROVIDING BACK TO
THE TREES TO GAS THE LODGING
INDUSTRY IS IN A PRIME POSITION.
TO PHASE OUT THIS PRACTICE AND
ONCE AGAIN CONTINUE TO ESTABLISH
ITSELF ON THE FOREFRONT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
SQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
ALL MEMBERS THE RESERVE AT THIS
REQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE SQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS I
THEREFORE CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO
NEWS TWENTY THREE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON ANOTHER WAS AN ATHLETE IN
JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL SCHOOL
PUPILS.
MEMBERS.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH SEEKS
TO ENSURE CONSISTENT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU INVOLVE
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
COLLABORATE WITH PROBATION ON AN
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN FOR YOUTH
TRANSITIONING.
OUT OF JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
COURT SCHOOL STUDENTS GET THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO TRANSITION
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
THRIVE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE -- MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALENT
ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE NO SIX IS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FIVE A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
LEGAL THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE THE COMMUNICATIONS.
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AB MADAM SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
WOULD EXTEND THE PROVISION THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE PRESERVING
THE LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT OF
VOICE OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL.
AND INTERNET PROTOCOL ENABLED
SERVICES UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY
RATHER THAN LETTING THESE POLICY
QUESTIONS BE TURNED OVER TO A
CUMBERSOME REGULATORY AGENCY.
IT ALSO PROVIDE NEW PROTECTIONS
FOR CONSUMERS OF THESE SERVICES
INCLUDING ESTABLISHING A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR STANDARD FOR
RESTORATION OF SERVICE AFTER
REPORTED OUTAGE IN WHICH STEPS
TO RESTORE THE SERVICE MUST BE
INITIATED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS.
CREATE AN OPTION FOR A BILL
CREDIT TO CUSTOMERS WITH SERVICE
HAS NOT BEEN RESTORED WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
REQUIRING A DISCLOSURE REGARDING
BACKUP BATTERY NEEDS FOR VOICE
AND ALTERNATIVES WHICH EXIST
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO BASIC
SERVICE AND REQUIRING THAT ANY
COMPLAINTS FROM V<c.cyan> CUSTOMERS</c>
RECEIVED BY THE CPUC.
INCLUDED IN THEIR ANNUAL REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN IN A
REPORT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FOR POSSIBLE ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
CODIFIED A POLICY RESERVING ANY
STATE REGULATION AVOID.
PROTOCOL AND I. P. ENABLE
SERVICES FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SINCE IN CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
CONTINUED BENEFITING FROM THE
SERVICES FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE WERE CALLING HOME MEANS
PLACING A CALL TO A FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
IP ENABLED SERVICES ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART TO STAYING
CONNECTED WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY
COSTLY LONG DISTANCE OR
INTERNATIONAL TELEPHONE BILLS.
BEFORE THE SERVICES WERE
AVAILABLE PEOPLE HAD TO RELY ON
RIDICULOUSLY EXPENSIVE
INTERNATIONAL CALLING CARDS
WHICH A REAL OBSTACLES IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LOW INCOME.
THE CLARITY PROVIDED
LEGISLATURE'S EXCUSE EXCLUSIVE
OF THIRTY OVER THE SERVICES WILL
SUNSET JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
BUT THIS DOESN'T SEEK TO JUST
MAINTAIN STATUS QUO.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU HAVE TALKED
TO ME ABOUT YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
LABOR'S OPPOSITION TO MY BILL
WHICH CONCERNS ME AS WELL I REST
ASSURED THAT I'M WORKING CLOSELY
WITH CW A AND THE LABOR
FEDERATION TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS.
AND I'LL TELL YOU IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS
BECAUSE AT THE SAME TIME AS
WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME
SORT OF PROTECTIONS -- EIGHTEEN
T. DID SOME MASSIVE LAYOFFS LAST
WEEK YOU KNOW TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND NATION WIDE OF LAYOFFS
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA NINETY SEVEN IN SAN
DIEGO AND SIXTY ONE IN MY OWN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL
PIECE OF WORKING WITH LABOR TO
ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
A WORK FORCE IN THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE AN IN STATE WORKFORCE IN
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
VITAL CUSTOMER SERVICE WHICH
MEANS VITAL IMPORTANT JOBS SO I
I I VERY UNCOMFORTABLE ASKING.
FOR SUPPORT ON A BILL THAT I
LABOR OPPOSES AT THIS TIME BUT
MY COMMITMENT IS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ MR
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX THIS.
BILL DOES NOT CREATE A NEW X.
EXEMPTION THEY MERELY CONTINUES
THE EXISTING STATE OF AFFAIRS
JUST TO BE CLEAR.
IT'S NOT THAT THESE INDUSTRIES
ARE NOT CURRENTLY REGULATED THEY
ARE REGULATED HERE BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO THE P. YOU
SEE I THINK THAT'S A VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR THESE INTERNET
TECHNOLOGIES AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE MISS
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
KIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
SQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FOR THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE A
SPORTFISHING MISTER WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD CHANGE THE
WAY CALIFORNIA ISSUE SPORT
FISHING LICENCES.
CURRENTLY ANNUAL SPORT FISHING
LICENSES TO EXPIRE ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST REGARDLESS OF WHEN
YOU PURCHASE THE LICENSE.
THIS BILL WOULD STE INSTEAD MAKE
LICENSES BUT LICENSES BALLOT
ABOUT FOR A YEAR FROM THE DATE
OF PURCHASE JUST LIKE YOUR CAR
REGISTRATION YOUR TRIPLE A
MEMBERSHIP YOUR COSTCO
MEMBERSHIP.
OF THE PROPOSAL IS PART OF A
LARGER RECRUITMENT RETENTION
REACTIVATION PROCESS THE THE ARE
THREE PROCESS THE DEPARTMENTS
WORKING THROUGH WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE ADMINISTRATION AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOOD.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THE MAN IS BIGGER MEMBERS THIS
IS A GREAT BILL -- IT WILL ALLOW
US. TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
FISHING.
IN THIS STATE FISHING LICENSES
BRING A LOT OF REVENUE TO HELP
SUPPORT CONSERVATION EFFORTS AND
ANY OTHER PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE NEED PEOPLE GET NOT THEIR
FISHING RECREATION.
ENJOY IN THE THE BOUNTIFUL
NATURE THAT WE HAVE -- IN THIS
GREAT STATE -- WE'VE WE'VE TRIED
THIS BILL A COUPLE OF TIMES GOT
OVER THE SENATE.
THIS YEAR WE'RE GETTING IT
THROUGH SO THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH AND WE
WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER MISS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
WOULD YOU MAY CLOSE.
UP RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THERE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
KNOWS ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN AB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TODAY 2% AB THREE
EIGHT SEVEN A BILL THAT WILL
MAKE MINOR CHANGES TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUG LABELING.
AB THREE EIGHT SEVEN WILL HELP
PATIENTS MORE EASILY IDENTIFY
AND DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
MEDICATIONS THERE BY REDUCING
PREVENTABLE ADVERSE DRUG OFFENSE.
AIRS DUE TO MEDICATIONS WITH
SUMMER NAMES ARE COMMON AN
ESTIMATED TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THOUSANDS OF DEATHS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN COSTS EVERY YEAR.
THIS BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
PHYSICIANS TO DISCUSS WITH
PATIENTS THE OPTION OF LISTING
THE PURPOSE OF A DRUG ON ITS
LABEL WHICH HELPS TO AVOID
CONFUSION AND PROTECT PATIENT
PRIVACY.
WE'VE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OPPOSITION TO
REMOVE THEIR CONCERNS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
MR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL A
DOCTOR'S -- SOMETIMES PRESCRIBE
A DRUG FOR SOMETHING OFF LABEL
WHEN YOU GO TO A NEW DOCTOR --
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THAT DOCTOR
TO KNOW WHY THE OTHER DOCTOR HAD --
PRESCRIBED IT AND THEY MAY NOT
NOW UNLESS WE HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS SO AGAIN I URGE YOU
NINE VOTE ON A. B. THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER GAVE
REALLY MAKE THOSE.
YOU HEARD THERE FROM A DOCTOR
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE A
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MYERS FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE SCORES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE OR KIRK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY EIGHT FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
NIGHTLY THE PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR MISS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU AND SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I'M PROUD TODAY PRESENT EIGHTEEN
TH. FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE I WISH
SIX TO BALANCE CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS ORGANIC.
WASTE DIVERSION GOALS WITH
CHANGING MARKET REALITIES AS WE
KNOW TRYING HIS NATIONAL SORT
POLICY IS CRIPPLED OUR RECYCLING
SECTOR AND AS A RESULT OUR
LANDFILLS ARE OVERFLOWING.
AB FIFTY NAY THREE IS A STEP TO
ADDRESS THE RISING NEED FOR
ORGANIC RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MARKET DEVELOPMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE --
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB TWO
EIGHTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME A BILL TO EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU AN
ACCOLADE CAL WORKS.
MISTER KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKERS AND A MEMBERS.
AB TWO EIGHTY THREE WERE REDUCE
FINANCIAL PENALTIES TO A MAXIMUM
OF FIFTY DOLLARS.
PLACE ON CAL WORKS FAMILIES FOR
FAILING TO COMPLY A WAS PROOF OF
DESTINATION OR STUDENT
ATTENDANCE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ARE.
EXTENDED THE DEADLINE -- MEDIA
REQUIREMENT FROM THIRTY DAYS TO
SIXTY DAYS M. PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS TO HELP
FAMILY COMPLY RATHER THAN BURDEN
THE FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS THREE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEMS
ONE FORTY ONE THROUGH ONE FORTY
THREE FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR
AB SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
ACCOLADE HEALTH FACILITIES.
IS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WHICH MAKES
IT NECESSARY WHICH MAKES THE
NECESSARY REFORMS TO THE NURSING
HOME INDUSTRY WHEN A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP.
A CURSE TO ADDRESS ISSUES WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS DURING THIS PROCESS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING CERTIFYING AND
ENFORCING REGULATORY STANDARDS
RELATED TO THE QUALITY CARE
PROVIDED IN SKILLED NURSING HOME
FACILITIES AND OTHER HEALTH
RELATED FACILITIES.
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF FORMS AND
DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE TO OPERATE A NURSING
HOME THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
APPROVAL PROCESS MAY TAKE AT
LEAST. FOUR MONTHS OR LONGER AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BY REQUIRING THAT A
LICENSEE NOTIFIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND ALL RESIDENTS AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES NO LATER THAN
NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO THE SALE OF
TRANSFER.
SALE OR TRANSFER CLARIFYING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT.
THAT AND FOR ENTITIES THAT ACT
AS MANAGEMENT COMPANIES AND
REQUIRING A SIXTY DAY TRANSITION
PERIOD OF STAFF WITH NO
REDUCTION IN WAGES. TO ALLOW FOR
RESIDENTS TO EXPERIENCE THE
CONTINUITY IN CARE AND PREVENT
DISRUPTIVE TURN OVER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
ENSURE THAT OUR INTENT FOR AB.
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE IT'S CLEAR
AND THAT ULTIMATELY RESIDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES FEEL
CONFIDENCE IN THE QUALITY OF THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE.
AND THE NURSING HOME STAFF ARE
INVULNERABLE TO ABRUPT CHANGES
IN OWNERSHIP AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALITA EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX A. B.
[inaudible]
TEN THIRTY SIX WHAT.
WELL THAT THAT WE ARE PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN AB.
NINE OH ONE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES -- FORTY ONE MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE QUIRK CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible] FIVE FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SIX AB TEN THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ.
THE LABEL TEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO ELECTIONS
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. TEN THIRTY
SIX WERE REDUCE BARRIERS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST TO REQUIRE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO UPDATE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE REGULATIONS
DIRECTING COUNTY OFFICIALS TO
DEVELOP VOTER OUTREACH PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY COUNTIES HAVE
VERY LOW REGISTRATION REDS RATES
IN SOME COUNTIES CLOSE 240% OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS ARE NOT
REGISTERED.
INCREASING VOTER REGISTRATION
THESE COUNTIES WILL INCREASE
VOTER PARTICIPATION A
PARTICIPATION IN THE CENSUS
SECOND AB TEN THIRTY SIX CREATES
A HIGH SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION
PILOT PROGRAM.
IN YELLOW COUNTY.
THE PILOT WILL STUDY MARQUEE
ELECTIONS AT HIGH SCHOOLS
CONDUCTED.
AT HIGH SCHOOLS CONDUCTED WITH
OFFICIAL ELECTIONS EQUIPMENT
LIKE VOTING MACHINES AND BALLOTS
THIS WILL TEACH OUR YOUNGER
GENERATION HOW TO CAST A BALLOT.
SO THEY ARE EXCITED AND
CONFIDENT WHEN THEY GO ON TO THE
FIRST POLL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY KNOWS A
LEVIN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR DEVOTE --
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
IT'S REQUIRES.
EPARED
ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB TEN NINETY
TO THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS THOSE RESERVE --
MYERS -- FORTY ONE MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
KNOWS NINETEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
COMPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SIX
KNOWS TWENTY THIS MEASURE PASSES?
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO TAKE
UP THE SPEAKER PRO TEM THIS
BILLS.
WE WILL START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT AB.
FIVE SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MR
MULLIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE VERY
FEW STATES TO HAVE STATE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS BUT
NO LOCAL CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS THIS MEANS THAT UNLESS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTS ITS OWN.
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
LITERALLY ANY AMOUNT CAN BE
CONTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO A
CANDIDATE FOR LOCAL OFFICE WE'VE
SEEN EXAMPLES OF CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS RECEIVING DIRECT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A SINGLE
DAUGHTER.
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS SALARY.
EVEN AS HIGH AS ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THIS MAGNITUDE UNDERMINE
PUBLIC TRUST IN DEMOCRACY AB
FIVE SEVEN ONE ESTABLISHES
DEFAULT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS.
OF FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT
ADOPTED THEIR OWN LIMITS THIS IS
THE SAME INDIVIDUAL CONTRIBUTION
LIMIT WE ARE BOUND BY THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE.
IS IMPORTANT STRESS THAT AB FIVE
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE MAINTAINS
COMPLETE LOCAL CONTROL AT ANY
POINT A LOCAL JURISDICTION CAN
OPT OUT BY ENACTING ITS OWN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS WHETHER
LOWER OR HIGHER.
THAN THE DEFAULT THIS IS SIMPLY
A BACKSTOP AB FIVE SEVEN ONE IS
A GOOD GOVERNANCE MEASURE THAT
WILL HELP ENSURE PUBLIC TRUST IN
LOCAL ELECTIONS AND I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THIS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS REQUIRES
.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE [inaudible]
REYES.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS REQUIRES
.
FIFTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY FIVE NO THIRTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SOMETHING ALL TWELVE SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS YOU MAY RECALL THAT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I KERRY LEGISLATION
ESTABLISHING THE DISCLOSE ACT.
TO REQUIRE GREATER DISCLOSURE ON
CERTAIN TYPES OF CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISING AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
SIMPLY SEEKS TO EXTEND THE
CALIFORNIA DISCLOSE ACT TO COVER
ISSUE ADS THAT ARE INTENDED TO
INFLUENCE LEGISLATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS.
AND ALSO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE FOR
ELECTION HEARING COMMUNICATIONS
THAT ATTACK OR SUPPORT
CANDIDATES DURING ELECTION
SEASON WITHOUT EXPRESSLY
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR ELECTION OR
DEFEAT.
ISSUE ADVERTISEMENTS THAT
ATTEMPT TO PRESSURE LEGISLATORS
TO INFLUENCE LEGISLATIVE
OUTCOMES ARE GROWING ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR GROUP PLACED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED ADS ON FACEBOOK TRYING
TO KILL A NET NEUTRALITY BILL.
THIS YEAR THERE BEEN SEVERAL ADS
RUNNING ON VARIOUS FORMS OF
MEDIA CLEARLY DESIGNED TO
MOTIVATE PUBLIC INTERACTION WITH
LEGISLATORS ON ISSUES SUCH AS
POLICE USE OF FORCE.
AS WELL AS LOCAL HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG IN FACT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
PUBLIC INTERACTION IN THE
PROCESS OF LAW MAKING.
MY ONLY GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC IS INFORMED AS
TO WHO IS ACTUALLY PAYING FOR
THOSE ADS WHICH ARE REQUESTING.
THAT PARTICIPATION IF THE ATIS
BEING PAID FOR BY A CERTAIN
INDUSTRY OR NONPROFIT GROUP THE
PUBLIC MAY Y. MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER.
WHETHER THE GROUP'S INTEREST
ALIGNED WITH THEIR OWN INTERESTS
AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN IS VERY
STRAIGHT FORWARD IT SIMPLY
EXTENDS THE SAME PRINCIPLES THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED BY TWO
THIRDS MAJORITY IN OUR LAST
SESSION. TO ADVERTISEMENT
SEEKING TO AFFECT PUBLIC POLICY
THE SAME AS THOSE SEEKING TO
IMPACT ELECTIONS AND I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN THE ISSUE AT DISCLOSE
ACT.
THIS BILL TAKES A CRUCIAL STEP
BY APPLYING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE DISCLOSE ACT ISSUE
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO
CONTACT THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS.
ABOUT PENDING ISSUES. TOO OFTEN
THESE TIMES OF ISSUE
ADVERTISEMENTS ARE SUPERFICIAL
AND MISLEADING SO IMPROVING
DISCLOSURE OF THE ENTITIES THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR FUNDING
THOSE ADS WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CONTEXT TORE CONSTITUENTS TO SEE
THE ADS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FIRST
CONTINUED EFFORTS AS A CHAMPION
FOR IMPROVING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN POLITICAL
ADVERTISING.
BOTH AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
ORIGINAL DISCLOSE ACT END OF
THIS BILL AND VERSE PERSEVERANCE
AND CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
OF THE ROAD RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENT
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS.
ARE BOTH WORKABLE AND EFFECTIVE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
MISTER BERMAN MR MALIK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER BOWLING YOU
MAY CLOSE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM PALO ALTO FIRST KIND WORDS
AND THE WORKING ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF
WORKING THROUGH SOME --
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH REGARD TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
AND I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE F. P. P. C. TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A VERY WORKABLE A
REGULATORY SCHEME GOING FORWARD
WITH REGARD TO ISSUE ADD.
REGULATION AND DISCLOSURE.
AND I ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible] FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
WHERE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
FIRST.
FIFTY FOUR CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS FOR THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS
ONE FORTY SEVEN THROUGH.
ONE FORTY NINE MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
FILE WITH FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
TWENTY FIVE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER CHAO AND ACTUALLY
CONSUMER PRIVACY.
MR CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM.
BAKER IN MEMBERS SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONE ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED IS WHETHER.
THE DEFINITION OF CONSUMER
INCLUDES AN EMPLOYEE AB TWENTY
FIVE CLARIFIES THAT THE
DEFINITION OF CONSUMER EXCLUDES
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED.
IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
ACTIVITIES AS AN EMPLOYEE
CONTRACTOR AGEN OR JOB APPLICANT
BUT ONLY TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
INFORMATION IS USED SOLELY. FOR
PURPOSES RELATED TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES THIS WILL ADDRESS THE
POSSIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE THAT AN
EMPLOYEE ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT MIGHT REQUEST TO
EXPUNGE COMPLAINTS ABOUT.
ALL OF THEM AT WORK THIS
CLARIFICATION ALSO ENSURES THAT
INDIVIDUALS RETAIN THEIR RIGHTS
AS A CONSUMER UNDER THE SEA CPA.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO SEEK TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE ABOUT
BUSINESSES COMPLYING WITH
CONSUMERS REQUIRES FOR SPECIFIC
PIECES OF INFORMATION.
IN A PRIVACY PROTECTIVE MANNER
PARTICULARLY WHEN CERTAIN --
INFORMATION MIGHT BE TIED TO A
HOUSEHOLD OR DEVICES THAT
CONSUME A SHARES WITH OTHERS.
THAT LANGUAGE WILL BE AMENDED
INTO THE BILL WHEN AND IF THERE
IS CONSENSUS AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO'S SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BURKE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY ONE KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB ONE
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY SIX BY
SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB ONE
THIRTY SIX WHICH IS PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS AUTHORED BY MY
COLLEAGUES.
RELATED TO THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL AND MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN MORE THAN FIFTY
PEOPLE WERE INDICTED BY FRED
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
CHARGES RANGE FROM COLLEGE COACH
BRIBES STANDARDIZED COLLEGE
TESTING ADMINISTRATORS WHO WERE
PAID FOR ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND
PARENTS TO PAY BRIBES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TO SECURE YOUR
ADMISSIONS TO THE BEST
UNIVERSITIES.
THAT THE UNITED STATES HAS TO
OFFER.
THOSE INVOLVED USED A NUMBER OF
SCHEMES WHICH VIOLATED FEDERAL
AND STATE.
TAX LAWS WELL ALSO REAPING TAX
BENEFITS RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN WITH INPUT FROM MEMBERS OF
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE ALL TYPES
OF TAX FRAUD OR ADDRESSED
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING ON
UNLAWFUL BUSINESS EXPENSES.
OR CORPORATION DEDUCTIONS AB ONE
THIRTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE THOSE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WHO ARE
NAMED IN THE FEDERAL INDICTMENT
AND FOUND GUILTY TO MEND THEIR
STATE TAX RETURNS.
AND DISCLOSURES THIS CRIMINAL
ACTION HAS VICTIMIZED HARD
WORKING STUDENTS WHO WERE DENIED
ADMISSIONS BECAUSE OF THE
ACTIONS OF THOSE INVOLVED AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO SO AT THE
EXPENSE OF CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
WE CAN'T LOOK THE OTHER WAY AND
WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE.SQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY TO READ. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB SIX TWENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
SOME THE MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MR COLOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB SIX TWENTY FIVE WHICH EXTENDS
AN EMPLOYEE RETENTION 10% BIT
PURPOSE ALL PUBLIC TRANSIT
CONTRACTS AWARDED BY THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA.
THE 10% BIG PREFERENCES A
SCORING CREDIT ON A STATE BID
FOR THE TRANSIT OPERATOR THAT
VOLUNTARILY AGREES TO RETAIN THE
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES THE PREVIOUS
CONTRACTOR. FOR A MINIMUM OF
NINETY DAYS.
THE WAGES AND BENEFITS OF ANY
RETAIN EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE THE SAME AS ON
THE PREVIOUS CONTRACTOR WITHOUT
THIS SIMPLE YET IMPORTANT
EMPLOYEE RETENTION PROVISION.
STATE TRANSIT WORKER JOBS ARE AT
RISK FOR CONTRACTING OUT WE MUST
ACT PREVENT UNNECESSARY AND
COSTLY TRANSIT WORKER LAYOFFS.
THIS MEASURE HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE ICE FORTY FIVE KNOWS
FOURTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE TO PERMIT THE CS
USED TO AWARD DOCTORATE DEGREES
IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY. TO
COMPLY WITH CHANGING
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS -- TEASE
SUPPORT CHILDREN WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES PEOPLE RECOVERING
FROM INJURIES AND OLDER ADULTS
EXPERIENCING COGNITIVE OR
PHYSICAL CHANGES.
AS WITH MANY HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS CALIFORNIA HAS A
SHORTAGE OF TEAS AND RANKS IN
FACT FORTY FOURTH IN THE NATION
IN ACCESS TO OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS.
CURRENTLY SEVENTY SIX OF THE
NINETY SIX OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY ARE TRANSITIONING TO A
DOCTORATE DEGREE INCLUDING ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE PROGRAM
SO.
AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH AN
AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR STUDENTS
PURSUING A CAREER IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
AB TWENTY NINE IS HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THOSE FOREIGN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK ABOUT A SPEAKER VERY
QUICKLY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I REPRESENT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN FRESNO THIS CAN BE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR UNIVERSITY
BUT ALSO I THINK VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGINGIT FORWARD.
I ASK FOR STRONG AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO THEIR
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY ONE NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB TEN FORTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ AS A
LEGAL TEN FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY THE
PARTICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
MR TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AB TEN FORTY SIX
INCREASES THE FOCUS.
OF THE ANNUAL FORECAST THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD MUST CONDUCT FOR
THE STATE'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT.
THE BILL CODIFIES THAT DIRECTION
SO THAT THE A A RP IS REQUIRED
TO LOOK AT THE STATE'S REBAY
PROJECT WITH A MORE CRITICAL EYE.
THE HOPEFULLY MAKE REFORMS.
CURRENTLY THE BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE THAT THE
PROGRAM WILL HAVE.
IT IS PREDICTED THAT THE PROGRAM
WILL RUN OUT OF MONEY.
OUT OF REBATES BY NEXT MONTH --
CURRENTLY IF WE ARE GOING TO
REACH THE STATE'S GOAL OF FIVE
MILLION ELECTRIC OR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY.
TWENTY THIRTY WE MUST HAVE A
MORE ROBUST PROGRAM ANY MORE
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM SO WE'RE
ASKING THE A. R. B. TO LOOK AT
THAT.
AND MAKE SURE THEY COME BACK
WITH SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON A. B..
TEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
TANG SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED RESERVE AT
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING VOTE ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS NINETEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE AB SEVENTEEN OH THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OH THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN IN THE
UNITED STATES HAVE LEARNING AND
ATTENTION ISSUES.
THE MOST FREQUENT LEARNING ISSUE
DYSLEXIA IS ESTIMATED TO AFFECT
ROUGHLY 15%.
OF THE US POPULATION ACCORDING
TO THE INTERNATIONAL DYSLEXIA
ASSOCIATION MEANING
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA -- IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HAVE LITERACY
RELATED LEARNING DISABILITY
WITHOUT EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION THE
IMPACT OF LEARNING ISSUES CAN BE
SIGNIFICANT AND LONG LASTING FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL AND FOR SOCIETY.
AT LARGE THERE ARE MANY LONG
TERM EFFECTS -- AND CALIFORNIA
HAS BRAIN SCIENTISTS WHO WERE
DOING CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH ON
THE BRAIN AND LEARNING.
AND WE HAVE CLASSROOM TEACHERS
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR ANSWERS AS
THEY STRUGGLE.
BUT WE HAVE NOT HAD A WAY TO
LINK THE TWO AND STRATEGIC AND
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC WAYS UNTIL NOW.
AB SEVENTY NO THREE WILL BRING
TOGETHER CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
BRAIN SCIENCE AND K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION EXPERTS FROM
ACROSS THE US THE UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES. FOR COLLABORATIVE
VENTURE USING EMERGING KNOWLEDGE
TO INFORM THE CREATION OF
INNOVATING TEACHING METHODS.
INNOVATIVE TEACHING MESSAGE FOR
APPLICATION THROUGHOUT THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
AB SEVENTY NOT THREE AS HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE.
TO ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
BURKE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO RESET BREAK TEMPORARILY FOR
DINNER.
UNDER CALL.
WE WITH THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
WILL HAVE DINNER.
IN THE MEMBERS LOUNGE THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS DINNER IS IN
THE RULES ROOM.
WE'LL BE BACK HERE AT
FIVE
THIRTY MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION.
PLEASE JOIN ME ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO WE CAN RETURN TO
BUSINESS
[inaudible]
GOOGLE MEMBERS FLOOR SO WE CAN
RESUME BUSINESS
.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FIVE
SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
FAMILY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCE.
IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIVE SEVENTY
CLARIFIES TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR
SENIORS AND DISABLED PERSONS.
CONSISTENT WITHEXISTING LAW
ANDY FINDS AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
ADDITIONALLY INCLUDE A FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER PROGRAM.
AB FIVE SEVENTY IS A COMPANION
MEASURE TO A CA ONE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INVESTMENT ACT.
IT WILL IT WOULD ONLY BECOME
OPERATIVE OF AC ONE IT.
IS PASSED AND APPROVED BY VOTERS
TO REPEAT MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW TAX EXEMPTIONS I ALSO.
THANK YOU SIR YEAR CURRY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY FOUR NEWS THIRTEEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
THAT WAS WHICH FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AND
ACTUALLY THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION MR CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH A BALANCE BETWEEN.
PERSONAL PRIVACY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY BY CREATING PROCEDURES
AROUND THE USE OF AND RETENTION
OF DATA COLLECTED BY AUTOMATED
LICENSE PLATE READERS OR A. L.
P. R..
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT ALL NON AN ITEMIZED
A. L. P. R. DATA BE DESTROYED
AFTER SIXTY DAYS.
AND IT WOULD FURTHER REQUIRE
THAT A. L. P. R. DATA BE
ANONYMIZED IF IT IS SHARE WITH
AN OUTSIDE ENTITY.
OTHER THAN THE ENTITY TO
GENERATE AT THE DATA RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO RETAIN A L. P. R.
DATA PASSED THE SIXTY DAY.
IF IT IS BEING USED AS EVIDENCE
OR IN FELONY INVESTIGATIONS
WHICH IS IDENTICAL TO WHAT THE
C. X. P. IS CURRENTLY ENTITLED
TO DO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
YOU MISTER CHAO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
SQUIRES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE ICE FORTY TWO NO
SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY THREE AB SIX EIGHTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL SIX EIGHTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ ACTUALLY
THE LEGENDS OF PLAYING THERE AND
SEE THERE ARE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AB SIX EIGHTY ONE
WOULD PROVIDE CALIFORNIA VOTERS
NOTICES BEFORE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARIES.
WITH KEY INFORMATION TO REDUCE
VOTER CONFUSION OVER THE PRIMARY
PROCESS AND ENSURE PROPER ACCESS
TO THE BALLOT.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
PEOPLE WHO REGISTER IS NO PARTY
PREFERENCE THAT ARE USED TO
BEING ABLE TO VOTE IN EVERY
ELECTION BUT WHEN IT COMES TO A
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY THEY HAVE
TO TAKE AN ADDITIONAL STEP. TO
VOTE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
THEY EITHER HAVE TO REQUEST A
DEMOCRATIC BALLOT OR TO VOTE THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY CURRENTLY
THEY HAVE TO RE REGISTER AS
REPUBLICANS.
IN THE LAST ELECTION CYCLE WITH
A LOT OF CONFUSION WHEN PEOPLE
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE WAS
NO PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES ON
THE BALLOT.
WHICH LED -- TO PEOPLE THINKING
THERE SOME SORT OF CONSPIRACY
WHAT WE WANT IS PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO BE NOTIFIED.
BEFORE AN ELECTION A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION
THREE TIMES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
KNOW ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
REQUESTING A MAIL BALLOT THAT
THEY HAVE TO REQUEST THE TAKE
THE ADDITIONAL STEP.
THE REQUESTED DEMOCRATIC BALLOT
OR RE REGISTERS REPUBLICAN.
IT'S AN EASY BILL IT SHOULD BE
NON CONTROVERSIAL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE AT
THIS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR KERBAL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS FOURTEEN ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY FOUR NORTH
THIRTEEN ON THE BILL THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY SOME NUMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY DO ELECTIONS.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU MEANT
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF THE DAY
WE PERCENT BEFORE YOU A BILL
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH OPEN SOURCE
PAPER BALLOT VOTING SYSTEMS.
AND CALIFORNIA WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE SECRETARY STATED MISTER
MATCHING FUNDS FOR THOSE
PARTICIPATING COUNTY SO THEY
COULD SPEED UP THE DEVELOPMENT
CERTIFICATION AND GOVERNANCE AND
DISTRIBUTION.
OF OPEN SOURCE OF VOTING SYSTEMS
HAVING MORE THAN EVER WE HAVE TO
THINK OF A TRANSPARENT WAY TO DO
ELECTIONS THAT HAS PAPER
BALLOTING AS WELL SO WE CAN
TRACK IF THERE'S BEEN ANY.
ANY PROBLEMS WE SEEN IN THE
RECENT ELECTIONS CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT METAL AND FORTY MEDDLING
IN OUR ELECTIONS AND AS WE COME
UP TO A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
THAT WE FOCUS ON HAVING.
OPEN TRANSPARENT ELECTIONS AND
THIS WILL GET US THERE MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU I RISE AS A JOINT AUTHORED
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES ON
SOMETHING THAT.
IS A PRIORITY NOT JUST FOR THE
CITY THAT ARE REPRESENT BUT FOR
OUR STATE AND FOR A COUNTRY.
AS OUR AUTHOR JUST STATED IT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE SANCTITY OF
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THAT
THERE BE TRUST.
IN AND ACCOUNTABLE AND
TRANSPARENT ELECTION SYSTEM THIS
IS A BILL THAT WILL HELP MOVE
FORWARD AND BUILDING THAT TRUST
WITH OPEN SOURCE.
OF VOTING WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR MANY MANY YEARS BUT THE
URGENCY OF IT WAS CERTAINLY
HIGHLIGHTED WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ELECTION
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER MISTER SANTIAGO DE LIKE
CLOTHES.
I THINK YOU MAY SPEAKERS BUCKLEY
ASTRONAUT ABOUT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOSE EYES FORTY NINE
NOONE KNOWS TWELVE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING A FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BY MISTER
BLOOM THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS SOME PEOPLE CALL SEVENTY NINE
BY FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
MISTER BLOOM OU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
REMOVING LAND USE BARRIERS TO
EQUITABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS OF THE STATE.
THESE ARE PLACES WITH GOOD
SCHOOLS JOBS -- ETCETERA IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE DRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS AND
INCREASING CHOICE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
IT'S ALSO CRUCIAL TO MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BY ENSURING THAT
LOW WAGE WORKERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE CLOSE TO
WHERE THEY WORK IN ALL AREAS OF
THE STATE.
HI RESOURCE AREAS MAY OR MAY NOT
BE NEAR EXISTING HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT HOWEVER THEY CAN SUPPORT
GREEN INFILL DEVELOPMENT WHICH
IS CRUCIAL TO SUPPORTING FUTURE
TRANSITING STANCHION.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
NEEDS AND OF COURSE WE ARE AND
REDUCING AUTO DEPENDENCE AND WE
ARE.
I THINK IN A CORD ON THAT AS
WELL THEN WE NEED TO INCREASE
DENSITY AND EXPAND INFILL
DEVELOPMENT IN MORE PARTS OF THE
STATE.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WHICH REFORM THE
RAIN ALLOCATION PROCESS AND
UNDER THAT BILL HIGH RESOURCE
AREAS OF THE STATE.
THAT LACK HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEIR LOWER WAGE WORKFORCE
WILL BE RECEIVING A LARGER SHARE
OF THE RINA THAN THEY HAVE IN
THE PAST.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE DOWN
HELPS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
INCREASED RINA ALLOCATIONS
TRANSLATE INTO ACTUAL HOUSING
UNITS.
THE BILL ENCOURAGES THE
PRODUCTION OF SMALL SCALE MARKET
RATE HOUSING SUCH AS DUPLEXES
TRI PLEX ISN'T FOR PLEXUS IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN MIDDLE
INCOME MIDDLE INCOME AND
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
ALONG MAIN ROADS AND IN OUR
DOWNTOWN AREAS IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR HIGH RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES TO SHOW THAT THEY
ARE PREPARED TO ACCOMMODATE.
THESE TYPES OF HOUSING IN NOT
THE BILL THEN PROVIDES FOR
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS TO
ENSURE THE PROJECTS CAN MOVE
FORWARD TO PROVIDE NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THESE
AREAS.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE CONTINUES
TO BE A WORK IN PROGRESS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND SEE SACK TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL CAN DELIVER
ON ITS PROMISE OF PROVIDING MORE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES.
IN PLACES WHERE LOWER AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES ARE
CURRENTLY PRICED OUT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL OTHER THAN ONE SMALL
CITY.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT WE NEED TO BUILD.
A TO BOTH BUILD MORE HOUSING AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY CITY NOT
JUST SOME CITIES ARE DOING THEIR
FAIR SHARE TO PROVIDE A RANGE OF
HOUSING TYPES.
AT A RANGE OF INCOME LEVELS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
SQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE ICE FORTY ONE NO
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS.
SEVENTY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
WITH UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
LIVING ON OUR STREETS AND AS
MANY AS ONE THIRD OF THEM
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOMELESSNESS AND ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S MOST CRITICAL
CHALLENGE.
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES ARE
ONE CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CONTINUE ON
THESE ARE FACILITIES THAT ARE
LICENSED AND PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
CARE SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE COMPLEX HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THAT REQUIRE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CARE.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO TEAR COLLECT
DATA.
OF FROMTHESE FACILITIES AND
OTHER COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES
PERTAINING TO THE NUMBER OF
THEIR RESIDENTS WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS.
THE DATA WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
THESE TYPES OF COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES SUFFICIENTLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND THEN WOULD BE.
UGH A COMPILED AS A RESULT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX OF THE DATA
THAT WOULD BE COMPILED.
IS URGENTLY NEEDED TO DETERMINE
THE NEED FOR BAD SPACES FOR THE
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL.
NUMBERS WE HAVE SEEN THESE
FACILITIES CLOSING ACROSS THE
STATE AND THERE IS NO
REPLACEMENT HOUSING FOR THEM
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT THE BILL HAS HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
HAVE A THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES
FILE EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY EIGHT
MY FAMILY MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SIX TWENTY
EIGHT GIVES SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS UNPAID JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE TO SEE CRITICAL
SERVICES CURRENTLY ALREADY
AVAILABLE FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
OR STOCKING.
GIVEN THE ME TOO MOVEMENT AND
THE GROWING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DIALOGUE TAKING PLACE ACROSS OUR
NATION IT'S OVERWHELMINGLY CLEAR.
THAT WE MUST DO MORE TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
EXTENDING EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS
TO SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS A COMMON SENSE
MUCH NEEDED STEP TO ENSURE A
SAFE.
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL.
IN THE SAME WAY SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT WOULD ALSO ALLOW IMMEDIATE
FAMILY TO SUPPORT A FAMILY
MEMBER IN OBTAINING THESE
CRITICAL SERVICES IF A LOVED ONE
HAS EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT STALKING AND
OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I KNOW.
IF A FAMILY MEMBER OF MINE WERE
IN THE SITUATION HARASSED.
ASSAULTED STOCKED A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MY MOTHER MY
SISTER ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS.
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPANY THEM OR HAVE
ANOTHER FAMILY MEMBER GO WITH
THEM FOR SUPPORT OR EVEN DRIVE
THEM.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE
TRANSPORTATION KNOWING THAT I
WON'T BE FIRED IF I DO SO I
THINK WE ALL WANT THIS. TO BE
CLEAR THIS.
UNPAID LEAVE IS ONLY AVAILABLE
FOR SERIOUS INCIDENTS THE
SURVIVOR OR THE FAMILY MEMBER
MUST HAVE EXPERIENCED SOMETHING
SO TRAUMATIC.
THAT THEY CONTACTED THE POLICE.
SOUGHT.
PROTECTION OR ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE.
THERE ARE EMPLOYER SAFEGUARDS
AND VERIFICATIONS IN THIS BILL.
IN WHICH A SURVIVOR AND THEIR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER MUST
PROVIDE WRITTEN PROOF FOR THEIR
ABSENCE IF REQUESTED FOR EXAMPLE
A POLICE REPORT A DOCTOR'S NOTE
ACCOUNTS LISTEN OUT.
COURT DOCUMENTS THIS BILL DOES
NOT CREATE ADDITIONAL PAID TIME
OFF IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SURVIVORS AND
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS CAN
ACCESS PAID TIME OFF.
ALREADY OFFERED TO THEM BY THEIR
EMPLOYER OR TAKE UNPAID JOB
PROTECTED TIME TO SEEK THESE
CRITICAL RELIEF SERVICES.
SURVIVORS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN KEEPING THEIR JOB
AND SEEKING RELIEF SERVICES WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN HARASSED STOCKED
ASSAULTED OR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE IT
THIS TAKES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE MR BONTA MOVE THE CALL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY NINE D. THE
ONE WAY WOULD ONE DAY WAITING
PERIOD ON AMENDED BILLS TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TODAY I DON'T WANT TWENTY
NINE A. B. SEVEN FORTY BURKE.
STIR FLORA.
BIGGER MESS WE WE OPPOSE US FOR
ROLL CALL THE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
OUR MOTION MISTER CALDERON.
SECONDED TO HAVE A SECOND THE
MOTION.
MISS WORK SECOND THE MOTION.
TAKES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR DON'T VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MR FLORA ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR A NO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS FIFTEEN THE MOTION.
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE AB
SEVEN FORTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL SEVEN FORTY BY SOME THE
MEMBER BURKE NECKLINE WILDFIRES
PLAYING DIFFERENCE EITHER UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SEVEN FORTY ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHIC WILD
FIRE VICTIMS FUND.
NEARLY THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FAMILIES LOST THEIR HOMES IN
WILD FIRE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND INSURANCE IS
PROVIDED RESOURCES TO REBUILD
AFTER DISASTER STRIKES.
ACCORDING TO VICE PRESIDENT
UNDERWRITING IN OPERATIONS AT
THEIR PLAN THAT THERE HAS BEEN
AN INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING INSURANCE
COVERAGE.
THE AFFAIR PLAN IN FACT IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS THE NUMBER
RESIDENTS COVERED BY FAIR PLAN
POLICIES IN THEIR WILD URBAN
LIFE INTERFACES GROW BY 35%.
AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE LAST TO
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
THE PAIR PLAN DOES NOT HAVE THE
NUMBER FOR THIS YEAR BUT IN SOME
KIND OF WRIST COUNTIES THEY'RE
RUNNING 3100% AHEAD OF LAST YEAR.
ALTHOUGH FAIR PLAN IS AN
INSURANCE POOL ESTABLISHED BY
THE INSURANCE CODE IN STATUTE
MOST INDIVIDUALS.
ON FAIR PLAN PAY HIGHER RATES
AND ARE TYPICALLY UNINSURED
UNDERINSURED.
MEMBERS I'VE HEARD FROM SO MANY
OF YOU ABOUT THE ISSUES OF UNDER
INSURANCE IN NORMAN RULES
AFFECTING YOUR CONSTITUENTS WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEIR PLAN TO
SEE HOW WE CAN INCREASE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. TO ALL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THOSE
LIVING IN HIGH REQUIRE RISK
AREAS.
EXASPERATING THE HARDSHIP OF
WILDFIRE VICTIMS OF THE FACT THE
CATASTROPHIC RELATED WILDFIRE
LAWSUITS CAN LAST BETWEEN SEVEN
TO NINE YEARS AND THE
CONSTRUCTION DEMAND AND PRICE
SURGING ARE RENDERING HOMEOWNERS
UNDER INSURED.
BY NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN AFTER
ENTERIC NEEDS ARE DESTROYED.
AB SEVEN FORTY IS A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE WILD
FIRE INSURANCE AND UTILITY
STABILITY ISSUE.
THIS BILL RE PROTECT UTILITY
REPAIRS FROM OCCURRING RATE
INCREASES AS A RESULT OF
CONTINUED WILDFIRE IT WILL
ENSURE THAT VICTIMS OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ARE
COMPENSATED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND WE ARE DOING ALL OF THIS
WHILE STILL HOLDING UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
WERE NOT THE FIRST DAY TO
UTILIZE A FUN TO DEAL WITH
CATASTROPHES AND SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE FLORIDA HAS UTILIZE
A SIMILAR MODEL WATCHING IN
OTHER STATES ARE ALSO CURRENTLY
EXPLORING FUNDS FOR WELFARE AND
OTHER CATASTROPHES.
VICTIMS IN THE STATE NEED TO BE
MADE WHOLE WE NEED TO DO THIS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE NEED UTILITIES TO CONTINUE TO
MITIGATE AND RECTIFY THEIR
STANDING IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR GOAL WITH THIS BILL IS TO
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
THAT ULTIMATELY PROVIDE
STABILITY REPAIRS.
WILDFIRE VICTIMS IN UTILITIES.
WE HAVE TO HOLD UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE ARE WORKING TO MAKE
VICTIMS FALL IN THIS IS A DIRECT
IN TIMELY SOLUTION FOR THOSE
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRE.
WE WEREN'T PREPARED FOR THE LAST
PASSED CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
LET'S NOT MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN.
MEMBERS THE FACE OF THIS ISSUE
SHOULD BE THOSE OF THE VICTIMS
THE GOAL FIRST AND FOREMOST OF
ANY WILDFIRE FUND SHOULD BE TO
PROTECT ALL CURRENT AND FUTURE
VICTIMS.
NOT THE UTILITIES STABILIZING
UTILITY SHOULD BE A BY PRODUCT
OF WHATEVER WE DO.
I BELIEVE ONLY THEN CAN WE COME
UP WITH AN APPROPRIATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION ONE THAT
WE CAN ALL STAND BEHIND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I THANK
YOU MISS BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
TOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE THIS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
AYE AYES SIXTY NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT AB
ONE THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BLOOM ACTUALLY
DRINKING WATER.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
THIS IS OF COURSE UNCONSCIONABLE
IN THE STATE -- TO SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR THERE HAS
BEEN A BROAD EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS TO DO SO.
AND SHOULD A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND BE CREATED.
AB ONE THIRTY FOUR SEEKS TO
ENSURE THE GOVERNANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE DRESSED IN
THAT FUND.
THE MEASURE OUTLINES A PROCESS
FOR IDENTIFYING FAILED THE
FAILING SYSTEMS AND DEVELOPING
PLANS TO ADDRESS CONTAMINATION
ADDITIONALLY AB ONE THIRTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE WATER BOARD TO
REPORT ON ITS PROGRESS.
AND THE LA -- TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF FUND
EXPENDITURES.
THIS BILL IS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION I ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE A THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE I'LL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE.
MOVE A FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE.
WE'RE GOING OUT
.
MEMBERS OF ANYBODY HAS A VOTE
CHANGE WE CAN ENTERTAIN THOSE AT
THIS TIME.
MISTER DALI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR VOTE CHANGE
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM. ONE SIXTEEN EIGHTY
SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE I TO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY
SOME LABEL SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE I
TO NOT VOTING.
MR VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
YES MADAM.
CHAIR.
I A LIE LINE ITEM FIFTY THREE A.
B..
TWELVE SEVENTEEN NO TO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTEEN NO IT'S NOT VOTING.
SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
MISS SMITH HAS RECOGNIZED.
GOOD THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
BILL AB TEN NINETY TWO I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
S. UNABLE TEN NINETY TWO I TO
KNOW.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MINISTER ACRE -- ON
FILE ONE THIRTY FIVE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX I DO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
AS ABLE THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX I TO
NOT VOTING.
MISS LIMóN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE I TO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE SEVENTY
NINE I TO NOT VOTING.
MISS FUTURE NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB ONE ZERO
SEVEN SIX I TO NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB ONE
ZERO NINE TWO THREE NORTH.
YOUR FIRST ONE SELECT YOUR FIRST
ONE AGAIN SO THAT SHE THE
READING CLERK AND REPEAT.
THE CHANGES ON THE NUMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AS A NAVAL TEN
SEVENTY SIX I IT'S NOT VOTING.
NINE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB ONE
ZERO NINE TWO HI TO NOW.
THE CHANGES ONLY BY REACHING
NORRIS'S ON YOUR TEN NINETY TWO
I TO KNOW.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VOTE CHANGE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY YES TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE IS THE ONLY MEMBER
LACKEY AS AN ELEVEN THIRTY I TO
KNOW [inaudible]
SIR FONG.
YOUR RECOGNIZE UP FILE ONE OH
THREE BILL AB FORTINO -- THREE
VOTE CHANGE I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGES ONLY MEMBER FONG AS
LEGAL FORTINO THREE I TO NOT
VOTING.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB ONE
THREE FIVE I DID NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE AS A MEMBER QUIRK AS
I HAVE A ONE THIRTY FIVE I TO
NOT VOTING.
OF FILE THIRTY EIGHT A. B. NINE
SIX TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGES I MEMBER QUIRK A
SINGLE NINE SIXTY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING.
IS BOERNER HORVATH YES FILE ITEM
FORTY EIGHT AB TEN NINETY TWO
FROM I TO NOT A TO FROM I TO
KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER
FOR THAT A SINGLE TEN NINETY TWO
I TO KNOW.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ZERO CHANGE THANK YOU
I AB -- ONE THIRTY FOUR I TO NOT
VOTING.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY FOUR I TO NOT VOTING
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE NINETEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ --
AGAIN WE
WILL TAKE UP FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR A. B. TWELVE NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE NINETEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. TWELVE
TWELVE NINETEEN IS A TEACHER
CREDENTIALING BILL THE GOOD BILL
TO BRING IN -- MAKING SURE THAT
TEACHERS ARE FULLY QUALIFIED
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE CLASSROOM TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY THREE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
MR
RAMEAU'S YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE?
THANK YOU
AND AB TEN NINETY TO VOTE CHANGE
I TO KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY
TWO I TO KNOW
.
MS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VET CHANGE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER -- AB
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FROM I TO NOT
VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE AS A MEMBER RUBIO
ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN FIFTEEN I
DO NOT VOTING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
LIKE ROOMS BAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN NINETY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT I DON'T KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
A SINGLE TEN NINETY TWO I TO
KNOW
WE ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE VOTE
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE -- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERT ABOUT THIS REQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FORTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES
FIRST WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM THREE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL LEVIN EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY THE COUNTIES.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
A MEASURE WHICH WILL CLARIFY AND
CODIFY NEARLY TWENTY YEAR OLD
COURT DECISION RELATED.
TO OVERSIGHT BOARDS OF SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS.
BOTH THE SHERIFFS AND COUNTY
SUPERVISORS ARE UNIQUE POSITIONS
BOTH INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED OF
COURSE IT IS CREATED SOME
CONFUSION ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS
FAR AS OVERSIGHT.
IT'S BEEN LONG ESTABLISHED SAID
CITY GOVERNMENTS HAVE THESE
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES BUT WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES FAR AS THE
CLARITY WITH COUNTY SHERIFF
OVERSIGHT COMMISSIONS.
A HEARING SACRAMENTO WE HAD A
WELL PUBLICIZED CON CONFLICT
WITH OUR SHERIFF LITERALLY
LOCKING THE KEYS AND SHUTTING
OUT.
THE OVERSIGHT BODY IN LOS
ANGELES THEY ALSO HAD SOME
CONFUSION THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO MANY
RESIDENTS DON'T MISS OUR LIVE IN
CITIES BUT LIVE IN
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY AREAS.
THIS BRINGS ABOUT MORE TRUST IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVING MORE AT
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT IS A
GOOD THING.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE SCORES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE --
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY ONE NEWS TWENTY THIS
MEASURE PASSES
.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
TENDENCY.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES.
IN THE MIDST OF THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY MILLIONS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA TENANTS ARE ONE RENT
INCREASE AWAY FROM BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD FOOD.
HEALTH CARE OR BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND WE'VE HEARD TOO MANY STORIES
OF TENANTS WERE FACING RENT
HIKES OF OVER 15% 25% FIFTY OR A
100%.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SOLUTION.
IT'S NOT RENT CONTROL BUT IT'S
AN ANTI RENT GOUGING POLICY
DESIGNED TO PROTECT MANY OF OUR
STATES FIFTEEN MILLION TENANTS
WHO DO NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL.
AGAINST THE MOST EGREGIOUS RENT
INCREASES WHILE ALLOWING
LANDLORDS TO MAKE A FAIR RETURN
ON INVESTMENT.
WE'VE ENGAGED IN MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION.
AND AT THIS MOMENT I AM PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT AS OF SIX OH
SEVEN PM TONIGHT.
THE COALITION SUPPORTING MY BILL
AND THE JUST BECAUSE BILL
AUTHORED BY OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
CONCORD IN OAKLAND.
HAVE REACHED AN AGREEMENT ON
AMENDMENTS TO BOTH BILLS THAT WE
WILL BE DRAFTING AND AMENDING IN
THE SENATE.
FLORAL ART IS BEING CIRCULATED
TO YOU AS WE SPEAK BUT I WANT TO
READ THE FOR DEAL POINTS OF
AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN OUR COALITION IN THE
REALTORS ON OUR BILL.
FIRST THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
RENT CAP OF 7%.
PLUS REGIONAL CPI WHICH IS UP
FROM CPI PLUS 5%.
THE BILL WOULD EXEMPT SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS WITH TEN OR
FEWER SINGLE FAMILY DETACHED
HOMES.
IT WOULD ESTABLISH A SUNSET DATE
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHICH IS
A THREE YEAR SUNSET DATE.
AND WOULD CLEAN UP LANGUAGE ON
VACANCY TO CONTROL OR MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WONDER ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE CPI PLUS
SOME PERCENT CAP.
WITH AN ANNUAL AVERAGE CPI
INCREASE OF TWO AND A HALF
PERCENT THE RENT GOUGING CAP
WOULD AVERAGE BETWEEN NINE AND A
HALF AND 10%.
IT'S BASED ON THE NUMBER OF DATA
POINTS FIRST FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
YEARS STATE LAWS PROHIBITED
PRICE GOUGING ABOVE 10% AFTER AN
EMERGENCY OR NATURAL DISASTER.
SECONDLY THIS IS A PRECEDENT FOR
STATEWIDE ANTI RENT GOUGING
MEASURES SET JUST EARLIER THIS
YEAR IN OREGON.
THIRD FEDERAL DATA SHOWS THAT
THIS LEVEL CPI PLUS 7% IS ON
AVERAGE A HUNDRED AND 50% HIGHER
THAN THE ANNUAL MEDIAN RENT
INCREASE IN OUR STATE'S LARGEST
REGIONS.
AS SUCH WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
A LEVEL TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO
CALIFORNIA RENTERS SO THAT THEY
WON'T RECEIVE AN EXORBITANT RENT
INCREASE WHILE ALLOWING PROPERTY
OWNERS TO MAKE A HEALTHY RETURN
ON THEIR INVESTMENT.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS AND RESPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU MISS WORKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WHEN I GOT ELECTED ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS I DID IN JANUARY AS
I DID A LISTING CHORE -- AT ALL
THAT HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS OF MY
DISTRICT NOT ALL OF THEM THERE
ARE MANY BUT I WENT TO A COUPLE
I WENT TO ONE IN BERKELEY. ONE
AND OPEN AND ONE IN RICHMOND.
AND I TALKED TO A LOT OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THESE ARE JUST HEART
BREAKING STORIES WHEN YOU TALK
TO FOLKS WHO ARE SLEEPING
OUTSIDE EVERY NIGHT.
AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS TO THE
THE HOMELESSNESS COUNTS JUST
CAME BACK IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WE'VE WE'VE SEEN A 43% INCREASE
IN HOMELESSNESS.
AND I'M SURE THAT'S REFLECTED IN
MANY OF YOUR DISTRICTS AS WELL.
THE DATA ALSO SHOWS THAT DATA
SHOWS THAT OVER HALF OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ECONOMICALLY
DISPLACED.
WE ALL BELIEVE.
THAT WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS.
AND I KNOW THAT PART OF THAT
SOLUTION IS BUILDING MORE HOMES
AND I'VE BEEN A PROPONENT OF A
LOT OF THE PRODUCTION
LEGISLATION I'M CHAMPING
PRODUCTION WITH THIS LEGISLATION
MYSELF.
THE SOLUTION ALSO WAS GUARDING
AGAINST DISPLACEMENT.
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON THIS BODY
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO STOP THIS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND THAT'S
WHY MEASURES LIKE THIS THIS IS A
MODERATE.
COMMONSENSE BILL AND IS A CO
AUTHOR I'VE SPENT TIME WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO WHO
WAS.
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY ACROSS.
THE SPECTRUM ON THE SAT DOWN
WITH ALL PARTIES TO NEGOTIATE A
DEAL THAT WE CAN ALL BELIEVE AND
WE CAN ALL SUPPORT.
THIS HAS A SUNSET IT'S ONLY FOR
THREE YEARS.
LANDLORDS CAN STILL INCREASED
10% A YEAR OR SO IF THEY SO
CHOOSE AND I'VE TALKED TO ALSO A
LOT OF MOM AND POP LANDLORDS IN
MY DISTRICT AND I KNOW THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE WHO THEY DON'T.
HAVE PENSIONS ARE RETIREMENTS
ARE FOR ON CASE.
THEY OWN A HOUSE THAT THEY RENT
OUT OR UNIT OR TWO THAT THEY
RENT OUT AND THAT'S THEIR INCOME
THAT'S A RETIREMENT INCOME.
THEY CAN STILL INCREASE RENTS
EVERY SINGLE YEAR IT'S A VERY
MODERATE MEASURE THAT WILL GUARD
AGAINST SOME OF THE MORE
EGREGIOUS PRACTICES THAT WERE
SAYING.
THAT 203-040-5060 PERCENT
INCREASES THAT WERE SAYING IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT IS CAUSING
THE DISPLACEMENT THAT WE SEE.
SO I'M PROUD TO CALL FOR THIS
BILL.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS MISS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
THAT OBJECTION.
WHAT IS RENT CONTROL?
RENT CONTROL IS WHAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE IN SOME CITIES IN OUR
STATE THAT.
HOLD RENT TO ASK OR BELOW
INFLATION THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IN THIS BILL IS HOW WE ADDRESS
RENT GOUGING SO.
IF YOU'RE AT CPI PLUS 7% YOU
HAVE AN ABILITY TO MAKE A
HEALTHY RETURN IF YOU ASK FOLKS
FROM THE INDUSTRY -- BUT YOU'RE
ALSO ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR PREVENT
SOME OF THE MORE EXORBITANT RENT
INCREASES AND PROVIDE SOME
PREDICTABILITY TO TENANTS. TWO
VERY DIFFERENT ANSWERS I THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO ON MY OWN TIME -- RENT
CONTROL IS THE GOVERNMENT
CONTROLLING AND REGULATING RENT.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
YOU CAN SAY IT'S NOT RENT
CONTROL ALL DAY LONG BUT IT IS
AND YOU KNOW IT IS.
AND WHEN YOU PUT RENT CONTROL.
IN THE PLACE THEN.
YOU THIS IS A DISINCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO BUILD.
AND WHAT WE NEED IS TO BELT.
EVERYBODY IN HERE HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE HOMELESS
CRISIS OH MY GOD IT'S SO
TERRIBLE WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
AND THEN WE COME UP WITH THIS.
THIS DOES NOT ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO BILL.
YOU'RE GOING TO DECREASE THE
NUMBER OF UNITS AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE THAT IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED.
THIS IS RENT CONTROL I DON'T
CARE HOW YOU SAY IT I DON'T CARE
HOW YOU SPEND IT THIS IS RENT
CONTROL AND YOU KNOW AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HARM.
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT NEED THE
HELP THE MOST.
I WOULD URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS MENDEZ MISS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM OF
BEING REALLY CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS
BILL I AM GOING TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE I RENT INVOLVED IN PARK
I'VE BEEN IN MY PLACE. FOR NINE
YEARS NOW MY RENTS STARTED AT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
MY RENT NOW IS SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH I DID THE MATH
AT JUST THE BASIC 5%.
IF THAT RENT CONTROL OR THE 5%
WAS IN PLACE -- MY A RATE WOULD
BE AT ALMOST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH NOW.
IF THE MY LANDLADY DECIDED TO
INCREASE MY RENT 5% NOW THERE
ARE SOME REPUTABLE -- LAND LORDS
THAT ARE NOT GOING -- TO
INCREASED RENT BUT I ASTOR.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF SHE -- WAS
NOW ABLE TO DO 5% AND SHE SAYS I
WOULD HAVE TO RAISE IT 5%
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT
BEHIND BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I
WON'T BE ABLE TO RAISE IT LATER.
SO MY CONCERN FOR MY COMMUNITY
IS THAT YES RIGHT NOW YOU'RE
CAPPING AT A 5% FOR THOSE.
ARE A REPUTABLE -- AND MAINLY
THE HOUSE PRICE GOUGING IS
REALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO LA SAN
JOSE THE REALLY HIGH PRICE AREAS
IN MY COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME BITE IF.
THEY HAVE A LICENSE NOW TO RAISE
THE RENT 5% THEY WILL BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT
BEHIND AND SO MY CONCERN IS THAT
SOME OF MY FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
PRICED OUT.
OF THEIR HOMES THERE RENTALS IN
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WHICH REALLY
IS GOING TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF FOLKS THAT DON'T HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO I THINK
THAT WE ARE.
REALLY DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OF
LOWER INCOME I UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES IN SANTA MONICA SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN JOSE.
BUT IN MY COMMUNITY.
IT IS NOT THE CASE SO I AM
REALLY CAUTIOUS ABOUT HOW WE
VOTE TODAY BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
GOING TO IT.
OF REALLY PRICE OUR FOLKS LOW
INCOME FOLKS I DON'T HOUSING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IN FIVE
YEARS THEY WON'T BE ABLE.
TO AFFORD OF 5% INCREASE EVERY
YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
RUBIO.
MR LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION TODAY
THIS IS A COMPROMISE AND I I
HAVE SO MUCH RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHORS TO WORK SO HARD TO GET
TO THE POINT THAT WERE AT I WISH
I COULD SAY THAT THIS IS THE
DEAL.
THAT WE NEED BUT THIS IS A
COMPROMISE THAT WE NEED WE HAVE
HEARD THE WORD COMMUNITY SO MUCH
TODAY.
AND ONE THING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
AS THE ECONOMY HAS GOTTEN SO HOT
FOR SO FEW IN CALIFORNIA THAT
PRICES HAVE JUST GOTTEN
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH FOR PEOPLE.
AND THE RENT HAS GONE UP WITH
THAT AND WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE
PRICED OUT OF THE HOMES AND OUT
OF THE APARTMENT THAT THEY LIVED
IN FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THE MIGRATION OF
PEOPLE FROM THE COASTAL BAY AREA
FOR EXAMPLE OR THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA INLAND AS THEY'RE
LOOKING TO FIND A PLACE THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD.
TAKING THEIR CHILDREN OUT OF
SCHOOL LEAVING THE WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY HAVE BEEN A
PART OF AND THIS BILL IS A IS AN
IMPORTANT PART.
ABOUT KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES
HOLE AND RECOGNIZING THAT IN
THIS WHITE HOT ECONOMY THAT WE
ARE IN THAT WE CAN NOT.
I OUT OF THEIR HOMES BECAUSE OF
SKY HIGH RENT INCREASES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER CHIU YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER LET ME JUST MAKE A FEW
QUICK POINTS AND RESPONSE TO THE
DISCUSSION AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
EVERYONE'S ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CPI PLUS 7% WHICH IS CLOSE
TO EFFECTIVELY 10%.
SO A SMALL PROPERTY OWNER
SOMEONE OWNS RENT CAN'T OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS POTENTIALLY
REYES RENT.
50%.
AS WE DISCUSSED AS WITH MANY
MEMBERS AND RENTAL HOUSING WORLD
THAT IS ADEQUATE ROOM TO MAKE
SURE YOU GET PROFIT BUT PROVIDE
SOME PREDICTABILITY.
TEAR TENANTS SECONDLY PRICE
GOUGING IS HAPPENING NOT JUST IN
URBAN AREAS IT IS HAPPENING ALL
OVER THE STATE.
AND RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE
URBAN PARTS THE STATE COASTAL
PARTS THE STATE INLAND PARTS THE
STATE -- I KNOW THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW WE
DIDN'T CONSIDER INCENTIVES TO
BUILD AND THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT
THE CASE ONE ASPECT OF THIS BILL
THAT WE DID NOT TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE IT WAS ALREADY EMBEDDED
IN THE BILL.
WHICH WE CARVE OUT A TEN YEAR
EXEMPTION FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
TO ADDRESS THAT VERY POINT AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES FOR THEIR
SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE ONE RENT
INCREASE AWAY FROM BEING FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES OF DECADES.
THEY ARE OUR NEIGHBORS THERE ARE
CO WORKERS THEY ARE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
THE OUR GRANDPARENTS.
JUST THIS WEEK WE'VE ALL BEEN
READING.
IN THE LA TIMES A STORY OF A ONE
HUNDRED AND TWO YEAR OLD WOMAN
WHO IS BEING FORCED EVER HOMES.
WE CAN DO BETTER IN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
VOTE.
AND ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE
-- ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY RESERVE AT THIS REQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESIRE TO VOTE.
SCORES
FORTY ONE VOTERS ARE
ABOUT THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS
REQUIRES
FORTY ONE QUIRK
WORKLOAD BUT ICE FORTY THREE
KNOWS TWENTY EIGHT THIS MEASURE
PASSES
WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE ARE MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS ONE
FIFTY THROUGH ONE FIFTY FIVE
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY
SIX BY SELLING MEMBERS MET
RELATIVE TO ADVANCE PLACEMENT
DAY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
NINE NEWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED?
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AS IN THE CURRENT VERSION SIXTY
FIVE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY SIX I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY TWO I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY I SIXTY NINE IS HERE
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TOMORROW THURSDAY MAY THIRTIETH
WE ARE IN SESSION AND NINE AM
MEMBERS THAT TO CHANGE WE'RE IN
SESSION TOMORROW AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN DAHLE MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY ANDMEMBERS WE HAVE A BILL
LONG CALL.
WE CANNOT INTERN [inaudible]
AND WE ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL AND FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE A.
B. SIX TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
SQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE IT
THIS IS AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
BONTA.
CHOIRS FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE ALL YOU DESERVE IT
THIS REQUIRES
.
FORTY ONE CLOSE THE ROLE NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION.
CLOSER ON TIE VOTE ICE THIRTY
SIX KNOWS.
FOURTEEN MR BONTA NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON.
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY THIRTIETH AT
NINE AM.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED
.
VOTE CHANGE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO ALL RIGHT TO KNOW QUIRK
SILVA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO I TO KNOW